e
[Music]
just waiting to get it all cool from the
back welcome everybody thank you for
coming to this uh panel uh I think oh
yeah were you going to play the thing
okay yeah cool we can just get on with
it wo uh thank you for coming to this
panel uh I think it's one of those areas
of uh Tech and games enthusiasm where
you know people uh really sort of have
certain different passions and lots of
different ideas and I'm hoping that sort
of through this session we'll be able to
sort of talk about a lot of this stuff
in both um ways that the specific people
on the panel can kind of really share
their own passions as well as talk about
that big picture of how you can kind of
do this stuff um really well if you're
getting into it uh one thing that I kind
of really think is a great point to make
at the start is you know people can
collect anything they want there is zero
judgment on people choosing to just
collect cool stuff that they really love
but then there are people who want to
work out now sometimes I want to think
about this in terms of might this be
valuable one day might this be something
that is worth keeping for actual reasons
other than you like it and some people
just make that excuse in their head this
might be worth something one day so you
know I'll just keep it around um and
then of course the garage fills up and
and things get a little out of control
um so hopefully our panelists can help
you kind of clear up a lot of that
thinking and really get on top of
building a collection that you can be
both proud of and potentially know it's
going to make you some money one day if
you really pick the right things so can
we please welcome I thought I'll
introduce the three panelists and then
we'll give them all a big round of
applause at the very end please welcome
Stacy Bor Alex BOS and no n
[Applause]
Wheatley now I thought a good kind of
intro line for this uh for each of you
is I think a really sort of simple
question on why do you love collecting
old games and hardware and we'll start
with you Stacy well I'm old myself so
it's a it's a good thing I grew up in
the times where there was arcades and
things like that all around the place so
I grew up playing video games and
pinball machines just like that so now
part of a group we in retro we we like
to go around and set up retro stuff for
for people around the country so yeah
it's it's just it's just the Nostalgia
Factor mostly I'm not really a massive
collector um I've got a whole variety of
things I haven't got a really focused
collection like something other the guys
um but I just like to have a bunch of
gear hardware and software that I can
just you know we can get out there and
yeah show the people off it's that's the
main thing having fun with friends and
and bringing joy to people cool Alex I
was going to say being an adult is hard
so Nostalgia for me it just takes me
back to um you know a time when he was
Carefree friends having fun um and also
the community I really really love the
community of um collectors especially
for you know any sort of games or any
sort of Hardware or accessories
magazines whatever people collect and
you always find yourself actually
talking more about it than actually
playing so and that's that's the best
part really but Nostalgia for me is
number one just takes me back to a great
fun time cool no um I've got to say for
me as well it's a lot of nostalgia
growing up in that sort of period like
back the 70s and the 80s with the
arcades ruled and the N everything
coming out in that period I always sort
of loved the games back then and now
I've been collecting for about 20 years
now and and I suppose in addition to
what you know both of you guys have said
there's also a bit of a historic thing
and educational thing as well a lot of
my friends have kids now and they you
know play on PS4s and Xbox Ones and
things like that then they see like an
old nest or a um CER Vision or a
television something like that and they
go what the hell is that and having
those set up for them to show them and
understand that where gaming has come
from and how it's progressed from its
Origins for it today is also part of the
reason I collect as
well cool um I also I always forget to
do this I'm Sheamus
burn um I work for CET the big
Technology News website and we're part
of the same sort of Gamespot family so
that's why I'm involved with this but I
also love old things I will flag I still
have my original color computer to uh
from the 1980s where I kind of first
learned some basic coding uh and I
remember running out of space on data
cassettes because I tried to make like
this Grand Opus RPG text RPG thing and
then yeah 64k it's never enough um
the next big question I think if we're
going to try to drill into some of these
ideas about sort of value in a sense um
is and Alex I might kind of throw this
to you first is you know what do you
feel like helps to make a collectible
thing have real value in a I guess uh
you know in that sense of I guess a lot
of people maybe Desiring it and want to
get their hands on it and therefore it
becomes something of value absolutely
it's um the Lo production runs so for
instance at tar Jaguar any anyone that
actually checks out eBay for instance
for AAR Jaguar software they'll find um
that yeah it's not cheap so
unfortunately yeah to actually find that
sort of stuff you're going to have to
pay for it um but you know Nintendo SE
are always very very popular so you can
probably pick those up for a good price
but anything that's a little bit more
exotic where it didn't really succeed
back in the day um unfortunately prices
tend to go up and condition as well I
mean that's a really interesting point
isn't it that actually quite often it's
things that it wasn't the big hit of the
time was it absolutely Virtual Boy
another example I mean people laughed at
it back in the 90s and look at it now
people want one to just get a headache I
don't want to play it I just want to
look at
it um how about you n any of your sort
of thoughts I know like NL works over at
Bethesda as kind of a community manager
but actually while the other two guys
are kind of the Retro experts no's just
a genuine lover of collecting stuff so
he's kind of more like the rest of us
but he takes it quite seriously thought
that was my
job
um I suppose from cable sense like apart
from you obviously the Rarity factor and
know being exclusive to different
regions different countries I suppose
also what makes it unique as well so if
you've got something signed by a
developer who's you know unfortunately
passed away or something that was a
prototype I've quite forun I've got a
couple of actually now only one uh
prototype disc uh for resistance for men
so it's not exactly an old game but
still not something you'd have read
available anywhere else um I would say
yeah there's a few OB these things so
you can get the collector editions which
are supposedly rare but not always as
rare as you'd like them to be but yeah
in my mind it's going to be something
that makes it unique and stand out so
not just a region but also yeah
potentially something that's been signed
or something that's been hand delivered
from like um looking for so the
Microsoft original Xbox consoles they
had the internal console signed by the
team few of those ever got out into the
market a couple have that I've seen and
now hands of collectors those things are
ultra rare insanely rare but they're not
very common obviously from
s
um but yeah that sort of thing to me is
what makes it really cool and really
rare and very very very
valuable um so how about the question of
like you know I guess I I think a big
part of the Rarity issues and things
like that is um restoration preservation
of old things I guess uh you know seeing
how you talk about these Community side
of it like how important is that so
Stacy maybe you can kind of start this
one but um how critical is that that
side of um the love of these things and
trying to help keep them around I guess
yeah it's pretty important I think um
the the good thing about stuff that was
made back in the 80s and 90s is it's
built super well so I had Commodore 128
sitting in the cupboard for 20 years you
pull them out turn them on and they're
fine it's just the way that they made
those things like you know won't talk
about too much but you know the modern
consoles have had their fair share of
problems in you know the first couple of
years because they the man the way
manufacturing's changed and times is is
is Big so um yeah anything old is is
they're well made but they still have
opportunity to fail and and finding
spare parts is not easy but yeah being
able to keep that stuff in good
condition is really important both both
by looks and by actually working because
you want to use these things so um yeah
definitely I'm I'm pretty keen on
getting my hands dirty and then fixing
things like joysticks and uh consoles
that are broken so sort of got a bit of
a background in electronics and stuff so
cool um I'm happy to do that uh but yeah
it's it's it's definitely critical
because yeah they're already rare a lot
of the time and so they start to fail
then yeah you can't just throw them out
you have to really try to keep them keep
them running so it's definitely an
important thing there's also a cost
Point too I mean normally collecting ret
games or consoles is can can can be
quite expensive so if you had to repair
them yourself you can actually save a
bit of cash like last year a megathon
grand final that was actually using one
of my Super Nintendos and now the Super
Nintendo I found on a thrower pile the
front of somebody's house got it home
pulled it apart cleaned it up fixed it a
couple of little so like a couple little
brakes inside and it's gone from
literally going to the tip to now being
on stage last year for the meone Grand
Final which I thought you know was a bit
of a proud moment for me I got to be
honest but yeah have any of you guys
worked with any I know like obviously
this stuff is even becoming more
important to like Museum Collections and
things that they're realizing you know
this is is an important part of sort of
cultural history as well so I don't know
have you guys had or you know been
involved with any of those sorts of
programs not
yet we've run a few we've run a few
small museums ourselves but yeah nothing
nothing with the sort of big places yet
but I mean was uh Pedro did Pedro get
involved with yeah when yeah had been
some some of some of the people in our
groups have sort of done that and done
talks and and presented some of their
really rare items from Nintendo we also
have events like packs um where we hope
rather than emulate people can come in
and actually have a go on the actual
room machines in the real games and see
how they played and I love seeing people
pick up a joystick and one button what
what's going on so some of the stuff
we've got in our Museum this year is
pretty rare as well hav seen any of it
so so I have to say blew my mind
actually to pop down there the other day
and see uh the like endless Runner
cannonbal that had been ported back to
com 64 down there running um and I I
double check looking it up thinking
someone like done something dodgy here
and like put something inside this4 to
make it look like like no no it's it's
legit yeah um so it's it's still amazing
to see that people even will go back and
code for some of this stuff as well oh
there's definitely there's a lot of
there's a lot of activity still going on
like there are new you new games coming
out or remasters of old games so it's
there still an active scene especially
in Europe I guess but actually um last
weekend I was up in Brisbane I met a
gentleman who's still writing games for
6 4 putting them on to the old 5 and a/4
in FL sorry 5 and a half 5 and a/4 I
forgot 5 and4 in floppy discs um and I
thought that was absolutely amazing that
you know 2016 a GU is writing games for
a comro 64 I thought that was
outstanding actually it's funny because
they do actually release games on cart
disc and cassette and for some bizarre
reason I always go for the cassette was
back in the day there was no way G for
you don't actually load them off the
cassette anymore do you doesn't happen I
when I want to hit up Nostalgia I do
watch TV and then it might not load and
then I got to get the screwdriver and
change
head want to look at like uh rather than
just the hardware itself thinking about
that kind of wider Market of uh
accessories and books I remember having
one of those you know how to beat
Pac-Man type books from the 80s I know I
know it's disappeared long gone but um
you know those kinds of things and like
magazines uh and then the sort of toys
of different times um yeah where does
all of that sort of stuff fit in with
with that larger idea of you know of
this sort of retro collecting and
stuff and value which is regards retr
collecting in general um I guess yeah on
the value side as well you know and
we'll start to kind of really dig into
some sort of value questions shortly but
um you know maybe are any of those
categories the particularly ones that
stand out or you know are there any of
those things where it's like well it it
doesn't really ever become something or
is it again just all about if you know
the right things it's going to be worth
something a lot of the magazines have
got pretty rare I think they are
especially the UK ones from the 80s so
like zap 64 CM VG um your Com or your
computer your comod all um aega format
um yeah so people would have thrown
those out years and years ago oh you can
get them on PDF but there's nothing you
know having magazine hands are actually
flicking and doggies and looking at the
ads and and plan in terms of our
condition
that's get magazines and condition
absolutely and back and back then you
actually you would get a coupon and send
through and um I know Activision had
patches so you'd actually get a patch
yeah of course yeah and the Atari link
now for some reason in France there was
a lot of pins made for amstrad and atar
links yeah so if you have a look they're
actually starting to rise up in value
it's I was going mention the pins
actually looking on eBay recently the
pins and patches and they just en more
more expensive and I was never into
those things but oh my God it's just
consing my time I just and I blame this
guy
here on the magazines there's also those
milto um like those milto is Milestone
issues too like you know issue 150 100
stuff like that even Comics exactly yeah
like also the US versions like Nintendo
power and stuff like that as well you
see those like could be like a dollar a
piece then you get that sort of
Milestone Edition and it's like you know
20 bucks 30 bucks or things it's like
wow he won't be getting a house deposit
with any of these things but you
know F yeah um now here's kind of where
we I want to start digging into you know
some of your secrets will share with the
room and therefore make it harder for
you to track things down in future um
but you know where where do you go
hunting for hidden Gems or I guess maybe
it's the two sides where's the really
easy starting place for people who maybe
are just starting to kind of think about
where where you go and then uh where is
some of those here clever places that
you then go
digging oh to the obvious one we
starting out um stting obviously the E
want is eBay where that's also probably
the evilest one as well because you can
find occasion Like Dimes in the rough
that have been either mlist or people
aren't you know trying to FL them for an
astronomical price um so you can get
your red gem on there occasionally for a
good price otherwise for myself
personally it's a matter of going around
to the markets and garage sales and
things like that but the problem is you
get a lot of resellers and other people
out there now doing the same thing so
unless you're up literally at the
Cracker Dawn and down to the markets or
going the garage s routs around around
where you live it becomes quite hard the
one little rare gem that I've got that
will share because actually who's from
Sydney damn
it buer all right I tracked now I'm
finished it's like going to like op
shops and things like that and you
occasionally like dig through um it's
funny like cassette bins like you'll see
people have cassettes in there they'll
be like just thr there I found like
bunch of con 64 cassettes in there and
um amstrad CP uh CP CPC good set in
those as well uh even old CDs you find
like the occasional random game disc
just stuffed on a shelf of like the
classic you know lovely great 80s and 7s
'90s hits and you I found a um Sega CD
and I found um actually what was that
one that was um Road Rush Sega CD and um
I can't feel the one now I found
recently 3DO disc uh NE for Speed so I
was quite happy about that sorry that's
right I'll go next yeah um gum tree is
an obvious one um especially the you be
surprised any people actually give away
um stuff on on G tree so just make sure
you do your local area and put in about
25k yeah radius and yeah you pick up all
sorts of stuff um a look markets as well
uh M markets in jalong or new town I
think or Newton um is a great one I if
you guys have actually been there uh
some prices are a little bit high but uh
if you actually have a look they do have
some reasonably good good things there
um ice comic in the city on Queen Street
upstairs I've actually got retro stuff
up there see people nodding so that
that's good um what else yeah op shops
hard waste collections guys so when
you're driving I mean yeah please take
care when you're driving but when you
see a hard waste uh pull over and have a
good look and hopefully if it hasn't
rained be able to pick something up be
careful turning things on
after yeah look and I actually found a
Dreamcast kiosk oh wow on the side of
the road right um and I actually did a
double take I was driving down Mountain
I on the road in money ponds and there
it was just sitting there and I thought
no dve around came back and I had my dad
in my car and uh yeah we just had to you
know hul across three lanes and um put
in the back of the golf my dad my dad
holding it down with the actual hatch
open and driving 2ks an hour to get at
home are there any police in the
CR have I say Andel and that and that's
the last time I ever saw my father the
side the road oh jeez yeah now that was
um yeah that was that was probably the
coolest thing I ever found so there is
always yeah stuff out so maybe just look
at you know on the um
Council um sites see when their hardw
collection Zone and go around have a
look um uh what other ones look eBay
eBay is evil right well but I actually
probably get 95% of my things off eBay
but that's because I'm on it constantly
and I've got alarms alerts all the time
so if you're only checking once a week
you're not going to find anything if
you're checking three or four times a
day for mult you know for all over the
world you'll definitely find something
it's also it's also a really good place
to do research on so you can ab things
that have sold it's got great tools you
can do completed sold listing so you can
actually have a look what things go for
right and you'll see a variety of prices
and whatnot and um look if you've got a
price in mind just stick with it don't
something will always come up right so
um unfortunately except for the T Jaguar
can you like dig into that a little bit
more about how you'd use those search
tools really effectively I think some
people do sort of think well yeah I'll
go and have a you know do a quick search
and look and go okay there's an idea but
that you can kind of really set up that
whole alert system really effectively
yeah yeah you can actually so um yeah I
just I'm always constantly on my um on
my iPhone just checking things so um you
know at work if I'm going on a break
coffee break I'll check if I'm in the
bathroom I'll check unfortunately I do
that um are there any of Coles in the
crowd they are they are so I'll be out
of a job on Monday so that's
right no I do do real work too um yeah
now look it's uh it's it's actually
quite quite cool to see when you
actually do worldwide search and you see
the actual price variation across from
Europe us and and obviously Australia
and it's usually the shipping that kills
it so um yeah always consider shipping
as B of the cost of your item absolutely
absolutely and with the fall with the
fall of our dollar it's not as lucrative
as it used to be um but look Japan sorry
the last one I've got the last if is um
the Yahoo Japan auctions that you can't
buy direct from there but you can get a
proxy Y and you'll be able to pick up
some really great items and the Japanese
the way they list their items amazing
they say oh it's it's graded as a c but
it's absolutely premium conditioned I've
bought things that have been labeled
junk and they're better than it's like
might as well come in the brand new in
the box
ridiculous uh you haven't told us any of
I haven't I mean these guys have come
through pretty much so yeah online
various options you op shops and things
but the these these things take time I
haven't got much time so um but yeah if
I if I had the time to run around all
the garage sales and everything I'd be
pretty happy um uh one one other thing I
guess is is markets and and fairs
sometimes they've got things for sale so
you I was I was lucky we went to like an
Easter Fair out the out in the sticks
and you I found a couple of sort of
Tommy
handheld and just like five 10 bucks
each and the Box everything
so like yeah how much are these so
much yeah no so so just keep your eyes
open everywhere wherever there's things
for sale there could be retro games for
sale so so you just got to keep your
eyes open and and do your research and
know what you want is is a good St I
don't do that so I just get whatever
whatever's available but if you have a
good idea of what you want you're
probably better off so so I'm guessing
you guys might have this well but also
your friends are a great source things
like that like they're out
somewhere I get messages on weekends and
even during the week occasionally from
friends oh spoted this would you like it
send me a photo and like it's a like a
Repro console I know I'm fine with that
thank you but occasionally I've seen
people send me a actually a little while
ago friend of mine sent me a photo of a
box with a PlayStation 2 and I went oh
what's okay this the PS2 opened up and
there's like 20 games Inside the Box
want 20 bucks I went yes please that'd
be fantastic thank you so
yes sorry I know there was two more I
actually just thought of um Aussie
arcade as well and also Facebook groups
there's a lot of close Facebook groups
that yeah people get truck photos up
there and people just negotiate from
there so if you don't want to hit up
eBay just fair enough um yeah they're
also available resource if you want to
stick to local as well yeah that's a
good one actually my wife works in the
Antiques industry um which is part of
where my sort of interest in having this
sort of panel came from was she's always
watching um a lot of and Facebook groups
has become a really big thing but now
then she sort of goes is this thing
interesting yeah she'll show me if she
some random Tech thing um and quite
often it's just somebody getting rid of
their old Skylanders
collection everybody seems to
be um that said maybe they'll become
withth something so yeah maybe let's
yeah have a think about some of the
newer things you know what based on all
your knowledge about collecting older
stuff you know now when people are just
buying really cool newer things what are
some of the things you feel like are
Hallmarks that will help to have
something become actually you know worth
something in the
future uh the Ness classic
Mini which is already sold out so I
guarantee um they'll be on eBay going at
probably four times the price that that
they would have been at eBay game so
sorry go wow yeah so yeah that one's a
classic um stra away sorry who's
actually preed one of those by the
way there we go make a lot of
money he's St so I'm willing to pay
anything um anything from Nintendo
that's got Zelda or Pokémon on it um
they do quite well too
so you got a 3DS there Zelda 3DS yeah I
was going to say I got my I get that
one there we go so I should stop playing
it yeah probably put get the box and you
got the star fame or the plastic things
that they come in different probably
not you
monster
I reckon it's pretty hard like you we
can all say that this is going to be
expensive but who knows if we really
knew we'd be swimming around in scre
McDuck style money bin so we don't
really know but we know I think here's
like a good example right now that's you
know that came up recently uh you know
sort of there was the whole like the
Disney Infinity sort of games line and
then they kind of pulled the plug
recently and now there's sort of lots of
these figures sitting unloved on store
shelves but they're kind of cool I know
some people have you know they've loved
to build out those collections mentioned
kind of Skylanders before everyone sort
of tipping them at the moment it seems
because they're deciding they've had
enough of it but then you know did those
sorts of things you have that potential
where because something actually on that
Disney side got abandoned as a product
line and people went oh well no point
keeping these that they do then get that
Rarity because people threw them all
away I wouldn't be surprised if in in 10
years or something they come back and
you know people got them box box still
because they've got that license behind
them so you know all the all the and
Star Wars stuff that's there I was about
they add the Star Wars and all the other
collectors as well but you know a lot of
people be thinking that people be
keeping these you four five things that
they' bought from Kmart or whatever so
it all depends it's just it's it's a
market like any other it's it's Rarity
and you know quality these things all
come into end you need to people to want
to buy them until that until those three
things come together the money isn't
there so and the four fin is time I
suppose too on that because like you
could say it's like exclusive now but
know wait 20 years and it might be like
you know every other person at a box
version has been taught him by their
child or damaged or whatever that you've
got that one pristine Mass produce
Skylands fig just use a Skyland as
example um that you know now nobody
wanted but in the future someone who
crazed for it or has made some sort of
resurgence would want and pay you know
1,200 bucks for or something like that
you know just storing all these things
is yeah that's a challenge yeah yeah I
mean a good point they even had like the
colored bases and stuff so you can know
what was a series one what was a series
two all that sort of business uh I'm
hoping this is an obvious question um
but maybe it isn't uh if something says
Collector's Edition on the box does that
mean it will ever be worth
anything maybe absolutely
not it's worth more money to the
retailer absolutely but look Oregan
limited edition runs definitely anything
that's got collectors or whatever on it
um it may be with with you know as time
the fact that things are made you know
in the hundreds of thousands that's
right yeah so if you zing store or e
games then it's yeah there's 30 of them
well I guarantee they've got 30 of them
in every single store around Australia
so a collect a collector edition that's
actually numbered individually that that
that will have they paying a big already
so um yeah do those sorts of things have
that almost that you know there's like
the cough of where it's like yep well no
no one really oh and then it comes back
again at some later
stage I mean this I'm actually curious
you are there any of those things old
school things from you know ' 80s or 90s
or anything where you know people now
consider the valuable that did have you
know those sorts of tags on them uh back
in the day that you
know has actually lived up to that uh
what it said on the box I'm just trying
to think I'm sure there are there must
be lot those Nintendo handheld things
that have come out sort of limited yeah
yeah they're they're definitely around
yeah but the fact that it's got that
written on it doesn't mean doesn't mean
anything that's not that's not the key
if they had didn't have that written on
it and they were still rare and desired
then that still hold the value so yeah
on its own it doesn't mean anything so
don't be don't be fooled by that if if
it if if you want it for what it is and
what it comes with because usually they
come with a cool statue or something I
buy them because I like the statues and
things like that but I'm not going to
pay a premium usually just just for that
I have to so I think I think we should
have made it clear we're collectors
we're not actually
sellers I'm I'm a hoarder yeah that's
right and I hopefully when I'm when I'm
gone it will be in a museum or be passed
on to someone to actually play in 35
years I can play 64 if them
want so uh the other thing I think that
can come up is shrink wrap you know and
also is there a way to know if it's
original shrink wrap or whether it's
like not you know I think that can
sometimes be one of those weird little
games that can happen some companies
actually do brand their shrink wrapping
like um PlayStation for example actually
had little PlayStation logo she Place
written around the shrink wrap I've got
at home uh two UK versions of Manhunt
still shrink wrap I picked up in a
garage sale for 10 bucks each which I'm
really happy about got those I was
debating whether opening one or not and
I've got open copy you can have so I
like sweet so keep them there but it's a
nice little hidden PlayStation thing
it's also something too you can tell
because of the um material as well like
some of the material you'll see on it
actually has little bits like you can
see obviously tell by age and things
like that it's been like you know you
got a 30-year-old game that has pristine
brand new shrink wrapping the odds of it
being original is quite you know zero to
none but that's what I found for a few
other things i' I've picked up if it
seems too good to be true it probably is
so then do do your research because
they're all different but you can find
out things about that of yeah forums are
a great source right so yeah I know with
the jagu stuff I think there's some
Holograms as well so um yeah that way
you can actually tell but yeah it's
pretty hard and plus I'm going to bust
it open anyway
it always happens it always happens I I
do remember that great story recently
and I'm kind of wondering if you know
you guys have sort of had these
experiences yourselves or know people
who have where uh uh it was about one of
the old like original
Nintendo like dance map track and field
game or something I can't remember the
exact name uh but that one sold for a
lot of money because someone had you
know dug it out but then another one
sold that was new and its uh wrapping
because they saw the news about the
other one that popped up are there kind
of quite often those moments where a few
of something will appear because people
suddenly realize oh that thing that's in
my cupboard is actually worth something
absolutely
yeah I'm going to wait for someone to
actually pull out another a Nintendo
PlayStation soon so go yeah that'll be
interesting say you can tell your one
or but it's funny too like you see
things that like trends like that will
start like you'll see one person like
either like a new about C game or a
certain ER or something like that and
some I've got one of those that must be
valuable now and then one goes out like
when Pokémon go um you know was mental
and other people still playing it I will
confess I'm still playing it too don't
judge but when that came out I saw
articles on various websites saying how
much value how much value was now in the
original card sets and things like that
cards are going for $1,000 and if you're
going to sell them sell them now and
suddenly all these Pokémon cards or
Pokémon games and if you're let the
Pokémon is just going up X exponentially
fing the market going up exponentially
in value see like people just listing it
everywhere um i' I saw the Pokemon game
boys you know the yellow yellow ones I
saw those sitting on eBay for ages like
you know 50 something dollars the second
Pokemon go took off it had that impact
on it 150 200 199 every always list
going there is no way no but yeah it
does have the impact on for
unfortunately unfortunately not sure
it's human nature isn't it see an
opportunity try to cash in it's just the
way and don't get mad I see people
getting really ticked off when things SC
rocket and look just don't worry about
it something else so I mean I know I I
really really want things but you know
they Skyrock pass I think you know what
just move on collecting collec is
definitely playing the um the the long
game it is absolutely abely uh now we
kind of touched on this a little bit
earlier but I'm wondering and also just
flag we'll do some questions um shortly
so um we'll do them based on the uh the
two microphones that are up the front um
so in about uh sort of probably 5
minutes uh I'll open it up to anybody
has questions um so keep that in mind
and uh the traditional situation is that
uh everybody's quite shy when we first
open up the questions uh and then
there's about eight people who miss out
at the end so don't be one of those
people be one of the first people anyway
uh yeah we touched on kind of values
changing worldwide and uh you I'm kind
of curious what is it about sort of that
that uh you know that works is it that
the kind of in internal markets inside a
country are actually kind of the most
important element of value or like you
know are there certain things here in
Australia that people really kind of
love and Chase and then in other
countries they kind of love and Chase
different types of things or is it even
just where I guess where you'll find
certain things absolutely um Nintendo
was huge in the US so Nintendo always
goes for high price in the US sea does
not right so Master System didn't take
off at all in the US so you can
definitely pick up some cheap games from
um from well you probably won't you
probably W want to get the ntsc ones
anyway but um in Australia what I found
is the Atari Links is actually at a very
very reasonable price so there's a tip
collect for the Atari Links um and
because they're very expensive in the US
very expensive in Europe so and they're
actually willing to pay for the shipping
from here because it still ends up being
cheaper for them from buying it from
here so um I just hope they steel stuff
a lot to do with yeah what was released
there what took off there yeah
absolutely so um yeah and for some
reason I've I've been keeping an eye
specifically on that particular system
and it's just funny that I always see it
coming up on eBay or gun tree and they
always go for a very reasonable price so
the original or the to either one but um
I just hope to don't startop skying but
yeah look it's it's been at least um two
three years where the price has just
been really really flat and the games
are available you can pick up games for
10 bucks I went to the carara markets up
in Queensland and I saw a a swag of a
tire of in games for $10 which so I
thought well that's a pretty good price
because I know in the US they go for 40
yeah right so um yeah and that's us
40 any others any thoughts on that kind
of international side of things I
suppose it's a regional exclusive
console like things like the um it's
called the Casio lupy which is a
coner that was a um a console in Japan
designed purely for purely for ladies or
for go girls I like one of those ladies
big pens
yeah like it was um one of those things
was the Japanese exclusive um I've got
I've managed to get one recently over
here because I found one insanely cheap
got it actually had a little printing on
the front app stickers because you know
apparently you know that's what girls
enjoy playing and things like that and
having um I'm not saying that just by
the way I'm just saying that's what the
thought process was apparently but it's
one of those things where I got it quite
cheaply and I showed another clect a
friend of mine who straight away off me
tripled what I paid for because he'd
been after one and he missed a listing
about it so I got it all up with
shipping 50 bucks that's pretty and I
was really happy about that in the box
and everything and it was just yeah it's
not one I'd seen before and I had to
sort of do a bit of research when of
scene what what's this and going through
and trying to find what it was and the
history of it I was like oh okay that's
actually quite a unique console we never
had in Australia so I got that actually
Le at the point you're saying before
Alex too about doing your research you
might see something completely random
like an apple pipping if you saw an
apple piping out in the wild you may not
see what it you might not recognize what
it was but they're super hard to get a
hold of so yeah and they weren't were
they I think they were stream releas
were they no apple walked away from it
long time but um when when someone
actually says I found this for you know
like you said the loopy 50 bucks the F
the first question I always ask is how
long I mean you might have been lucky
and found it straight away but I don't
want people actually tell me that I say
well how long are we actually looking
for then you find out two three four
years it's like well exactly what I said
at the start is is that yeah you got to
be patient you got to just keep on
looking be yeah Vigilant about your
surgery and and your research my may had
been looking for 3 years I found it in 3
hours dark yeah just a little bit pissed
off uh just one of these weird little
Pro tip things about searching I'm
curious if you guys use it I know that
it comes up a bit in um you know sort of
other antiques Industries and things do
you ever do typo searching on some of
those listings definitely yes my my
favorite is
Nintendo just but now actually eBay
smart up go
algorithm damn
it so you got to really something the G
doesn't have that oh yeah you're right
yeah Saga still works for SE
occasionally as well on eBay
occasionally uh now again you I know
you've kind of said uh you know you're
mostly collectors not sellers but you
know I guess if someone feels like
they've got something that they're
curious about you know hey maybe I
should sell this um you know how would
somebody get try to get that sense of
well what what is the market willing to
pay for this thing Ebay eay completed
listings right it means it's it's green
then Market putting the spreadsheet
right um I think eBay keeps out for a
few months so you can actually track it
and go for an average price whatever
that may be but um yeah I people do
think that they can B something for five
bucks look up on eBay it says 2000 so
well they probably won't and you
probably see that particular listing
come up over and over and over again it
doesn't sell it doesn't sell because
there's no market for it no one's to P
that much so completed sold
listings actually check
for cool good point unfortunately
resellers will always check eBay listing
for the listed price and the highest
possible listed price and then we put
that you know $10 Mario Kart Nest cart
you know it's super rare
,000 no thank you and if you if you ask
actually on a forum someone might
actually label if you don't know so do
your own research definitely you should
be okay definitely I remember once um
eBay would having one of their sales and
i' they were selling these Dragon Age
Inquisition collectors things and so I
checked on eBay just to see what you
know what they value like $90 I think
they were selling them for and on in in
America they were buying just the tarot
cards out of that set for like
$250 so I said I'll buy couple go
literally sold just the ter cards for
250 us each wow and I was like okay good
so that's wasn't really a reseller thing
cuz it was a new item so but they must
have not had that available to them yeah
I mean yeah that's a good point that
even on some of those new things again
just the way that those sets can be
distributed on that Global level there
was no way I would send the whole thing
like if that was if I had to send forget
about but just just the pack of cards
yeah no problem I was fine I live in a
country town in New South Wales and uh
you know going to the local EB if there
is some lawn of something where I know
that up in the city it's like all my
friends like I couldn't get my pre-order
and like I'll just go to my local
there's not as many
people uh look I think we'll we'll get
ready to take questions out in a moment
I thought I'll just run through these
guys some pictures I've I've got them to
kind of tell me what some of their
personal you know like white whale
Collectibles are those like desperate
things they're hoping to one day track
down again and get their hands on um so
I think we've got uh a couple things
here uh I think Alex I think a couple of
these first ones are yours do you want
to just give us a few little thoughts on
these I really love uh TVs so you'll
find that my white Wales are all TVs
that have got builtin consoles so this
one's the sharp in TV actually come in a
14 and 21 in so it's going to BU any
this um only available in Japan I think
they were released also in America and
they also came in Red so are they
exclusive colors on the controllers
anything yeah yeah they are so I I
guarantee someone can probably sell
those controllers forg so much but um
yeah um Unfortunately they aren't cheap
um predominantly in Japan so shipping
probably G us as much probably arrive
all broken anyway yeah um but uh yeah
and so that's still where the sharpen is
oh another view yeah and then we've got
the the main well the sf1 or the super
fcom so yeah that's the 20 I think
that's 21 in so up the top no no it's
still sharp so yeah you can just put in
your super ficom um card up the top
there and uh yeah play play some games
and super fom games are actually cheaper
than a Super Nintendo pal game so um
there's another tip if you want to yeah
wow and then I guess yeah you're right
if you've got the TV set up you don't
have to worry about absolutely so um
yeah and these yeah and they actually do
go for about 1,500 bucks um that's
another one with the as you can see the
control ports at the front there with
the game sticking out from the top
that's cool and last but not least the
very very expensive divers 20061
Dreamcast um roughly between $4 and
$8,000 so if you can follow for four
grand and you got a you know something
burning or cash burning your um in your
pocket just yeah no no not the divers
yeah I think I think um us and Japan I
love that swoop at the back there is
nothing that says Space Age more than
wasn't it designed Sonic head orign
sonic yeah so that's what it looks like
that but yeah
so no was this was this yours or was
this yours oh it's not it's not super
rare it's it's it's an SX 64 so it's a
fully portable Comm 64 system it's got
the tiny tiny screen there flppy drive
built in all that sort of stuff the
keyboard doubles as a sort of lid to the
top but yeah the like I'm sure we
borrowed one of these back in back in
the day so I had a friend who what my
brother's friend had one and so we we
had it in our house for a while and I
was like you know just just just love it
it's just it's just an amazing system um
so is that actually like a c64
but yeah so it's it's it's probably
weighs about 20 kilos so portable but
I've got a you com 128d which is also
portable to car if you have both of
those it's both computer system and a
weight working um but yeah it's a pretty
cool item and yes I'm I'm a bit of a
pinball head so if I I'm looking to get
a pinball and this is my favorite the
scared stiff the elvir oh wow theming
you know one one of my favorites from
back in the day so uh not they're around
but they're pretty rare so one one day
I'll find one and you say I think when
you first mentioned this on you're
saying that like conditioners are kind
of a big yeah definitely cuz um you a
lot of a lot of the pinballs yeah if
they don't work they're not great but
definitely repairable um some of the
Plastics and stuff are hard hard to hard
to reproduce like the snake but but
these days with radio Printing and stuff
it's getting a bit easier to do that so
um yeah really yeah just amazing system
so all right this this was mine um this
is actually the very first computer I
ever had as a child Tandy
vz300 I'd love this thing it was the
most amazing thing to me when I was a
kid I've been trying to find one for a
couple years now if anyone has one in
the cupboard please let me know come
find me after the
show repas want get want to rid of it
someone willing to sell yeah EXA at a
reasonable price um yeah know I love
this thing it was the first PC I ever
got to play with really as the first
real Venture into home gaming from that
point was all arcade to me and why I got
a real to it's not worth tons but it's
hard to find hard hard to find working
and yeah it's got a real sort of you
know Nostalgia hit for me which why I'm
chasing one of
those this thing this thing has been my
white Wale for quite some time now now
the still Balian controller set for the
Xbox I've come across a couple of these
a few times I know some people in the
room have them not them glaring at them
um I've won one these for ages like I
played the game I played the game once
actually I can't remember where it was
it was like a demo day or something like
that with I had it up in Sydney I played
it instantly fell love cuz I just love
doing the old um Mech Warrior things I
had a time zone the full captal stuff
you're sitting there and do the full
controls this to me was like one of the
most phenomenal control systems and I've
always wanted one but I've always eluded
me every time I've seen them they've
been listed for an insane price so I'm
hoping against hope one day I'll find
one at a reasonable price or maybe when
I go overseas I'll find one that's you
know barely reasonable that can somehow
fit into a suitcase CU it's a big box
gigantic yeah it'll into a shipping
container I'll leave everything else own
behind just bring that one thing back
but yeah that's definitely one of my
probably biggest white Wes I'd love to
get my hands on to be honest cool um so
look I think we'll take take some
questions now if people want to
desperately Rush up quickly to make sure
they don't miss out um yeah we'll do
quick than you
guys we will uh start over here on the
left so
um I'm sure it'll come up there's a
stream so yeah we good okay so uh with
your old systems like I've got a
commodor 64 what do you do for
controllers because I've got a bunch of
juny controllers that don't work for Dam
and I've got one in a sealed box that's
never been opened or used which like I
place something man I should just use
that new controller but I can't bring
myself to open the box so um so what do
you do for controllers I just I just buy
tons of controllers I've probably got
100 Comm controllers but the good thing
about commodor controls is they're
pretty simple they're not they're not
complex Electronics in there it's just
buttons and switches so you can open
them up if you know someone who does
some soling you can you can fix them
pretty well so you can get replacement
switches but most of the time it's just
connection so like the the cable and the
and the uh and internal uh internal
soldering so it's they're pretty
relatively easy to fix I was say which
particular stick is it is it those brown
no it's not the it's not the original
Commodore one it's um it's it was
marketed as a pro stick you know it's
like you hold it from the base
competition Pro oh yeah s on top one
yeah Speed Stick Speed Stick I say
definitely worth repairing they're
they're in excellent stick they are
excellent stick all right okay I was say
too never throw your controls because
they're great for spare parts if you
ever do thing as well so exactly right
cool over here do you actually ever sell
anything or I even though we talk about
value I I never sold anything from my
collection I I've never actually
technically sold anything for my
collection but I have traded off doubles
and triples to other collectors as well
so they've had something that I've
wanted or something they've wanted so
I've L just done that sort of bar system
it's hard to sort of part with some of
the things spend much time trying to
track them down or get in your
collection that you don't really want to
part with them but you will for another
collector or someone who really wants it
or really sort of is Keen for it but
I've never personally sold anything I
think collectors by Nature are hoarders
as well like a lot of the time I just
want to get stuff and get more stuff and
then some more stuff so but it does you
know if if the if the deal comes up that
you can't resist then you will sell so
how much storage space do you guys
actually have not
enough the answer that I put I put it we
we put we like build a room in our roof
for extra storage I've built a room in
my garage to sort of keep my stuff in
now so it's it's always at a premium in
Melbourne and Sydney I guess like a
sealed dust free room yeah exactly yeah
you there were mice in the old shed so
I'm like you're not getting here buddy
I'm like I've got a very understanding
wife um I've got a full R for myself and
now my I call it my my home office as
well is now like four walls full of
shelves and a stack literally like I've
got a Voltron figurine which sits about
an inch from the roof just so everything
stacked up everywhere
so and here on the left
helloo that working okay yep um do you
ever find that stuff loses value if it
gets say re-released like example was on
the Wii there was Metroid collection but
then it came out on the Virtual Console
yeah and then the prices went down yeah
I think diders do that a little bit yeah
I was going to say digital preservation
okay but physical always hold it a bit
more always hold it it may not in the
short term but it definitely will and
again it comes down to storage have you
got you know spacing a roof um you know
do you want to keep the Box a styrofoam
whatever it may be right but um yeah it
will definitely have collectors always
want the physical EXA right I mean it's
great to you know if you meet like a
developer of a game you can't take up
and say hey sign my hard drive it's like
hey can you sign my original copy of
your game please as as well as well as
the fact that these virtual things might
not always work forever exactly you've
got the original hardware and the
original orinal software from from back
in Windows cartridges they'll just work
forever well as long as the hardware and
software you got the means to keep it
definitely keep it I I got like games on
like SN but then I just buy them on the
virs console anyway it's more
convenient yeah yeah because I can't
hook up my Super Nintendo on the train
so yeah that's true it's ons that's what
Lynx is for isn't it oh
be funny when I put some power adapters
on the TRS and trains and we link
backpack batteries as well I remember
saying a guy on the train he was like
playing Xbox like a TV and an
[Laughter]
Xbox over here uh okay so I have a
simple question uh what is the most
valuable things in your
collection uh for me it will be the
Pioneer laser
active uh which was released in Japan
they only sold a couple thousand of
those and what you do is you actually so
it plays all laser dis movies but on top
of that it actually comes with um PC
engine and Genesis Mega Drive packs that
you can actually interchange so you can
actually play carts CDs and also LD so
Mega LD games that's something that
people probably didn't know about so you
can actually play Sega Mega LD games on
it um yeah so that's probably the most
expensive item in my collection cool did
you get it at a good price I got it at a
phenomenally good price because it was
mis
listed misting wow am I'm not sure like
probably for me there's a couple of
things like they're not valuable because
of what they are well one thing is I've
got uh I think this for one found only
one of 10 in the world uh Helgen statues
like life siiz Helgen statues from the
game Killzone one on Playstation um G Me
by PlayStation Australia which I
absolutely adored and loved his name is
Roy by the way he got named by my wife
um I've got a
Star Wars 360 console signed by car
Fisher which is kind of cool and I think
probably the rarest thing but it's not
technically the most valuable is a
original DS signed by
Moto that was given to me and I was
insanely insanely happy when he gave it
to me so yeah is that is that got a B
guard yeah it is locked away in a safe
yes it's not it's not just sitting at
the shelf on using the train every day
I've turned it on it still works I've
going that's awesome you go away now
live in
I don't think I even have any I don't I
don't even know what the most valuable
thing in my collection is cuz I don't
keep Good Records I I have no idea what
the most valuable thing in my collection
is is there a favorite I love my
commodor but really that that's my
favorite my original commodor 128's 128d
is are just my favorite I bought a I
bought one of the original 1 1701
screens for like 10 bucks that was
that's that's pretty bad that's pretty
cool but yes I I haven't I haven't got
many high end items it's just not my I
just haven't got the
the means for that so but yeah I I love
all my stuff it's all great for
that hi can you hear me hello yes um I
missed the first 20 minutes so I don't
know if you've covered this but um just
I've got two question um one of them
sort of you mentioned eBay and gum tree
is that kind of the main source that has
because I'm me I run to eBay and and gum
tree but I mean there's been forums and
there's been sites that have kind of
come up and they've just kind of just
disappeared cuz nobody's sort of taking
them on so I just wonder about you guys
sort of yeah definitely um Main Place
you go eBay definitely right and I know
um yeah I'm I think I said it the ACT
talk that I'm on it constantly so um
yeah if you're only going to search once
a week you definitely won't find that
particular item so I was saying I
actually search when I'm on my coffee
break while I'm in the bathroom um you
know in the morning just before I get up
out of bed or at night constantly and
I've got actual alerts on as well so I
do not miss a thing um you got to be
H one yeah soorry the second one was um
we mentioned virtual consoles just
before um I mean I I'm a collector and
I'm collecting from my my kids I've just
had a couple of kids and obviously it's
going to go past to them they're going
to play awesome games um I realized it's
come through my virtual world as well so
my steam collection's like ridiculous
but passing that on to them is going to
be difficult and I want if you if this
actually goes into your virtual world as
well for you guys you know your steam
collection and your your Virtual Console
games and you actually classify them as
collections or they are just the
throwaway oh they they're collections
for using they're not not collections
for anything else I guess like yeah
they're definitely a collection of stuff
you know they're things that you can use
things you can play but I mean yeah the
the physical collections are the things
that you can pass on and you're at the
mercy of the service as well if the
service goes then you're gone so um yeah
that's why
yeah that's come up quite a bit in you
know in our Tech coverage of a lot of
these Services where something
disappears and it's like you you only
ever owned a license you never owned an
actual
thing sucked in basically yeah yeah
absolutely cool thanks uh so my question
is sort of in regards to you mentioned
you guys have a lot of storage in
regards to you know keeping all this
content how do you actually store them
like you know consoles and cartridges
and that so I've got a lot of and S
those types of um games and cartridges
how do you actually store them in your
storage plastic tubs
mostly yeah re reject shop plastic tubs
they actually and and they are yeah
they're very very Hardy like Stacy said
at the top of the actual talk that um
these things were built to last we you
just blow them and they'll work so I'm
dead against blowing like I
don't it does work um so
Busters be D it works it definitely
works um yeah so I mean don't keep them
under the house um if you got a garage
whatever but yeah plastic tubs perfect
for that away moisture that the main the
main issues moisture insects animals
small children um anything that cause
damage to them like I've got a lot of my
stuff seeing up on display shelves
around the house which I'm quite you
know fortunate about but the second we
have kids those shelves are going to get
right and high
so yeah and just give them we I if sort
of water Ty that's water type but
yeah with those tubs are you looking for
the ones that like have a really good
seal on them like versus ones that just
flop around a bit or what it's not it's
not that imp me you know unless you're
expecting flooding you're okay but I
mean you're looking to keep out General
moisture and and animals yeah if you're
putting them in a place where you can
get pests and definitely important I've
had manuals destroyed unfortunately by
various insects and things which is just
painful up stack like yeah they are like
oh no
my old color computer 2 just sits around
in its original box and I have to say
though that it's not like it's not in
styrofoam or anything and it has gotten
a lot yellower over the years yes it
happens get character yeah that's right
character all right I was just wondering
how you guys balance getting a good deal
and morals because if somebody is you
know putting something up for a
ridiculously cheap price because they
have no idea how much it's worth is it
okay to take advantage of that
oh I think the room is very comfortable
with human nature is that you would but
um I think someone actually asked a
question earlier yeah we tend to sort of
um barter with other K detectors so that
way we're not going to you know we do
know that something's worth x amount but
and if someone does not know that um
it's actually better to be honest about
it um but yeah look if you see something
on eBay and it's actually that cheap I
mean go it go for it go for it I mean
there's enough there's enough you know
unless you're going around to you know
octogenarian houses and trying to still
take their 10 bucks then people
otherwise have plenty of means to
research this stuff so if they really
wanted to do it they could they could
they could do that often they'll just be
yeah you don't want to take super
advantage of people but are you keeping
or
reselling and don't feel bad if you find
if you do find something genuinely
that's you know for five bucks and then
it ends up being 100 um and if someone's
willing to pay for it by all means right
I know people have got an issue with
that but if people are willing to pay
for it they're going to pay for but the
opposite happens too put stuff up
for I take I think M people put up for
like $100 when it's worth five like if
people get it for $5 and res 100 fair
enough that's that's what they've chosen
to do but my thing is I I won't take
advantage of anyone's being naive or
anything like that yeah so I think I
think if it's online then
if it's online it's fair game you just
go for it if it's like some Pro granny
who's got you know a massive attire
collection sitting there for $5 you look
no I'll give you 50 for it it's worth
this but it does happen when you go like
if you go to an OP shop and they've got
something five bucks and they can see
the excitement in your face I guarantee
they'll jack up the price so make sure
you have a p face definitely actually I
was going to say as well on eBay in the
space of time of you sending a polite
message to aist someone else will have
bought it
absolutely y here um I've got question
on um collecting magnetic media that's
um you know have a fear of it um as we
all know it degrades over time and a
fear of collecting that and um for
example I bought a pack of um commodor
64 tapes that smell a bit dubious musty
wise um so what's uh your advice sort of
around around that oh it's a great
question my my my feeling on this is
that it's good to have the originals but
I don't like to play The Originals yeah
so there's a lot of ways to play the
games by SD card and things like that
new technology I'd much prefer to have
the original and and use that technology
because that's the part of those systems
it's much hardest to keep uh in in good
condition like the hardware runs
properly but the drives and things can
be a bit tricky and they can they can
chew up old old media so tapes are yeah
tapes are tricky but I know with the
floppy floppy discs I don't know why I
did this when I was a kid but when I
used to buy singles CDs from JB I would
actually get the plastic insert and put
my floppy disc in there so they all work
perfectly
fine so I must have had for Sight going
to say you're a very I don't think they
degrade as badly
as thing is with those they can't
actually they can't fail um recently was
playing uh one of my favorite games on
the com 64 was Hills far dragons yeah
love that game played it probably a
couple months ago anyway went to Play It
Again few just couple weeks ago and
nothing nothing disc is dead it's
completely sometimes be the drive as
well as no I tried I've got three
different drives I tried trust me I went
for two different commodor three
different
drives not as effective with discs
blow yeah it can it can definitely be CH
just got to make sure you store them in
a place where it's going to keep them at
a reasonable temperature the other thing
too I found with tapes is a little bit
of the um stuff that they keep them away
from moisture um found a bunch of tapes
I've St in storage for years and they
did get a bit the Box a bit moist um and
it's just mold on the cassette and
they're literally just they're useless
now apart from show pieces that's that's
it so I just say try and store them as
best as you possibly can to keep them
like especially the this do flat or up
that's a question uh up you up right but
but if you're actually buying tapes um
yeah there's nothing more unfortunate
when you bust up in that box and you can
smell smoke
or and it's like oh dear um un people
don't list that so you're taking
a cool thank you I think we will manage
to sneak in these last two questions so
yeah first up so um yeah sort of
branching off the uh like virtual
re-releases thing a bit it's like um so
I'm I'm big on I I do actually love the
Virtual Boy and I know that there's like
rumors around that some of the
um some of the like sort of you know uh
unicorn unreleased games do someone does
have a copy of them but refuses to like
dump them and release them to the
community CU they want to retain that
value and yeah I guess yeah what your
guys thoughts are on like keeping stuff
for yourself versus sharing absolutely
sharing absolutely sharing it drives me
nuts for when people do that because you
want to preserve this stuff for people
to play in decades to come right so um
yeah someone actually asked a question
earlier where they're passing their
stuff on to their kids that's exactly
why everyone's doing it you want to
preserve things so they can actually
played on the original Hardware that was
on I mean uh digital preservation is
great but um yeah nothing beats actually
you know BL on a card or whatever may be
chucking it in and up she comes and you
play and if something happens to that in
in the meantime then we're going to lose
it forever so like exctly it's part of
history I mean it's part of the part of
the culture we all love we all love
video games we all love Retro Gaming so
if that's in lost from history because
one person was greedy about it you
wouldn't imagine you lose too much value
on the original anyway like I don't
understand why people would do that but
there are people that do that
unfortunately so um
yeah last question we'll sneak in I'll
try and keep it quick um getting you
mentioned like repairing stuff and you
do most of it yourself what if you're
not as confident do you guys have any
like places you go to or recommendations
I got a his
guy because if I sold to something I
guarantee it's going straight in the
B no I'm absolutely hopeless um yeah but
there are definitely places around still
that do that I mean you know General
Electronics is is hasn't changed too
much in the last 20 30 years so anyone
that's doing that sort of work still
you'll be able to get that done any sort
of you know TV repair places and things
like that is there a way to learn like
as in you
know or something like you know no well
yeah you can do that um I mean M I
haven't got any formal learning in it
but I sort of did a lot of scientific
research and stuff so I was sort of
tinkering around with things and yeah my
my way is just to Tinker around with
things you know look look online cuz
often problems that are relatively
common have solution so got a bit of
just just practice with the soldering is
important so on stuff that's not not
valuable um yeah once once you got some
confidence then then yeah you can do
that but but there are definitely places
around CU it's an important it's
important and and there are guys on
forums that actually do that they can
actually fix things and also um if you
check on YouTube there's a lot of video
tutorials these days as well a lot of
research re forums groups that people
had the similar issu I can tell you
almost step-by-step guides on how to fix
it but yeah I'm selftaught as well like
all sort of stuff and it's just one of
those things like I may have destroyed
more stuff than I fixed to begin with
but yeah now it's sort of Handy to have
but I learned through a lot of guys
going asking them so how do I do this
how I do that going on the old school
forums and like before we had like
YouTube was even around asking like old
X repairment how they fix stuff and
digging out old manuals that from people
know had from alares and things like
that to workout stuff and yeah just as I
was saying like just have just you know
research and practice cool look um
hopefully you've gotten a few useful
tips in your own sort of efforts ahead
of you collecting uh can we please give
a very big thank you to the panel Stacy
Alex and
[Applause]
[Music]
N thanks
guys
yeah
[Music]
e
out
two
two two two
two two
two
hey
yo coming through the head
t
yeah I
think I just want to make sure that I'm
sending
everything down the yeah I'm pretty sure
I
am oh you doing
[Music]
Matrix
e
[Music]
that's good it's so funny man
watching hey just got a
[Applause]
question
oh yeah he
right
he actually came here if
few I'm just going to mute
your
[Music]
w
la
two different ways we do one varies
depart information go into large table
simulation I love that one and then
we've got another one which is uh we
just choose what the success of any
intervention or treatment would be based
on reasonable
experience um it just changes the
dynamic it changes the way people think
about simulation um I don't know how to
make this this is already getting on my
nerves I'm want to make it into SL no no
no yeah like I want to just play it like
for some it was working and then now
it's not and I don't ever use Mac so
this is Google
Slides I might just I might just start
again I'm just going to like brows to
the page
this just give me a sec M just I've got
no don't worry about just I
start
yeah well I'm trying to use a ma to do
something that is
[Music]
inherently
it should be up now okay do you want me
to test the audio now
he the audio is coming out of the
laptop CH the a
there
the other reason they don't bring people
in in it earlier is to make sure all
this technical crap is sorted out this
is mine this is my talk I did just in
real but then what I've done is I've
done it so that you can go to any PA
[Music]
Y and then go back again yeah ni and go
to anything else
that's cool yeah I've not realized you
could do this on PowerPoint before I
think I don't know that you could have
done it in PowerPoint there was an app
that you could get you get off
[Music]
the Jump SL now everyone's
happy
red what do you
mean session yes I've been I've been all
over the this is the only panel that's
mine though the rest of them I just turn
up thank
you me your M oh okay well that's F I'm
happy with that I spent I was in the
drop for two talks yesterday uh and they
were back to back so I just sat in the
same SP for two and a half
hours
[Music]
one of the questions is whether they're
psychedelic mushrooms or not Steph is
here but I don't think that's a
problem now that you got an extra you
got it that's the difference between the
gallerina the death galleras and the
which that's Amo which is which is the
most
feel free to start letting people in if
you need
to
and you can you can I'm sure you can
hear me is it
on I uncooked mushrooms in my salads all
the
time you check who not particularly you
don't
knowest
to be fair there is a couple of Google
things on people crapping out mushrooms
I'm sure I'm sure
you s a u v is in
[Applause]
[Music]
Bravo
never been on a panel before do
something new with a packs every
year so I'm I'm one of the guys that
runs the painting
[Music]
t
I don't know what grand scheme you've
got underway
Delilah we'll take
it but I'm coming to put you in your
grave So It Begins
I got a couple of mates here yeah I
realized I left my phone with my friends
I don't know where they are missed the
opportunity for the
selfie
really Le have a presentation I did have
a
presentation finish this I it's going to
beol yeah keep in mind I got told about
it this morning H I got told about it an
hour
ago
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
what's the
smell
[Music]
let's do
this hi everyone welcome to packs day
three how you
going awesome everyone exhausted yet or
still got yeah me too so um welcome to
the medical MythBusters take on games
look at you lucky people we're turning
people away at the door now get the
opportunity to just like completely
destroy your own opinion of the healthc
Care
Professionals um so we're going to we're
going to deconstruct some some games a
who said professional who said
professional yeah professional um and
I'll be leading the panel and Dr
Jennifer Hazel you might have seen me a
few other panels if you have just
deconstruct everything you thought about
me cuz this is going to be a really good
fun entertaining pinch of salt kind of
panel and thank you to my fellow doctors
for being here with me today I really
appreciate them coming particularly Adam
who found out he was going to be on this
panel about 45 minutes
ago so do you guys want to introduce
yourselves and tell me what specialty or
tell the room cuz I know but tell the
room what your specialty is okay so hi
um I'm Dr Shel Zia I've been working as
a doctor down in Sydney for the last
four to five years and I'm specializing
in mental health my name is Steve Costo
I'm an Emergency Physician I work at
Ballarat uh in Victoria um and I've got
an interest in gamification of medical
simulation uh my name is Adam strob uh
former emergency registar up in Bat now
medical registar um and I love games
um and hi everyone my name is Steph I'm
sort of like the fraud on the panel
because I'm technically not a doctor yet
I'm a final year med student I had my
last day of class on Friday so fingers
crossed I'll be graduating soon um but I
also love video games and I have a
pretty strong interest in mental health
awesome um can we get
the thank you um I was going to put our
faces on there but um because I'm a
doctor I'm like the most disorganized
person in the world so I actually made
this presentation in bed this morning uh
so you're just going to have to do with
Adam and Jamie um so let's just get into
it um these are going to be loaded off
of YouTube oh please don't control my
laptop that's my
laptop who doing
that
can I have some text support up here
please what's going
[Music]
[Laughter]
on there we
[Music]
[Applause]
go the magic words so
so hopefully this is going to be
completely spoiler free this is actually
the first scene in Uncharted 2 and I'm
going to skip straight to the part where
you realize that Nathan Drake's been
stabbed and shot and is at the bottom of
a train that's falling off a cliff so
can you see you're watching it on
here
[Music]
just
two-handed climbing up bearing in mind
currently bleeding
out with the
concussion
move's good for a man who's been stabbed
in the
guts he always looks great for a man
that's been stabbed in the
gut I like that his back is covered in
blood he's just like casually just okay
ascending up a
pipe oh
dear he has got to be the most unlucky
man in the
world so I'll just skip to the Middle
where he gets to the
top the Train's gone at this
point
I actually think they did a good job of
making him look quite
gray like he he does look a bit on the
verge of
day
thoughts bizarrely I had a patient in
last night who exactly the same thing
had
[Laughter]
happened so how much can the human how
much blood can you lose and still
perform like that if ever h i so the
thing that comes to mind is I thing
called the Apache score which is um um
an injury score injury severity score
scale and you you start looking at the
the the type of injuries and insults
that your physiology has taken and
you're sort of going okay he's been
stabbed in the guts well that scores him
a nine in his guts you know and he's
been shot as well
shot probably someone remind me shot and
St
you know so if it's not in the guts
obviously you can't go above a nine on
your score so that's probably another
another area so that's going to give you
a nine somewhere else you and once you
start he just doubled his score above
like well you just got you start working
on you just can't survive that you know
your survival rate is incredibly low but
um yeah I I knew had a p and I'm I'm
I've got to be cautious obviously with
talking about patients I've seen but you
know I have seen a guy who was ex
Special Forces who was in a bip plane
crash so literally fell out of the sky
in plane so this guy is about as fit as
you can and survived to the hospital and
actually then survived the cardiac
arrest as well which you know surviving
cardiac arrest is you know 12 14% anyway
surviving a traumatic uh Cardiac Arrest
is is virtually unheard of um and didn't
survive you know so you start putting
that into Realms of what you've seen and
things you realize that you it's it
everyone knows that it's not quite right
but it's it's getting over the adversity
I think
what happens in the
games I think even before that just that
upper body
strength it's just physically impossible
no no no see I used to I used to rock
climb um um don't carry the physique of
my rock climbing years of course but um
you know there were guys that can do
one-handed pull-ups and uh the the the
big climbs now have what's called a
dynamic move in them where you're not
actually capable of holding on to the
rock face in the middle of a move so you
can hold on here and you can hold on
here but in between that you have to
have something that gives you some lift
and there'll be a tiny ledge that you
can't physic the coefficient of friction
won't allow you to hold on but you use
that to then move to another hold that
you can move on to so the high sort of 9
a 9 b c grades that are are being
accomplished now they've got Dynamic
moves so you you know you can't do that
and I've seen guys that can do
one-handed pull-ups you know they
literally can pull their whole body
weight up on one hand so possible but
then when you add in you know ice and
the fact you just shot i' never tried
it I'm guessing it's pretty good we can
try one later if you want you know meet
us at the pub afterwards let's
see um I'll buy around for anyone who
can do
one after
you um about take let's bear in mind
what this is the next game yeah really
or the game after how far you we and uh
bearing mind you know what Nathan did
that we've just
seen but this particularly is what I
wanted to show you cuz this is like this
just it makes me so happy it's not even
funny look how strong he is ridiculous
he still climbs up the
Rope because that's what stops him
absolutely that's like I've been shot
and stabbed and I'm going to like climb
up this entire train but me versus a
boat
railing no I've met some very strong
railings have you guys seen anything
like that people in in in hospital that
have been able to tolerate things that
are like really really really huge and
then get super sick over something like
quite minor yeah yeah I I think the
thing you see is we always talking
percentages in medicine which is kind of
where the role the the the the role
playing game the dice has come in with
my research is that you know you can't
ever say nothing will ever happen um so
you know you see if you get ejected from
a car in a in a in an accident your
mortality at the scene is
80% so you're actually if you get thrown
out out of a car during a during a
rollover or during a car crash you the
chance of you being dead at the scene
are four out of five that leaves one out
of five of being uh have survived but
that doesn't mean they're going to
survive a year or a week or a month or
or to the hospital they're just alive at
scene you know um but you know you see
people coming out of crashes and you
look at the car and wow how how did you
get out of that you know that's
incredible and the reality is just by
literally by chance they didn't collide
with the steering wheel and they didn't
put their head through the wind screen
or the A aell on the car um because the
angle was just right and things happen
you know and I um when I was still in
the UK when I was working at dford U
there's this big Trauma Center in the
southwest um I had a 19-year-old kid
that came in from uh motorcycle versus
Jeep um head on both going 60 MPH which
is well I don't know 100
100K so comb combined 200k um you can
imagine who fed best in that situation
this kid uh was like so so the biggest
killers in in motorcycle accidents as
far as I know bonm it's been a few years
since I did emergency is his head injury
and pelvic injuries and he managed to
avoid both somehow um but every other
bone in his body was
broken to compens you know swings some
roundabouts um and he was just sitting
there both arms broken with his femur
sticking out of his
skin you guys want to hear all the
gruesome I guess that's why you here
isn't it why you want hear trigger
warning we could give you just a whole
bunch of math and statistics if you
prefer you can test me on my a level
physics it's not brilliant and um and I
knew him he was there for the whole
fourm month rotation he came in I think
my first week and was discharged in my
last week um and that entire time um I
only ever knew him horizontal
so he had all these surgeries and you
can't do them all at once so they were
being staggered you know one week after
the other and then in my last week I saw
him walking down the corridor with the
Physio and I was just
like you're
tall had no idea the whole time that he
was like 6'4 cuz I only ever saw him in
a
bed that's the reality I think of of
those situations is you're talking like
some fit young kid is going to then
spend the next four months in bed I
don't know if you've have you
experienced much trauma and stuff yet St
not huge amount personally um most of
stuff that I've seen is like you know
Pub braw stabbings kind of thing the
dirty North eping area which is
understandable
um the best pub stabbing was that I saw
was a guy that had come in he'd been in
a bar he'd gone through the front window
of the pub and he came in drunk as a
skunk and ter caring up my emergency
department and he had this cut that went
all the way across one eyebrow down the
side of his nose and almost to his ear
on the other side and he was you know
being held down by the
cops you know it's typical Saturday
night and in amongst all the other
things that we had going on this guy's
yelling and carrying on in one of the
pays and he was just so angry that he
wouldn't let the junior doctor go near
him with the needle for the anesthetic
for his face I get that a lot
so he elected to have her staple his
face
shut without any local with no
anesthetic at all he didn't really feel
it I don't know that he was feeling very
much at the
time and I and I I swear to you it took
70 Staples in this man's face to keep it
closed and as he was getting hauled down
to the police station afterwards he's
going I'm just going to rip him out my
hand when I get
there have fun with that let them give
you
anesthetic it's good it's very good so
um I want to show you guys a a clip from
a much older game but um a Trope that
has uh persisted Through The Years this
is 11 seconds so blink and you'll miss
it but um this was Mortal Kombat back in
the
[Music]
day
sub winds FL
fatality so just to clarify he just
ripped that man's skull and spinal cord
out of his body yeah you you can do that
that's called a a cranial spinal trans
um transplant yeah it's it's just that
easy oh is he just is he going to put
another one in yeah
yeah he's he's just very skilled you
know one-handed he is a pro it doesn't
damage the nerves at
all I've got to say though that that
there is some accuracy in there and that
that that would be
fatal I mean you know I think the from
my memory the tendons and ligaments that
hold the spinal vertebrae together are
pretty damn strong and they'd probably
remain together if you put that much
force I wonder how much force it would
take to actually rip
someone's spinal C out in one gun a
little
bit I'm wondering whether it would
pulverize the bones as well so it just
can out as powder you are what like
because the force would yeah be like
needed would be so much that they would
just come out like all squished together
yeah yeah I'm just trying to decide how
he managed to do it without pulling out
the ribs and the pelvis
they're kind of attached if you got if
you got that if you Tred to pull the
head off if you actually managed to get
through the soft tissues of the of the
neck which are pretty strong generally
speaking and if you there's some horri
horrific videos of um people who tried
no no no no well well to some extent
yeah there was some American scientists
tried to work out the forces that would
have to be uh conducted to cause
cervical spine fractures um to your neck
fractures so they got a lot of monkeys
and put them in a cage and B them in and
then slammed weights into the cage and
then slow motion videoed the monkeys
which was was horrific video so the the
story then goes and this is probably
where we're touching on myth I reckon at
this point but they go down the pub
afterwards and they're proud that
they've done all these calculations
about how to knock someone out and the
force needed to knock someone out and
one of the guys in there's a boxer and
says well well yeah and they're like
what yeah of course everyone knows that
what do you mean well if you ever watch
Boxing the way you knock someone out is
you hit them in the side of their head
you don't hit people in the front of the
head so that's that's how you cause
brain injuries and is to to hit someone
in the side of the head is that the
middleman and jeun or no I think so my
theory on this and obviously I carry
lots of personal theories around with me
and espouse them at any opportunity but
I work with him I know if you if you're
evolving and you're running through the
woods chasing your dinner uh you're
likely to be running forwards rarely
running sideways and therefore if you're
going to hit something with your head
you're going to hit the front of your
head on a branch so you don't really
want to be killing yourself by running
into a branch at full Pelt but you
probably haven't evolved much to be
punched in or hit in the side of the
head so when you get hit in the side of
the head you get really quite severe
concussion brain injury um so maybe
Subzero is doing it wrong yeah well see
I now he rips out from the top from what
I can see yeah do you want to do you
want to watch it
again yeah from the top it looks like
grabs him here questioning his technique
is what I'm
saying I mean he's successful but what
I'm thinking is if you get through so we
come back to thing you get through the
neck okay you got to get through the
soft tissues and neck which are pretty
strong so you see the monkeys it hit by
the cage cage swings to the side head
basically stays still the head goes in a
very weird way and the neck extends
massively but I reckon if you grab by
the head then you're probably going to
come off at the um atlal joint first and
take the head off in itself I don't
reckon you'd be able to get the spine
out but I mean maybe if you went in at
the bottom first and went up then I Reon
you might be able to do that how would
you get in well I mean you know how does
he get the bones out of the skin in the
first place grab the spinal cord from
below and then you know make sure you
get the anterior ligament cuz that's
your strongest ligament that goes right
the way up your spinal cord and then
pull from the bottom up you know like
deboning a fish
yeah I'm just saying you're a scary
dude what else you doing your spare
time work this stuff out don't you so um
so when we were planning well in the in
the program we talk about what would
happen in Assassin's Creed um
and I there there's a variety of
different options of of scenes in all of
the games that you could go to
demonstrate this I chose this one
because it's close to
home um let's have a look um it's only a
minute and a half or what's the whole
thing
yeah that's not going
to that see that's upper body
[Laughter]
strength no one wants to compare Health
funds go
away I'll take his so I'll tell you what
if he's fully privately
Insurance I'll ask
him you was in the line G probably get
work I was going to say might be work
cover this one I don't know what
assassins have work
cover but Australia if you getting
injury at work you're covered by work
cover aren't you pay into it but is if
playay in then I'm sure
it's I'm not sure it gets overseas
covered but they've been covered by the
NHS
so isn't that pretty it makes me
homesick from all the times that I used
to do
this this is like just a normal Sunday
in the year
I I like his perfect balance on the top
of the Cross there we
go and into some height Ah that's
the see see what they don't show you is
the very large cushions underneath all
of that straw yeah I mean we you know
England being still in the Middle Ages
obviously we we often have bales of hay
lying around the cities still to feed
the oh this
was oh yeah oh it's special hay yeah I
Deon we you know See Fields of it um Can
someone Google how tall Big Ben is and
then 400 people got out their
phones um and then just shout it out and
then we can work out like what would
actually
happen all right number one whatever
96 M cheers mate it's just what we tell
the tourists to make them feel they know
more than we do where's your calculation
again so what was it how
much well I calculated it for 200 ft and
um what's that in M uh 2 about 65 oh
right so like double it so so the big
issue the big issue is um the force is
is mass times your acceleration squared
and the uh so M um M velocity squared so
it's your velocity that's the important
thing um now I've got I don't know if
you can get to that video I've got of a
parkour um an 8 m parkour
drop um to see what happens to this guy
um but um I put together a really nice
PowerPoint not realizing J J one already
um it should be just that right down the
bottom up second one up this D yeah so
this I I don't I don't think it's going
to play that I can just look it up on
YouTube yeah you might uh 8 me parkour
drop I don't know I can't remember what
I said it was part of another part of
another thing but so
the basically the
um where where's my calculations on that
one I can't remember those basically
your your energy and speed at about 5 to
8 m you know you're talking about 30 to
50 kilm an hour when you hit the ground
um when you calculate it for the speed
from 200 M you're going at about 100 or
200 ft you're going about
125 150 which is almost getting up to
terminal velocity 125 km an
hour so you know it's at two 200 so he's
almost at terminal velocity unless he
actually which he does he kind of
directs himself down so he might be able
to get up to about 200 if he was a bit
higher um but at that speed you know
your energy that you're going into just
going to crumple like a tin can you know
it's
um you're not even able to um to control
your descent and it's it's the the
distance over which you
decelerate and the um and the force you
apply and the timing I mean you've all
seen the sort of little Russian gymnasts
that Vault off of a a vault and and try
and land accurately and and they fail
regularly so um you'd have to have
immense timing to get it just at the
right moment if you Tred to land on the
the ground without the ha stack um you
know virtually impossible
um going head first as well you know so
I think you probably need about a
kilometer of rolling distance um and
that whole thing of oh you just convert
it to a roll you know you're like no no
look you know several of the sort of big
jumps that I've seen you know you end up
fracturing both your heel bones your
calcum you know which is devastating in
itself um uh and I think one guy did
four stories
and and the funniest thing about his
story and and forgive me for saying
about patience but U this is
particularly um uh comedic uh history
that the guy gave in that he climbed up
a building that was five stories and
looked off and it was concrete
underneath and he thought that's going
to hurt too much so he went to the next
climbed all the way down again went to
the next building was only four stories
and had grass underneath it and jumped
off that one instead
and just just sorry um and uh a
colleague told me of a guy who who done
a similar jump and ended up as he landed
his his so as he landed you can't
control Waits too much so he he
basically curled up in a ball and his
knees came straight up under his jaw and
just literally split his face you know
um
so so so I
had I mean what would happen to his body
though well I had to think about I had
to think about this you see do you
reckon it would like be even
recognizable as a body anymore yeah your
body stays together pretty well I mean
you bodies that come out of planes and
stuff you know and they they Zoom across
you know they're not all completely
pulverized um so your soft tissu is
actually really elastic and so you can
smash them to pieces and they literally
would probably go virtually flat and
just back up here you like Billy the Bon
the bones don't work anymore
everything's kind of smashed and mushed
but generally speaking Skin's pretty
elastic so you know I think it will keep
everything contained to some extent you
probably got it's amazing how little
externally you need to look wrong um for
everything in decide to be mushed to
Pieces so I had I had to think about
this though so what what would you have
to do how would you have to evolve in
order to be able to jump off of um a Big
Ben or 200 ft in order to be able to
survive you got to have amazing timing
so you'd have to really change your
ability to time your Landing Way in
excess of anything that's that's seen in
sort of you know Olympic or World
Championship gymnastics and these guys
tumbles and rolls I think even if you
throw a cow Big
Ben it would land on its feet not it
would land on its feet and then the feet
would yeah and then the feet would land
to its
head you know um what was the last thing
that went through the cat's head you
know that's the
joke Ju Just remember it's not the fall
that kills you that sudden stop at the
end so then then you've got to cope with
the stresses that your body would would
would endure and there are people say oh
this guy fell out of a plane without a
parachute you know and it's like yeah
but you wouldn't take it as a the first
option would
you um and you'd have to so then you'd
have to have some sort of collagen so
collagen's the the basic sort of Goo
that holds you together it's the
proteins you'd have have some sort of
extraordinary collagen because you've
got not only the muscle so your actual
muscle fibers would have to apply the
forces to your bones you'd have to then
have bones that could take those forces
as well and then it's not only your
bones and your muscles but your guts so
it's your your your acceleration DEC
acceleration injuries in like motor
vehicle accidents they're quite often
like your liver especially so I mean I'm
everyone's sort of seen or well most
people have on vegetarian now but I
still remember what liver's like you
know it's pretty mushy and it's you know
it's sort of drier than than other stuff
it doesn't have a lot of Bounce to it
and and liver liver tears and splenic
tears you know those are the things that
really cause massive bleeding really
quickly so you've then got to have your
collagen's got to be really tough to
stop your liver rupturing and your
spleen rupturing Ing and then your guts
are on this big sort of pedicle called a
meant tree that holds them to the back
wall of your of your body as well so as
you decelerate all your guts kind of
Bounce down and bounce back up again on
your blood vessels would have to be sort
of stretchy or really tough as well so
there's a I think we got a bit of
evolution to
go what I'm saying so basically we need
to evolve into rubber yeah yeah yeah
yeah either got to be rubbery you got to
be able to be like you know the blob and
just s of go and then just I and you
know all you've got to be absolutely
solid you know you got to be really
fantastic fantastic red you know red you
don't know what's in his in his cap and
stuff you know Red Bull's got these guys
that are now jumping off of of buildings
and out of planes with those flight
suits and they're they're becoming
pretty successful and um I didn't get a
chance to look it up but I think these
guys are even Landing without the
assistance of a final parachute you know
so these guys are actually getting that
jump from space and stuff yeah you know
with the flight suit they're going into
so boxes and you know carbo boxes CU it
decelerates you really slowly and that's
the idea is the distance over which you
decelerate is what's really important
but you know these guys are starting to
get to a point where they're evolving
these suits that they're actually going
to be able to land without a parachute
or without going into something else
eventually so you know if he's got that
on board then OB all just all changes
doesn't it it's just kind of they had
that back in yeah Medieval Times
medieval times I didn't he was having a
crack wasn't
he um so this one's uh there's no video
but it's more um applicable to the the
two mental health people that are on the
panel
um in I was told yesterday that in Don't
Starve uh you can you have like a sanity
meter which is a thing that I hate and I
go on and on and on about how terrible
it is um and obviously it's just
perpetuating stigma against Mental
Illness but the way that you become not
insane is you collect
flowers well I mean if that worked I
wouldn't have a job yeah that's true we
most of the world would be deforested
by absolutely so um that's just an
interesting little addition there I
don't know whether there's any truth in
the fact that maybe some of the
treatments that we make for you know
mental health issues or any other um
medical conditions actually come from
flowers and herbs and I suppose also
that when he's picking the flowers it is
a distraction from his crippling
loneliness and depression um but to be
honest if picking flowers and um putting
them on your head was a legitimate
treatment then I would be really really
happy and I'd be telling a lot of people
to do it um I love my job but that would
make my job so much easier easier and
fun can we just dance with flowers
around on our heads all the time can I
try that in my emergency department with
somebody psychotic is that going to help
rather rather than shackling it
[Laughter]
here have a flower I think we I've been
working a bit on um a course in Era in
in in medical era and part of what we've
been looking at is uh uh mental health
in and the psychology of simulation and
how we stress doctors um or not but also
we're looking at you know a sexual
bullying as well and that's brought up
some really interesting Dynamics and I
my my is you've got this susceptibility
to bullying and and the environment
itself and if I'm having a really good
day and someone looks me up and down and
says your shoes don't really go with
your outfit I'm not going to feel too
bad you know but if I've had a really
bad day and I've just had some bad
patience and I'm feeling pretty lousy
and someone walks up to me and just goes
why did you do that I'm I'm you know if
that's my boss I'm going to feel pretty
bad so I think you've got this
susceptibility to to mental illness and
susceptibility to things like bullying
and negative pressures from outside and
then you've got the environment itself
and that that formal structure of of
especially medicine we' we've still got
this history of being very hierarchical
and therefore and you're always
intimidated by your boss you know that's
it's kind of part and parcel generally
speaking you're always going to
be and I I thought I was all right I
thought I was all right you now I
thought I was doing great so in our in
our course we well I closed my eyes and
put my fingers in my ear and the guys
asked how many people feel great feel
like they can challenge Steve and I
thought this is going to be Universal
I'm going to be great two out of 11
people put their hand up you know it's
like I'm running the god running the
course you said like me I've got
feelings and I'm where of yours is wrong
with you people you know and they didn't
feel that they could approach it I don't
know what was wrong but you should have
just given them flowers well yeah yeah
let's have a look at Far Cry um this
we're getting back to the dramatic
injuries very
realistic um so this this is just
standard you know oh that's a stick
that's not too bad he just takes it out
and cracks on I want to know whether
he's had a Tanis shot don't worry just
fix
it
I'm back with the
shooting and then honestly this goes on
for like a
while I think he need he needs to be
more careful
oh wasn't he just holding that no it's
fine don't worry about it don't even
worry it happened
again
just Pat it out you'll be
fine like this goes on for like
Jesus find that in the wilderness yeah
no I know right um yeah and then you
just crack on yeah yeah rub some dirt in
it it's fine just rub some dirt in it
the funny there's elements of that that
are just like yeah that is exactly what
you do rub dir in it I'm not coming to
your
emergency see I've had I've had a guy
turned up in uh West London with and his
arm was orange you had this big cut in
his arm his arm is orange what you done
better and no turmeric no way seriously
India turmeric it's you know a lot of
the a lot of the spices in Indian food
are because they have medicinal
properties you know you're dealing with
most most most populations in the world
ever have dealt with with with famine
you know and you're dealing with
whatever food you can find so how do you
make that food palatable well you you
put stuff in it that's either going to
kill the bugs um so that you don't get
DMV and gastritis or covers the taste
you know covers the taste so you a lot
of the stuff that's in in food it has
actually properties that probably have
some element of of of Truth in them and
help to some extent either to disguise
the disgusting flavor of whatever
protein or starch you're trying to
consume um or or actually have some sort
of effect on it so this guy came with
with chimmer but you know things like
relocating dislocations if you get on
with it quick you don't have the muscle
spasm and therefore you can reduce them
really quickly and with the minimum of
effort whereas if you you also have the
adrenaline Spike helping you deal with
it yeah um but over time especially
shoulders are the big one you see
someone coming with a shoulder get on
with it really quickly with minimum
analgesia and do it really nice and
slowly and lovely and gently and they go
back in quite nice I think the thing is
is that is that functionality afterwards
you know once you've dislocated
something you've ripped all the it's not
the bones it's not the bones that the
problem although it's obviously is
they're a bit of a problem but the
problem now not after is the ligaments
that hold them all together normally you
know a lot of joints don't have they're
not encapsulated joint the only joint I
know of that's encapsulated is a a bull
or a cow's leg uh joint that actually
one bone encapsulates the other and you
can't separate them but for for humans
most of the joints sit together and it's
the ligaments around actually hold them
in place once you've got that joint out
it means you've ripped all the ligaments
which means functionally it's not going
to work anymore don't don't you want to
like when I watch that all I want to do
is just like take him to theater and
just put like five liters of saline in
those wounds and just be like no this
isn't clean can you please
stop I'll just rip this thing out and
then like carry on in the desert like
there there there's no there's no bugs
there it's okay there's no no no no no
bacteria there St sterile area
my my art
teacher he he did get
malaria my old art
teacher worries to be honest does he
does he wake up with the night
[Music]
sweats oh good my old art
teacher my art teacher birdie Barnes
used to tell me that he used to put
spiderwebs in cuts to stop them bleeding
i' I thought was brilliant you have
heard of that yeah spider I think it's
got a large surface area I think that's
why it would work if you got a spider
web big enough but it's got large
surface area
and well I think I think it was just the
webs I don't think it was the spiders if
there's a little one lurking you
discourage it well you make it you tell
it to go away to be fair once you're
putting spider webs in your Cuts I don't
R about little spider to be honest like
um I have any of you guys seen Surgeon
Simulator no a bit I've heard about it
so there's no no I think there's a
version that you can do on Donald Trump
yeah there is I think that's the best
version yeah um so I want I want to take
questions but I also want to show you
guys this just cuz it's so funny and I'd
like to do it on mute because the only
thing I could find was a
YouTuber but um I'm sorry we can't so
we're going to have to listen to his
voice but um but have have a look and
see how much this reminds you guys of
your own experiences doing
surgery oh that's a good
[Laughter]
idea and you could do this on a t
course blah blah blah blah blah so
um so my number one criticism is
uh is the fact that he's not wearing
gloves
[Music]
gloves like if if he loses that watch in
the chest Cav waiting to happen that's
going to be a lawsuit right oh yeah um
so so now the both of the lungs are
gone he's probably got him on on bypass
he's on EO yeah he on he definely on
yeah he's not incubate he's not
in no he's not inting he's just got a
mask on he's just got an oxygen mask
there's no statist no I think the
greatest is that there is no scrub nurse
that can tell you which instrument to
use next I don't think he needs the
instruments at this point
and realistically I think he needs a
[Laughter]
lawyer oh yeah yeah
yeah you don't have to put all the other
bits back they're just they're extras
it's fine all you need is a heart and
then he's done good nurse you can Carry
On from here the do just replace the
lungs
thank um and and I also like the the
absence of anything else in there yeah
it's just just one heart and well most
of us only have one um you're surgeon
probably not even that and I also like
how he removes the rib cage oh I get
that you made an anti- surgeon joke I'm
on board with
this you just take off the whole rib
cage that's fine that's normal
I don't even we don't even need to go
into
that it's just so silly that is a very
realistic game that was that was surgery
last week
oh there is another one oh should we do
this that's why we pay theologist so
much
money um let's just skip to the
surgery so this is
um
this is eye
surgery I
think
eyes well he's upgraded from using his
bare hands so we just haven't confused
the CIA training
program what's this thing
can can I ask where the patient's arms
are why is he strapped
in probably because this guy's doing the
operating just chop him just Chuck My Oh
I thought that was for the surgeon maybe
it is maybe that's I'm surpris he's
doing it all with one
hand that's
[Laughter]
quite you can imagine he on his mobile
phone on the other hand isn't he he's
trying to text the Miss think I might be
H perform an ey transplant here's your
Hammer
go um is that enough of
that yeah it's not supposed to go that
far
in wow see see that was the mental
institutions back in the 70s and that's
how you do a labotomy well actually you
go through the nose oh terribly sorry
what I was doing
wrong how they take out the EG P when
you remove P Tre you go through the nose
cuz the bone at the Top's really small
but the bottomy I pick over the eye yeah
yeah it's pretty
horrific I wouldn't want
one
um
questions we've got a roaming mic um
this young gentleman's got one so has
has anyone got anything to ask my my
team of
doctors
um this this chat can you shout or
this I must admit I did think if I can
get this while my my CME and how many
how many medical professionals have we
got in here show ofans
awesome so if it's perer evaluated that
means I can probably sign off that's all
right yeah probably get five or six
points for this
one um
yep hi there um I'm interested in the
effect of adrenaline on people when they
have um an injury of some sort I read an
article about sword fighting that
suggested that um the most dangerous
time was actually just after you
inflicted the killing blow because
somebody was likely to keep going for a
good half hour half hour venine Rush
yeah that was that was what the article
was talking about yeah on the Fatal
depending on the Fatal I think it was
like in the chest region um but not
actually directly into the heart to the
level of of in I think it would depend
what the killing blow is I you know it's
it's a really nefarious kind of of
statement you know um so there zones of
death you know uh that you can that you
have there's the instant death you know
like the ripping off of the head you
know decapitation and stuff generally
speaking if you keep going for half an
hour I'm going to give in you can win
that one that's fine
um but so you've got your instantaneous
not compatible with Life injuries then
you've got your sort of was it your
platinum 10 minutes or golden 10 minutes
or platinum 10 minutes your golden hour
and then you've got your your survival
to hospital so the things that will kill
you within the first 10 minutes but
don't kill you instantaneously like an
aortic rupture that starts bleeding into
your chest um being a very very big
blood V vessel that comes off your heart
to feed the whole of your body yeah you
T it's called Atomic the atomic injuries
um not cuz it not of bombs cuz just a
pneumonic which uh doctors used to
remember lists um and then you've got
your your things that will kill you in
in the hour uh and then you got things
that kill you sort of later on like the
infection and things as well because
when you have massive trauma your your
body gives up all these inflammatory
inflammatory chemicals and they start
impeding your cell's ability to use
oxygen and actually metabolize and so
you become susceptible to systemic
illness your body's just overwhelmed by
the inflammations so I think it would
just depend on what kind of killer blow
you've inflicted um you know is it the
five finger heart exploding technique
that done or you know or is it the fact
that you've given someone an infection
with something that's really
nasty um yeah this chap
just cheers um I've actually got a
mental health question uh Dr hez I think
you mentioned in another panel that
there's an achievement for Drake killing
a thousand people and uh in Uncharted 2
he actually casually throws people off
the Himalayas for a good chunk of the
game oh absolutely yeah I was just
wondering um should his friends and
family be worried is there some like
issue that he has and and assuming like
that's diagnosable and assuming that he
what should he be doing between all the
horribly traumatic moments of his life
uh games that is to try and keep himself
on an even Keel or to recover I think I
think we also need to pose that question
for Lara Croft as well and the new Tomb
Raiders and her struggles with killing
multiple multiple people well they they
they started to acknowledge it there and
then they kind of backed off very
quickly and pretended it wasn't
happening which was a bit of a
disappointment so like in the the tomb
raid trailer Lara actually so showed
signs of PTSD but then they never
touched on it in the game which was a
bit of a shame because that would have
been a really fascinating and important
way of approaching that issue um in
Uncharted they they do actually they
actually mention it quite a few times
like the characters in their dialogue
were very casually just like make a joke
about you know oh why are we killing
these people like um and I always feel
really guilty as the player doing it um
I think I think Drake maybe I don't know
I don't know if you can pathologize him
well he's a
sociopath well no cuz he's
nice ching and all that apparently
Hitler was really nice to sit down and
have a cup of tea with you know he was a
Charming host you know just I can't see
that overall it balances out you know I
I you know and I I I don't reckon the
next Uncharted where they go and make
Easter bonnets together you know is
going to be the one that puts it all
right again you know whatever they got
to use the flowers killing that's the
Bonet bon in you they stop killing and
and place some Crush
Bandicoot I don't reckon it's going to
be a big seller
but um I can't answer that mostly mostly
out of personal bias because if I insult
Nathan I therefore insult Elena who is
my hero and Idol so you know probably
should seek a mental health professional
or their GP but I think you only got to
look at guys that do like Special Forces
you know that's their job that's what
it's what they do um and that being said
they do go through massive psychological
profiling and assessment and um they
keep a very close eye to make sure that
they don't have PTSD and there are you
know High rates of PTSD and people who
come back from war so there are you know
effects we just don't know whether Na
and Drake's feeling them because maybe
he's a
sociopath eat flowers eat flowers yeah
um man with microphone I'm you just do
what you want like give it to anyone I'm
happy he has the power he has the power
hey so in Portal and Portal 2 uh CH has
long full boots um what would the
construct of those longf boots need to
be for to survive those Falls and things
like that without much skeletal and
muscular damage um have you guys what
sort of distance what sort of distances
we talk she's dropping off some things
like like Big Ben yeah so with portal
you you have two Portal guns and they it
makes two doors that connect to one
another so um a few of the different
puzzles are solved by putting one on the
floor and one on the ceiling then going
through an infinite Loop reaching
terminal velocity and using that to
launch you to other places
exactly we're going to ignore the
physics break on how those guns
work that's not what was but she's got
these These boots right that um they
look like like at least they've put some
thought into it I like that um like
little spring boots you know I I always
thought that they looked like the the
running legs for the paralympians yeah I
think they need to be hydraulic I
reckon
yeah
yeah I think it would touch back on what
Steve was saying is that you'd have to
be able to deal with the amount of force
that's coming in and slow it
down you know sort of slow enough that
you you don't turn to jelly when you use
it they'd probably have to be about 15
ft tall yeah just massively collapsible
and the other thing is you don't want
them elastic because then you'd sort of
get to the bottom and then just shoot
off
again you
know
around
the you know they have to have sort of
you know like you know like it lifts in
in massive buildings you know they they
have Crump like literally B massive tin
cans uh and full of a liquid water or or
some sort of substance so if the lift
actually does fall then when it hits the
ground it decelerates over a sensible do
that that makes me feel better yeah so
you get a period of freeall but then
when you get to the bottom it's not
quite as yeah but I know but do you hit
your head on the top still I think that
would be the problem wouldn't it no
because you'd fall with the lift you'd
fall at the same speed you kind of like
probably slowly to you know You' lose
traction on the floor yeah so for a few
seconds you have a great laugh
but that honestly in the back of your
head um we we're out of time guys thank
you so much for coming can I have a big
round of applause for my
doctors
of course have a great pack guys much
guys thanks
lot yeah the
[Music]
door
[Applause]
[Music]
e
la
a
[Music]
yeah
he
[Music]
e
I don't know what grand scheme you've
got underway
Delila we'll
take but I'm coming to put you in your
grave
begin many
talk hey guys how are we all
it's day three that's way too loud um
welcome to the character creation
concept panel uh I'm Luke lanter with
CET but you really don't care about me
so let's run down the immensely talented
guests we have today we've got Leona
Yu Georg van
[Music]
kinberg FR
clusters and Davey Reen
that's good that sounds like we're done
we can get out of here now we're happy
with that um so today we're going to
make a video game character um but first
do you guys want to tell us a bit about
what you
do I'm starting you're first okay um I
used to be a freelance iller and then in
February I started working with Monty
games and I help out with crossy Road
Disney crossy Road and shoy sky so
hello y um hi everyone I'm Georgia and
um I do mainly voices in the Video Game
World uh do lots of other fun stuff like
nonprofits and philanthropies and
swimming and stuff but I also do voices
um so I've been uh a few really special
characters I'm very honored to be uh
venil in Final Fantasy uh thank
you um just got to do it it's like part
of the job um Star Wars um ends and rain
and Temple uh Diablo I Survivor and uh
payday to Sydney um so yeah get to do
those
things good day everyone I'm Trent
custers I'm co-founder and director at a
local independent game studio called
League of Geeks we made a game called
arelo thank you uh I'm also the chair of
the free play independent games Festival
which is Australia's largest and longest
running independent games festival and I
lecture at VCA on riding for
games uh good ey everyone I'm not
Australian uh my name is Davey I'm uh a
designer writer I was the writer of The
Stanley Parable and of the beginner's
guide and um thank
you and uh I live in Texas and I'm out
here for the week visiting and it's been
super lovely um so thank you very much
for having me
okay hot scoop as well Dave used to live
in Melbourne too that's true yeah what
okay let's get stuck in guys first thing
we need from you what genre what genre
game are we making just stick your hand
up don't be
shy there was a lot a lot of horror just
got pulled out okay horror romance
horror and heard RPG okay a horror
romance RPG is what we're doing all
right
lot of
oh okay so this cthulu dating Sim that
we've now settle with the overlap in Moy
noises is going to I'm very be very
potent to make those noises yeah yeah
you've just signed yourself up for this
you know
that okay um who's our character who was
our main character someone's that
someone are you okay with that
um I'd prefer she was not a
dad we'll go with someone's mom we'll go
with someone's
mom stac Stacy's mom that was awesome
she's got it going on she
does okay um can we get the screen
up oh we're not done yet this is this is
the test as you can clearly see okay so
we have our concept we have
something slightly better than a blank
slate designers do your thing Where Do
We Go From
Here make for
us H so we have someone's someone's Mom
it's a horror romance RPG I guess are we
are we play is are we playing the
character you are playing as the right
this is the playable character this is
the playable
character who's who's okay who's going
to give us some kind of like thing that
this character wants or is trying to
achieve in the horror romance RPG game
yeah Okay no Okay there it is good all
right Stacy the
child Stacy's gone missing
everyone so I think when like when I
first start to look at characters I I
think about traits and it's it's a
little tool that I've used is like a
trait Diamond so to speak so four things
that
person you know for traits or quality so
are
they you know are they persistant are
they arrogant are they stubborn are they
um reliable things like that so I I
reckon that's a good good place to start
maybe with with four four traits well so
it's actually kind of interesting when
you say that thinking about it because
horror and RPG are kind of two sort of
styles of game that have tend to give
their protagonist very opposite traits
right like horror games tend to make the
protagonist very weak right so that you
feel like you're constantly threatened
by something but RPGs tend to make their
protagonist very powerful so that you
can like literally kill God so like now
so this is kind of curious like where
how do you like if if it is going to be
a horror game it has to be like this
protagonist has to have like yeah have
to have like a lot of sort of some
weaknesses that come out in the game
play you know
what we'll just yeah go for
itan yeah horror game with RPG mechanics
right right right yeah so then you
dating Sim as well don't forget dating
Sim da dating Sim okay I like it are you
dating are you dating the things that
you're that are chasing they going to
kill you that sounds like regular dating
yeah yeah uh Tinder RPG
yeah I think I think for a lot of horror
games we're going to require that our
protagonist like be totally uh in the
dark um all
right yeah and that's true because that
Mother's Love for a child would keep her
weak pretty much the whole time because
she's going to do
anything oh that's a good one that's a
good one okay so like the mother that's
her Crypt yeah she yeah she will throw
herself in danger for the child you know
when they in the horror movies when they
go into the basement you're like what
the [__] don't do that what are you
doing well there's a really good reason
post they're going to make it to the end
what was that I said if they're on the
poster they're going to make it to the
end unless okay I like the idea that
it's not that like like her child has
been taken away from her or something
the child is just an idiot and just
wanders off into like really really bad
scenarios yeah just like God damn Stacy
stop stop come
back what world are they in by the way
oh that's a good one it looks like we've
got a picture of Stacy's mom as like a
set character do you guys prefer set
characters where do you like to factor
in player
customization that's a that's a really
good question and I think in the
creation of a game like that comes quite
early on like you'll know whether your
game is a type of game where you're
going to be role playing a character
like an Etso or whether you're actually
going to just have some sort of Skyrim
esque character customization thing so H
I think that we should go with a second
well it's character creation panel right
so we should probably create yeah create
a set character and then the RPG
elements can be the
progressive um I guess skill set that
that the character has and Dave you were
talking about the um traits like the
traits you like to have early on when
you go into design how do you represent
those in like in gameplay in design in
the choices you make I mean I like to
cheat uh I don't I don't like giving
people a lot of control over what
they're going to do I like I like uh
saying okay here's this very specific
scenario and I'm like I have this I have
this idea in mind for this story that I
want to tell and I'm only G to give you
options I'm only going to give the
player options that fit with this like I
don't know this very narrow I don't know
it's like a thing a lot of games like to
be like you can do anything you can make
your character be like all sorts of
wacky stuff and uh I'm like I don't know
I would rather I would rather tell like
a much more specific story about story
gets to be stronger that way question
yeah
yeah there you go did you say Mafia
packed C pack a mafia packed
fantastic we do to bring in the romance
somewhere so yeah um how do you guys go
about I mean of course she hat the
moners because she's looking for a new
partner because her old one made a mafia
pack with cthulu and
um if we are looking at the monsters and
the dad and the daughter now how does it
different to designing NPCs to play
characters well I guess the the first
thing is when you think about NPCs is
how do you how are we going to interact
with them so there are different types
of NPCs you know you have your enemy
characters which you know you might be
interacting with them in by combat
because really what you have a lot of
the time or really all you have in games
is are the verbs that the player can can
perform right and so if and are there
NPC that we can escort that we can we
can hang out with and things like that
so that's how I would start with that
one yeah yeah sure sure she's dating
eldrid Horrors why not you know she's an
equal opportunity
employer getting deep I did
say
[Music]
Y and that's that's something as a voice
actor that we were discussing just
yesterday it's a huge consideration
because as I was sharing with these guys
in Star Wars because it's
multi-directional uh literally I can get
my lines where it's either you're
married to the character or you've just
met them and you have to deliver exactly
like both of those so it's definitely
something to consider that if if you're
going to take it multi-directional that
it needs to be a character that could
isn't going to be polar either way
because it's just not going to work so
are these just like the technical limits
of branching narratives yeah you really
do have to consider with the branching
narratives that the the character has to
grow but you have to watch that growth
so it actually is consistent because
otherwise it's going to look super weird
I do think it is kind of interesting
that we could go down the idea of like a
RPG sort of system where what you're
doing is I don't know having dialogues
with say you know I guess specters like
sexy ghost
specters right well that that's how you
work the dating thing in there right
it's like you're you're sort of trying
to kill them but you're also maybe
looking for someone who's going to feel
a part of you that you
know i' love it ghost to be like I need
you to feel my see through
self oh God guys looks like what have I
done what have we got myself just you
wait till we drop the lines in you're in
trouble so so what was the line from the
Star Wars game Georgia oh gosh well um
the first one when
um the one where I literally said to the
director cuz I walked in and he was like
okay it's we're leveled up we got new
levels um we don't have Graphics yet
she's just arrived and she says it's
been for I it was something along the
lines if it's been forever where have
you been I need your help and I said
great so have I just met and he goes
well you could be married but you could
have just
met cool I'll give that read but it was
that thing yeah it was along the lines
of meeting like you come across this
person you have to deliver it like
they're your husband or a
stranger I mean they could be both
that's true it's true in this world I'm
C I was just curious Leon what what
you're do yeah what what you're
imagining here I am imagining a very
practical mother who has to survive in a
horror world and I don't know how to
make her datable so I gave her lipstick
but I don't know I don't know where to
go from there but I'm just trying to
figure it out and this program keep
keeps like stopping up on me so excuse
me if I keep closing the program and
opening up again that's what's happen
you gave me an idea though I feel like
her lipstick should have some sort of
power ooh oh like when you kiss other
people it doesn't come off on
them that is magical if you could work
out how to do that Trent I'll buy it um
okay so one thing we keep referring to
her as Stacy's mom what is Stacy's Mom's
name it's just Stacy's
mom I feel like
d but like St a z y z m u m like all one
word yeah yeah yeah I love it
[Music]
yeah oh
interesting
you know George is right there we can't
really have I spill that everywhere
that's on me
guys de how do we take that and put it
the laptop it's fine so yeah that's
really interesting this topic has come
up a few times um throughout the week at
different panel some things like that um
and and I think that largely depends on
the format of the game like I used the
Etso uh example before if you're playing
something like an Assassin's Creed that
has a heavily authored character and
they're in front of you they're like
it's a third person perspective then
it's easier for you're seeing them
constantly on screen it can be harder to
be like oh this this player this
character has no name who is it but
they're right there it's more of a role
playing thing um but if it's a first
person thing like say Bioshock that's
where the character doesn't talk at all
you're completely a silent protagonist
uh I think the no-name thing can work
really well there uh so here's a
question uh this game is it first person
third
person isometric third
person isometric first
person boom boom there it is
yeah
wow okay it's exciting to you yeah
that's it you know what's you know
what's interesting is that very recently
undertale did a lot of this but all in
first person as far as like all of the
combat goes or the interactions goes so
it is it is possible to do it first
person and still like have a very like
heavily identified sense of like who you
are you know um totally but that was
like I don't know that was definitely a
sort of on the that was very unusual I
thought it was very
uh definitely not wouldn't have been my
first choice if I were doing that kind
of thing um because yeah cuz like seeing
this person and so and and again it's an
interesting question about whether or
not they should talk because we're we're
we're make we're talking about literally
like a like a romance like a dating Sim
kind of thing here right and so hearing
hearing this person talk might
uh like it depends you're taking a risk
right like you're taking the risk that
the that the player won't identify with
that voice right or won won't identify
so I think it's there's kind of this
tradeoff where when you give that
character like a much more specific
voice and you make them sound like they
are a particular thing you're someone
who clicks with that is going to go
really really deep with that character
right like going to really really dive
into that you know person like uh yeah I
don't know take Bioshock was brought up
right like is there more uh cosplay of
Jack or of Andrew Ryan right there's
obviously more Andrew Ryan because like
we can see him andar him and really like
actually identify with him a little bit
more I definitely sorry I was going to
say I I don't know man like Mass Effect
is basically a dating him and that's
fully voice acted that's true there's so
many people that are like had done
naughty things to my friend Ellie
Hillis you just going to drop that
and um she's one of the leades in
that it's third person though as well
Mass Effect so I think leaning into this
we have this this really strong idea of
this character Stacy's mom um it's a
horror film as well um a horror film
horror game um I think and also like a
dating Sim if I'm thinking about a lot
of dating Sims you like you're seeing
the characters on screen you want to see
the reactions you everything I think we
should be leaning into it making it
something like a a third person game you
where it's like you're actually you're
seeing the character like you're
reminded that you are you are role
playing Stacy's mom I think for the sake
of creating a character it's better to
see them yeah yeah well this is this is
what I mentioned before like when you
when you n when you uh uh narrow down
the amount of stuff that your character
is going to possibly be doing based on
player input just makes it so much
easier to design you know you're not
thinking about like you have to spend
less time thinking about every
individual Edge case of like what if the
you know player decides that like oh
this is going to happen this is going to
happen this is going to happen we have
to have 50 different you know possible
outcomes and all of those have to be
welld designed because we want the
player to feel good about all of them
and they all have to be produced and
voice acted so like yeah certainly when
you start thinking about the production
of this kind of thing which you know
this is all fantasy right now so we
don't have to think about production
like we could just sit up here and be
like there 5 million endings you know um
but like that is certainly as a designer
you really have to think about that and
you have to go oh okay I've decided that
I want you know Stacy's mom to have 50
different ways that she could end this
based on each of the 50 different moners
moners in this game that she could be
dating right and you're like well that's
the next 3 years of my life that's going
to be spent you know making like making
and implementing all of those things
right at what point do those design
concerns start to become part of the
character creation process how much does
one inform the other oh like right away
depends yeah it depends but I I would
recommend
immediately yeah for sure the decisions
that you make early on with characters
can 100% come back to bite you later on
I remember I was working um the studio
we were doing a game and it was when I
sort of first started and I was writing
up the scripts and everything and I
wrote the script for a Cuts scene and I
said and then everyone
applauded and my the lead animator we
were sitting there doing a script
reading and he's like everyone wait
who's everyone and I was like the the
crowd like that's gathered and he's like
you just added like 40 NPCs to our
budget I'm like ah okay yeah all right
no one
applauds no applause yeah just play the
sound it's fine you don't need the card
just it's a track it's an audience track
um so what do you guys like to do to
make these characters compelling cuz
that's that's the goal right making
characters that players can connect with
I think everyone has wants and desires
so a big question that I always ask
myself I think that that gets you
started off really well is like what is
what is this character want and that
it's a very multi-layered question and
you can ask it time and time again after
you answer it you you can ask it again
and then find out what else they want so
you know because you can say with you
know if you use Indiana Jones rers of
their lost Arc as an example it's like
what does IND Indie want it's like he
wants the arc right he wants the arc but
then if you ask no what does indie want
then it's a very different question
right yeah exactly and you can keep
going and you can start I I remember
when I was studying uh writing and
editing one of my uh mentors and
teachers said like writing is a lot like
just opening a series of doors and then
just taking a look at what's on the
other side and and I think that's what
you're doing a lot when you're when
you're creating characters like you keep
asking those deep questions like like a
psychologist would ask to you you know
it's like tell me about your mother and
you're like tell her like and how does
that make you feel and how does that
actually make you feel you know like
that's what you're doing about these
characters on paper you're like no but
you know what do they want what are
their flaws you know and just keep on
deep diving so how a game character is
different to like a character in a
book I mean fundamentally they're not
right or hopefully they're not I think I
think that my my least favorite game
characters are are charact are games
that treat their characters like their
games you know um because I because I
feel like a like a like a game kind of
thing is meant to be you know the way
the way that a lot of times we
traditionally think about games is like
oh you have to be able to I don't know I
mentioned this before but like you have
to be able to decide everything about
how this player about how this character
is going to turn out and everything
about their personality and that should
all be the decided by the player and I
don't know I I think that that can lead
to some good things but I think that
when I as a designer have had the time
to really sit down and think about like
taking time ahead of time and going what
does this character want and need and
think and feel and I try and put that
into the game and put that into the
story that's not really any different
than when you're writing a short story
or you know making a film or whatever
you're still sitting down and going all
right what who like who really is this
character if we flush them out you know
and and that's something that uh I think
Final Fantasy does extremely well is
that before each game starts being
created or recorded and there's a Bible
for every single one of those games and
we are all required to know it and read
it and go through it before we even go
into record so it really was like I was
stepping into a book and I think what
makes gains different to books is simply
that we get to interact with the book
that's it you know it's still the should
be the same level of development of a
character with a story with a need with
a want with an arc the difference is
that in a video game you get to discover
that with the character whereas with a
book you're a less active you know
participant but Final Fantasy I mean
they literally like this thing this
thick about who I was am will be where
it's going what the world is they've
done the book before they come to the
game do you find that kind of limiting
creativ
um that's a really good question because
it's so it's just a different Choice
like you know for Final Fantasy I knew
already like a um they' already done the
Japanese version so there was very
little that I was actually I was
actually required to be certain things
like it was very clear you need to be
just for those people out there that
want to know this I was required to be
annoying from the start not just that I
am annoying um it was a direction um
because I'm uncovering so they asked
that but like when we created payday um
that was a conversation with the global
brand director that went hey do you want
to create a character for a Payday with
me so at that point that's when I get to
play but you just know what you're
coming into you either know it's been
created for you or you get to have some
creative control and even if a character
is incredibly authored when you get
there I mean it's still coming through
you too right so there's just inherent
like uh interpretation there yeah you
have to find where you resonate with it
I think something interesting with
characters in games and potentially
where it differs is perhaps not in the
creation process but in how you frame a
character in regards to like how you
frame them in your game how they're
presented uh like much like in theater
you know where people stand in
particular places and things like that
you have all your spots marked out going
back to the Bioshock example there's a
reason why in BioShock you like you'll I
forget her name but the um the doctor
that throws you Something From A Balcony
like or someone's talking to you through
a peole like there's a reason why um
irrational don't let you get within a
range of a character where you can
interact with him in ways that would
create a dissonance between the
narrative and what you're actually doing
like you know you're trying to fire your
gun at someone and it's like what
happens then do we do we actually show
the feedback or the hits or do we just
let it pass through them and like what
does that mean you know everyone's been
in that room at the start of halflife 2o
where um Alex and Eli are talking and
you're just jumping in the corner you
know um that sort of stuff is something
that I think comes into account a lot
and Ken LaVine spoke about this in a GDC
talk once where he knew that they could
do photorealistic rooms but they
couldn't do NPCs to the degree which
they were able to do them um for
infinite right so they had to be very
particular about how they actually frame
these NPCs and how many they had and
they actually went through the game at a
later stage in the process and cut like
more than half of the NPCs from the game
and then solidify them into different
characters I think that's an interesting
thing as well like I remember I was
working um on a Scooby-Doo game and yeah
as you do and it's like a action
adventure game like if you imagine Lego
Star Wars but uh with Mystery Inc and so
we're um we're at Alpha which is like
sort of halfway or just past halfway on
the games project
and I was told that by the art lead that
we had one NPC too many he was like look
it it doesn't look like we're going to
get to make this eth NPC or whatever
we're only going to have a budget for
seven and I was like
well what do you mean like that's
totally H like that's part of this whole
level blah blah blah he's like look I'm
I'm sorry we got to find a way to work
around I'm like all right I'll think of
something and then I came back to him
like 10 minutes later and I was like can
you give me an animating door and he was
like what and I said what is if we never
saw the character but the character was
scared of the wendigo monster and ran
away and locked itself in the basement
and so we just need like you know there
American style basement doors we just
need them doing that and he was like
yeah we can probably do that and I was
like all right cool so we went from
having this fully concepted character
was going to be animated and walking
around the level and you interact with
them and move around with them to just
putting them in this like basement of
the ouse of this hotel and we just made
these doors fla and got all the lines
recorded and and that was how we got our
eighth NPC into the game so I think in
games you've got to be incredibly
resourceful I mean creating a character
animating them and everything is a huge
overhead and so it's it all has to do
with how you frame them I think I think
that has a lot of considerations in
games that perhaps other mediums don't
have that actually makes me think of
Stacy in like maybe this game where you
know where Stacy's mom is running around
and these doors are closing all opening
and closing all over the place place and
you hear Stacy's voice but also you're
dating monsters look I don't know you
guys made these suggestions we can work
the door in just the talking door can be
one of the options talking door there
you go what if Stacey is a talking door
W okay so you said overhead which means
this question's fair game how important
is it to make your characters
marketable um that's that's really
interesting okay so for those of you who
are familiar with our game arelo that is
is basically everything to do with the
game like it's a hero based game um the
heroes are the box art they are our hero
shots um creating those Heroes that
speak to particular player fantasies or
archetypes uh but at the same time seem
like they have complex backgrounds and
are interesting characters in and of
themselves and are fun to role play um
whether it be barab like the kid Mad
Tinker rabbit um which is a bit of comic
relief for this stoic you know um Archer
River who I call Arrow dog um that's
like it's really important to us and I
think for that particular genre we take
a look at things and approach them
similar to like how OverWatch would um
you know you can see you look at every
OverWatch character you I mean I don't
know if any of you have seen the insane
9 foot Reinhardt cosplay that's walking
around the show for um but like that's
that's case in point of um the power of
creating like you know marketable
character is is is a there is Sombra
cosplay already yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
pretty amazing i i al I think that the
the one of the Holy Grails of character
design is really good comedy like it's
so hard but if you can make your
character really funny like that [__]
sells like it really does and uh and I
don't know it's it's tough though
because it when when uh when it when
you're going for comedy with with a
character or with your game in general
and it falls
if it falls flat Falls really really
flat like it hurts so much worse so you
I don't know I find comedy to be kind of
this like big risk that you can take
that really makes it really makes it
sing if you pull it off so is Stacy's
mom hilarious of course of course that's
on you guys you're creating I just get
to say yes well maybe that's you know
it's a great when you have a horror game
or sorry a horror film if we look at the
horror
genre humor comedy is a coping mechanism
for a lot of characters I mean there's
always that goofball character in the
slasher films you know
um's probably cops it halfway through
you know um but I I think there's
probably there's there's room there for
Stacy to maybe be dealing with the the
horror elements of the game and the the
predicament that she's in with a bit of
humor and I mean if you can't laugh
about the fact that you're you're dating
monsters we kind of have to make yeah
sort of you you're not you're if we
don't make it at least a little bit
comedic it's never going to we're never
going to sell the horror SL dating Sim
aspect you can just see it that same way
she's like you're just such a monster oh
hang on you
are yeah I imagine that like there's all
these Monsters Everywhere and Stacy's
mom keeps trying to date them and
they're like dude seriously we're
monsters what are you
doing so um how much do you guys like
working with those archetypes do you
prefer to I guess pay homage to that
kind of thing if you're making a horror
game do you want those stock horror
characters in
there I I like to subvert I think I
think that's the real thing I
think cliche is bad but understanding
the power of archetypes and knowing like
having a great back catalog in your mind
of tropes um is is there are so many
good tools there and there are ways to I
mean everything's a remix right like
every piece of media is other pieces of
media mashed up and SP back out so
so yeah see this is good this is what we
yeah very good hang on I'm dating
zombies
now moners are are these zombie monsters
we did say she likes all sorts yeah yeah
yeah she does have a a spectrum of
interests I like it zombies is cool we
could go for a bit of a warm blood angle
with the romance so how do you feed
players cues like that like we kind of
know who Stacy's mom is just because she
wants to go find some love zombies you
know it's interesting what's happening
here this Dynamic I really I think this
really highlights the collaborative
nature of game design too like uh we
just look at the screen and Leon's
written loving zombies and we're like ah
okay yeah maybe maybe they are zombies
you know like different disciplines and
working with different people across the
team get informed like the direction you
go along I really like one one thing
that I really like is um trying to like
obviously if you have I this could be
true for comedy but it could be true for
any character attribute in your game is
that like oh we want to um tell the
player that the character likes a
certain thing and one way that you can
do that is have a cutc scene where where
where
Stacy's good job very
good uh you know so like one way to do
that is like have a cut scene where
Stacy's mom sees a zombie and she's like
hey I'm into zombies and another way to
do that is a battle starts and a menu
just opens up and says just go find some
Ling zombies and then you know and you
didn't have to have the cut scene it
just kind of like it just makes it like
an organic part of the actual game that
you're playing I always really like
those kinds of things where it feels
like you're you're sort of discovering
uh this who this character is by
actually playing as them um because like
it'll give you options that are like the
kinds of things that that character
would do and then you're like oh that's
what this character would do because
those those are the options that I've
been given uh and like in this case I
think this is a great example of that
yeah yeah it's true like the menu
options can really speak to that I I
just just had this crazy thought I
remember I was in Seattle um earlier
this year or maybe last year hanging out
with some friends in Game Dev and I was
walking home with one of them and this
homeless guy came up to us and he was
chatting to one of my friends about um
his DOTA jacket he's like that's a
really good jacket man and we were
chatting to him for a little bit then he
asked for some money and we we gave him
some money and then he walked off and as
he walked off one of my friends she goes
God that homeless guy was so
hot
and I was like wow yeah actually he was
so maybe maybe that's how tie it back
together yeah so maybe Stacy's mom all
this stuff is going on right oh come on
yeah Stacy's mom all this stuff is going
on her daughter's gone missing during a
zombie apocalypse right so that's the
worst thing they're like all right we're
going to get out of here get out of town
the zombie apocalypse is happening then
her daughter goes missing and then
during all of the madness trying to find
him she just passes is like this really
attractive zombie and she's like H like
that sty cross lover thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah sorry was that
yeah Stacy's mom she could be Stacy
senior by putting up emotional walls
yeah
[Laughter]
can that actually be like a power you
get emotional wall and it just comes up
and the zombies are like yeah she
doesn't fight the zombies she just puts
off walls to like redirect them that's
so smart I don't want to talk about it
yeah so maybe the dating part isn't
actual dating maybe it's all like I'm
not ready to address that yet yeah it's
been it's been so soon since I was
really hurt by that so like can we
please maybe come back to that later
yeah exactly we can discuss that in
chapter
eight okay so how important are visual
cues in letting a player know what a
character can do oh incredibly important
like I I definitely think that
[Music]
um
it's you have a hot zombie very good as
far as uh video game characters are
concerned especially like NPCs enemies
stuff like that uh form 100% follows
function so I
mean like how shitty would Zelda be if
like the bosses didn't have like a big
flashing red thing that you had to you
had to attack and you knew and so and
also it gives like little cues right
tell you a lot about about characters
you think
of even just something like like
Uncharted you look at what Drake is
wearing and you're like ah yeah okay I
totally understand what this dude is
about for
sure um okay so who he has played
firewatch cool um you don't see the
characters in that game is this well you
see chunky arms see feet and you see
chunky arms and you see a wedding ring
oh yeah okay but how do you play with
that space when you're just learning
about a character through their
conversation with another
character God yeah like I've seen it's
interesting like you see a lot of fan
art I have seen I have seen fan art to
firewall that you know depict the
characters in all of these different
ways like they're the two main
characters of the game but like the all
of the fan art for it is totally
different yeah I think that's really
interesting you know that uh that well
it's cuz it's all it's all done through
just like really well done um really
well- written character choices and
character choices I mean like the
writing for that game is like you know
they knew who those characters were
ahead of time you're not playing as
blank slates right you're not playing as
like like when when when firewatch gives
you character choices uh or sry excuse
me dialogue choices um each of those
dialogue choices is not like this
character could be someone completely
different it's more I think of it more
like uh these are different things that
are on this character's mind you know
like this character the same character
could say any of these things and you're
just getting to choose which of the
things that's on this character's mind
are they actually saying um I think
that's a really effective way to think
about characters in terms of giving
players choices like I still get to
choose what I'm saying but but like the
core of that character is still there
from the very beginning and honestly at
that point you just I it just comes down
to writing well which is hard to cuz
that just takes
practice I was going to say that it's
like video games or the craft of video
games you just start with a toolbox and
depending on the decisions that you make
some tools are just put aside and like
when you go to touch them they're like B
no you're a first person game the player
doesn't get to see like what you look
like uh and you know there are times
when you can maybe put that in your game
like the character looks in a mirror or
something like that or maybe your cut
scenes are external to the first person
view um or maybe it's a franchise where
the character already knows what they
look like it's a first person Bond game
for example and you know what um 64bit
Pierce brosen looks like um but it's
really what it means is that you just
you just have less tools you for this
particular Journey this particular video
game that you're crafting you're leaning
into other tools and I think that's what
yeah having fewer tools is actually like
such a good such a good good thing
because you can't do that much so you
have to do what you're you have to make
something really good out of exactly
what you have and uh it forces people to
be forces you to be really creative as a
writer or a designer or whatever you
know you're like okay I know that we
can't look at my character so how do I
get people to really care about them and
you have to really dig and really come
up with with interesting creative
material that you wouldn't have if you
would had like a hundred artists who
were like we're going to craft every
individual detail and they're like okay
we'll just let the artists do their
thing right and you'd stop thinking
about how to actually make this
character really compelling um just on
the note of like hundreds of artists
working on concept stuff how much do
modelers hate concept
artist oh well if they're not working
together well I mean if the concept
artist is a jerk sure um no I I think
you'd be surprised how closely they work
together like for sure um and a really
good concept Artist as well like a good
friend of mine his name is Richard lines
he's a senior concept artist at Naughty
Dog worked on our mow as well with us um
he's just absolutely phenomenal like if
you see like just his sheets and sheets
and sheets of like the standard trooper
from Uncharted or the heavy Trooper or
the you know the the paramilitary guys
in the eighth level or you know and you
just look at and then all of the
variations as well because you know
they're the same
rig they're the same actual 3D model but
then they have these different
attachments to basically be able to
create like 30 or 40 variations of an
enemy um out of just a couple of Base
models it's incredibly amazing um
process but that that type of person um
that type of concept artist who's just
really thinking about who's had the
experience to know what goes into the
modeling side of things working with the
modeling team um to really understand
what they need to do and what they need
to show and I mean it's uh those I don't
think two two roles work more closely
together perhaps than than those
two okay so we're looking at Stacy's mom
again you have pumped out so many
drawings that's really impressive I know
what I like about this version of
Stacy's mom cuz I've been looking at her
she doesn't look so like in the other
ones she looks super
needy like she needed that zombie really
badly she's
more before the zombie show zombie
yeah yeah so so so so did she come to
learn over time that she was actually
the
zombie that she didn't need the zombies
to Feel Complete yeah cuz that's I guess
that's what we haven't discovered yet oh
no well well that's probably why she's
peaceful um that makes sense uh it's a
sad lesson for dating one cannot be at
peace until this um
but I I do think it it's something that
we haven't really discussed is why is
she dating so much on the quest to find
her daugh like I was thinking like we
haven't we haven't really talked about
like what Stacy is like or excuse me
what Stacy's mom is like we haven't
talked about like a a flaw of hers or
something that you know she's like
struggling with
yeah yeah in conjunction with the
mafia
yeah I actually think there's an
interesting like tension here between
like Stacy's mom is looking for Stacy
but also keeping an eye out for like
some you know someone to come along
and right she's like this is my
opportunity suddenly the odds just get
swung away into her favor maybe as well
it's just got to be to do with her
dating past I
mean did she keep the HS is that like a
scalping
yeah you I mean like if you date enough
guys who are dead inside I'm sure actual
dead guys would start becoming pretty
attractive what are you talking about TR
I have no
idea um so what do you guys like about
Stacy's mom why is she interesting as a
game protagonist apart from the zombie
head
fetish I mean so like there's this
distinctly comedic thing where like
she's treating the zombie apocalypse as
a dating opportunity
um which is like which is kind of which
obviously is sort of like Goofy and sort
of surreal but it also has this like I
don't know this element of like someone
trying to see the best in a really
shitty situation and there's something
that's kind of endearing about that you
know like I I like the idea that I like
the idea that everything is going in the
complete opposite direction of what
Stacy's mom is is you know for like
every her the her uh former partner
summoned cthulu and the zombie
apocalypse and her daughter's gone
missing and she's like I'll bet you
there's an upside to this right she's
she's she ever The Optimist yeah and I
and yeah and I kind of like that and
things are sort of like a little weird
and up in the air for her but she's like
and so I mean yes like there's this very
goofy thing but I like the kind of
endearing optimism underneath that yeah
she's getting more and more like I
didn't want to make her American but
she's sounding more and more the way
that like from I live in LA and there's
just this breed of woman there that no
matter what you say they think it's
great oh that's super great that and I
feel like Stacy's Mom's becoming more
the like oh my God you're like so super
cute even though you're like dead and
stuff I feel like she's got I've wanted
her to be Australian just so I could say
Stace
but now but maybe that's what she named
her daughter she's American but she
named her daughter SCE yeah it's true
she like oh my God you're like super
dude I'm looking for
sty okay that's what's happening okay
okay I think we're at that point now um
we're ready to give her a voice right so
we need some awful monster pickup lines
oh monster pickup lines monst to pickup
lines all
right
uh
so many bones which one to
pick yeah we're brains are a theme here
you're drop dead gorgeous brains and
Bones let's just do pick up lines for
zombies the next
panel under oh all
right
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I kind of wanted to have like great
pickup lines like responses but then I
also just feel like it could be funny if
she just
Giggles to everything it's so good like
a sea of like zombie dudes who don't who
don't moan they just drop really bad
pick
[Music]
there it is all right oh wow guys this
is too fun you just resurrected me very
good very good um okay I think we should
open up the questions cuz we are rapidly
running out of time there's some mics on
either side if you guys have questions
for our panelists or if you just want to
keep shouting out pickup lines this is
hi um I'd like to talk about the
character arcs that could be explored in
the in this game because I don't think
we have touched on how the character is
going to grow throughout the game mhm
yeah yeah well we're definitely like it
sounds like the direction we're going is
that we have like this sort of like
Stacy's mom is like could end up like
finding Stacy but also could end up
finding love in the zombie apocalypse so
like I mean potentially if you want to
go multiple endings there could be like
Stacy's mom decides that you know her
family was the most important thing
versus the pursuit of her own like if
you I don't know if you give this
character like some kind of like she has
to she has to choose and she has to give
up one of those things right and and you
know that's not bad everyone has to go
through that but it's like if we sort of
if there's some kind of Arc where it
becomes clear to her that she can only
have one of them right maybe when her
maybe when her husband summoned cthulu
and broke her heart um maybe she was so
heartbroken and upset about that that
she went out dating and all these sort
of things and just I guess neglected her
relationship with her daughter Stacy and
the arc is that she realizes that she
doesn't need a man to be complete or
whatever and that her relationship with
her daughter is the woman who don't need
no zombie
exactly um yeah and that her
relationship with her daughter uh is all
that she needs what if we take it to
another level and that's the story we
think we're getting but it's a
psychological Thriller horror genre and
she's actually healing her inner
child Stacy doesn't
exist she's looking
[Applause]
for um I think we should ask Leon some
questions cuz you're me in there
hi hi um how did you just in like five
sketches flesh out Stacy's mom so
well I was panicking actually because
the program kept going no it's not
responding and then uh howow I just
thought hm if I had a mother what would
she look like and hang on this is the
Deep story into um and uh I don't know
it just turned out really quirky because
that's what I person Le yours yeah I
noticed you gave her like almost evil
eyes yes I did I want to I want to
understand where your head went cuz I
love it don't get me wrong but the way
she was looking at that zombie had a lot
of deeper thought behind it what was
your thought on it she has personal
issues
so uh so you're talking about this one
was it no no oh that one she looks
peaceful there this this one yeah look
at that that one well she needs some Lin
so she has to get somewhere that's why
it's just that simple yeah yes it makes
her look like the creepiest thing in the
game it it should be she's totally like
hanging on that zombie I'm going to get
you you got to be
aggressive
yeah okay so um do you often build
personality when you do that is that
what you like to do when you're creating
character sketches or is it more this is
what the character looks like just go to
work um I like like drawing things
characters out like see how they are
like when they are themselves so that's
why I drew Drew this one because that's
obviously her like trying to hit on a
zombie so uh yeah I just like to keep
sketching because it's more iteration
because you keep drawing the same
character you quickly develop the
character into something more fleshed
out
yep is okay so at what point do you guys
know if a character is going to work or
not
oh when you shipped your game oh no yeah
totally um I think it's a it's a large
misconception that um games are just
great and fantastic the whole time long
development I mean you talked to The
Last of Us crew and like that game
apparently was like not fun 6 weeks
before they shipped and then it was like
a few last things came together and it's
like oh oh cool this is like one of the
best games released in the last 10 years
um and and I think it's much the same
for the characters that you create and
everything as well like you and there's
always that if you are one of those
creative types it's you know super
self-critical of your work and
everything you're just perpetually
doubting everything until the end and
all you see is the holes but when you
get it out there and you see how it
works like obviously we get data on like
how many um like the rate of what
characters are played uh in our mow you
know we have 20 heroes or something like
that and we can see like who's played
the most and and um how many Times by
particular players and things like that
and so when you have that data and then
you're seeing okay well who's creating
fan art of which character the most I
mean like you see those reactions in the
community I mean not every OverWatch
character is being cosplayed here but I
mean bashton would be pretty intense um
but I think that's a really like those
sort of things are a really good uh
metric for how much people identify with
your character I mean you go to you went
to PS after transistor was released and
like 40% of the cosplay was red so yeah
I think you have to be excited from the
from the beginning like you don't know
whether or not something is going to
work but you got to you got to really be
stoked for it you know cuz like it's
going to take a long time and you're
going to go through a lot of iteration
and if you don't really love that the
idea of this thing I mean like already
here we've got like a sort of a a
concept for Stacy's mom and like who she
is and what she does and it's funny like
it's it's interesting there's actual
like there's something here right and I
think if if if we were sitting down to
make something and and we were like
that's it's okay I mean it's you know
it's a character it works it could
conceivably if like then that would be
really hard to sustain through all of
the time that it's going to take to work
this thing over and over and over and
get it really get it really good and
that's something that you see like from
the character design as far as the
narrative goes which I really love is
when I get to speak to the narrative
team or when I get to talk to a producer
about the character before we even
create it as a voiceover you kind of
Blown Away how much they know about this
character before they bring it to you
you're like really you know like for
Sydney payday like they had she was from
like these are Swedish guys and they
sent me a document like she's from
Frankston and I was like how do you know
about
Frankston like I do but mind you they
wanted to call it the gang the frangers
and I was
like let me explain you can't do that um
but it is an incredible thing to see
even in Final Fantasy for those of you
that have played 13 hope is a very
challenging character as far as the
personality goes and they love hated him
so much like the The Producers were like
he's the most annoying thing ever and we
love it so whether it's good or bad
there has to be that passion behind the
character for what it is whether it's
good whether it's annoying whether it's
complex and I think we spend like we
spend more time with those characters
than any of you likely ever will a lot
of the time um I mean like if you want
to talk about a dysfunctional
relationship it's that between a Creator
and their characters right um this is
this is where comedy becomes really hard
to produce this where you're listening
to the same jokes over and over and over
and over and over and over and you're
trying to stay in love with this
character but man heard this joke so
many times oh my God you know yeah
totally um was there a question just yet
hi uh so I was just curious how do you
handle a situation where say one of the
concept designers or a producer or
anyone within the team have serious
disagreements about the direction or the
design of a character like say if a
concept itas has a design and it's
they're in love with it and they think
it's really like it's got to stick but
maybe someone says no that doesn't work
at all how do you handle and diffuse
that kind of situation exactly like that
you literally just described the whole
conversation and I mean honestly like
hopefully you can justify it and back
that up but like it's important for
depending on the size of the team you
know you get different levels of you
might have different levels of directors
art director gameplay director audio
director whatever you know it's really
benefits depending on the size of the
team it really benefits you to have
someone whose job it is to look at
what's going on and say this works this
works this doesn't this works this
doesn't and the stuff that gets cut a
lot of the times is really really good
on its own if you isolated it and looked
at it like this design or these you know
or this type of dialogue or this thing
that this character could be doing or
whatever like like oh that's you know
this happens all the time where you get
like a meeting and people are like oh
what if we did this thing and everyone's
like yeah that's amazing and then you go
and you put it in the context and it
just doesn't work and a lot of times
whoever implemented that or came up with
the idea or you know whatever is like
really attached to that thing and if
there isn't someone like kind of who has
veto power over them to look at it and
be a little bit detached from it and go
I know you like it but it just doesn't
work you get you end up going down long
rabbit holes chasing this thing that
isn't real and shouldn't exist yeah so
what's the hardest thing you guys have
ever had to
kill a small child
actually did you kill
Stacy um oh that's a really good
question once um I was working on a game
and there were like five different
worlds and we just had to kill like an
entire world so it's like you know a
whole level in Banjo Kazi or something
like that it just had to go and that's
like that's really heartbreaking but I
think you you can't get attached to that
stuff in games I mean like especially if
you're working on the types of projects
where you have ex external Milestones
like whether that be um you know
externally as in like within the same
company but a you know a different
office or something like that or whether
it be a publisher or you're working on a
licensed title um you it's more
important a lot of time that you ship on
time and stuff like that God it's so
hard to like write a joke and you're
like this is so funny and you just think
it's the best and then you put it in
front of people and it just dies on the
vine like oh it's the worst yeah yeah I
don't know I've that hundreds of those
hundreds yeah sorry I was going to say
another thing it's not so much killing
but something that is is good for
everybody who plays games around here uh
to realize is that as performance level
also is a real challenge because usually
your best performance isn't the one that
goes in there and so often people are
like oh I didn't really like that read
or whatever there's so many
considerations when you go into voice a
character the biggest one being timing
that we don't get the opportunity to
take our time to and then they draw to
fit our mouth it's the other way around
so like you can do the best performance
you've ever done and you like look up at
the director and you be like that was
great but it's 0.005 of a second
long yeah so can you do it again and you
like literally the amount of times have
been like three more2 less and by the
time you do it you're like that was the
worst but it fits for the timing so it's
interesting to consider when by the time
you play the game that in performances
of voices there's so many more things
that we would have preferred you heard
but you get the version that fits
because that's something that I think
every voice actor should know and
sometimes they don't act like it is
they're not the most important part of
the game and and it's hard to fit in
just like the lighting needs to fit into
a movie The Voice needs to fit into the
graphic just the in
there play out what do you mean by
Progressive visual
representation oh I 100% think that that
should happen more and more and more oh
yeah I like I remember when I first
played Uncharted and like you get in the
water and his clothes get wet and I was
like yes video
games um yeah I I've always wanted to I
don't know what the game is but like
something that I would love to do to
just really marry like the time that you
spend with a character and like seeing
their Arc through a game actually
technically to the progression of the
game is I would love to see Tech
where a model like starts as a small
child and then procedurally is basically
blending between different models until
you're you're an adult character or
something like that you know what if
Stacy's mom slowly becomes a child over
the course
of
what like actually what yeah no yeah no
I think I think that I think that's Ace
I think anywh you can do it yeah like
cuz it's just some weird form of
narrative dissonance that is created
through technical limitations I believe
that it's the reason why we don't have
it I mean imagine a movie where like you
know bond is in his tuxedo at the start
and there's like he never ever gets a
scratch on it at all he kind of does
right like that sort of is how Bond
films go but those fil you know they're
always very like kind of plastic they
feel very round and and soft and smooth
and there aren't really hard edges cuz
yeah you're like bond is going to look
he's he's going to be fine we're not
worried I think actually is Indiana
Jones going to
survive right I think something that I I
did love in rockstars max pain 3 uh
which is one of my favorite games it's
something incredibly amazing that they
did was like this real meta commentary
on Shooters themselves and it comes down
to things like where you'll be in a be
in a gunfight and you take a bunch of
bullets and then it cuts to a cut scene
and he's there and he's totally fine but
he's got like bullet holes all through
him like I just love that like there's
no way that rockar didn't know that that
was the case there's no way that someone
didn't come along and go oh wait like
he's just totally fine but he's got
bullet holes like it that is kind of
weird meta commentary on Shooters and
this whole idea of Max pain and how
ridiculous it is I think Metar solid
sort of does that as well like there'll
be a cut scene and snake will just be
like covered in blood right
yeah those are good like it's scar you
talk to someone then you got like an
arrow like yeah yeah
yeah yeah but that's all organic right
that's all like happening just through
organically through the gate through as
you're actually playing the game which I
think is why that works so well is
because it feels like I did a thing and
now it's shown on the
screen um anyone else yeah uh Hey guys
um so basically I was thinking more of
the storywriting side of the character
um like do you need to establish that at
the start when you're actually creating
it like 100% or does something actually
get fit in at the last minute or
somewhere along the line of that
creation of the character I mean you
have to remember it depends a lot on on
uh technically what you're trying to
achieve So like um so like lines of
dialogue are in the spectrum of things
very very cheap to produce so like if
you have a character that's doing
voiceover and all you're hearing is
their voiceover then you can I mean you
can slip that in like real close to
launch right if you need to actually see
that character on the screen and they're
like moving around and they need to be
like animating to go along with that you
got to think of that a lot earlier and
honestly it means that uh it's it can
benefit you to start thinking about how
to cheat those things early in
production right if you're if you're
thinking about like we could make the
character one of these two ways but
making it in this way is going to make
it a lot like technically easier for us
to change and iterate on the character
over the course of production it might
might be worth doing that even if for
example it might not look as good
because you know that you're going to be
able to change things faster which means
you're going to be able to pick up on
stuff that isn't working faster and make
it better in the end and usually when
the actual writing is better people
forgive you know like a technical thing
that isn't quite working as well as it
should be because they like the writing
and you know it depends on what kind of
game you're making but I usually try to
air toward giving myself more Flex
ability in technically being able to
make changes uh further down the
line no more questions questions sorry
guys um thank you very much for joining
us thank you thank you very much thanks
for
coming a big round of applause to Le as
yeah thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you but I'm coming to put you in your
grave
[Music]
begin
he
[Music]
for
e
[Music]
what's the
smell
[Music]
e
what's the
smell
e
[Music]
I don't know what grand scheme you've
got underway
Delilah take
it but I'm coming to put you in your
[Music]
Brave what a Gruff
voice Good Start hey everyone hey hi
should we introduce ourselves real quick
uh my name's Jess I work for Gamespot as
a producer I'm Carlo I am part of big
head mode we do video game comedy I'm
Ben also from big head mode I'm Emily
I'm from burning glass creative we do
game design production and narrative
services for the games industry what are
we doing today guys well um I believe
the idea is it's a thing that KL and I
like to do a lot uh on a stage show we
do called bonus stage where we just we
just get audience suggestions and make
characters in games um it's also the
second time I've ever used a PlayStation
4 so looking forward to
this what are you using uh Xbox One or
just play got my own games made yeah my
own consoles bunch of rocks we have a
lot of laughs excellent uh we also have
some stuff to give away I think we got
some Bea goodie B so maybe at some stage
we'll get you guys to pick like in your
heads what you're going to make and
these guys can try and guess yeah yeah I
think we could we could also get some
some audience suggestions too I reckon
yeah so we should F on what we're doing
today is we're going to be building
characters characters in Skyrim
character creator I I just want to say
early on um we've done Nicholas Cage
about 40 times he's always the first one
suggested
41 actually scar Nicholas Cage would
would be really easy I Reon actually I
think go cor Nicholas Cage should we
both start with a different Nicholas
Cage probably yes I think we can all
agree yes go with Wickman Nicholas Cage
Covenant
bees I hope they put bees in in one of
the mods so um for those who are
unfamiliar with uh with this game what
character creators have you used before
we've used a couple of character rers um
we used what was it WWF ww WWE was it
was a particularly
good that one is good I see a lot of
screenshots from that on Reddit yeah
it's that's why you get the game to be
honest not the wrestling just to make
the person yeah um what else have we sa
4 was really good we made a great Tony
Abbott in Saints 4 um and literally like
I think it it took about a minute and a
half for anyone to guess it and all we
did was uh put him in underpants lower
his sex appeal and I was in the middle
of giving him big ears and then
someone's like Tony AB nailed it good
yeah that'd be fantastic if yeah I hope
you guys all remember the start of
Skyrim you do not get to make your
character immediately cuz it goes for
some time everything's fine uh this is
the old town of pan the old town of pan
I used to be sweet on a girl from here
yeah is that the one who put
Ginger I yeah
great a lot many ask me how many times
I've seen it this weekend cuz K and I
did a scar and pub crawl on Friday um so
should we have a chat about like
character creation tools like I assume
you guys in the audience are all pretty
into creating characters like okay who
who goes with a default option when
you're creating characters it's all
right given the EV the character maybe
they want to learn okay all right who
reords they take less than 5 minutes to
make a character wow okay more more more
than
10 more than
20 more than
40 depends on the game an hour depends
how many hairstyle options there are I
don't want to get to playing the game so
it's kind of a tup I'm so proud of you
guys I feel like I'm with my people
what about when you spend 40 minutes
making a character and then you get to
the first cut scene and you're like no
that chin looks
awful AG i i i reweld a character in uh
Dragon Age Inquisition no it must have
been before that I think it was the
first game and I created an else and God
she was so beautiful and I took so long
and it was fantastic start of the game
her head was Tiny
yeah no I had a problem with with
Inquisition because the lighting in the
Avatar creat is and the same as in the
cut scenes and and then I created this
perfect person and got to the first cut
scene it looks like her lips are made
out of metal cuz the shininess is too
high and I'm like oh the shininess in
dragon inquisition's lip gloss my
ersion super sonic you had to be very
careful in Dragon Age that you didn't
give characters mouths that would open
too much because the teeth in that game
were
nightmar I still have still have dreams
all right in so we're starting with with
uh a cage off yeah
we're yeah face off better start with
should we do face off one of us is John
jolta one of us is Nicholas
Cage who do you want who do you want uh
I'll be Travolta all right I got cage
can you see how planned this panel is
all right you guys are going to decide
which is better so judge them harshly
please see see the thing like I mean we
have different like fantasy races to
choose from which is radic for
Nicholas
whatas ah don't applaud that goodness
gracious to me we're doing uh we are I'm
doing this is from Face Off I'm doing
Travolta from Face Off yeah I feel like
cage has got a he an Elvin quality to
Nicholas Cage no maybe he's a
bron I I feel like you could work with
that me let me look at that the thing
about Skyrim is all the men look
ridiculous
there are some bizarre and the women
don't look great either the women don't
oh gosh women look but yeah everyone
Oblivion he like a balloon anal was like
a waxy odd
face oh that's that's maybe I'm just
thinking con now it's got the
hair uh so what are what are your
favorite character creators is there any
that you've used um I I really like um
GTA 5 character creator um it's a nice
picking your parents yeah it's quite
it's quite a nice touch or grandparents
as it as the case may be yeah um that is
not Nicholas speaking of that you
know starting Fallout 4 and then
thinking that you have two protagonists
and doing both of them and um spending
so then that's 2 hours for those of you
who take an hour to make your character
and then realizing you'll never see one
again
spoilers oh
that's minutes yeah um but you need to
know that that I didn't know that I made
the most so beautiful now that is a game
with some terrifying
teeth you don't want your car you just
stop picking the happy options of
dialogue after a little while
hey now here's a fun fact this is what
Nicholas Cage's hair actually looks like
um when he's not wearing a horrible
wig I need to just look this up juding
looks like no no just I I remember him
yeah there we go that's what I need
that's what I need now see you're going
off the picture with half of their face
so you'll make a character looks half
like John
jalta yeah great great
great in in Skyrim's character see
that's maybe a little bit does everybody
I I know I I do this quite a bit where
you start with a preset and then you
move this sort of thing you okay I'll
change this a little bit and then you
just end up going back to what the
preset was and kind of look at the end
go yeah I did something here like I've
done 30 minutes has to have done
something age is the most ridiculous
human being on the
face every single photo on Google image
search is
demented I actually I'm pretty sure I
did that um with my Fallout 4 chick I
spent so long making her and um I
started playing the game at work and I'm
pretty sure I spent like 30 40 minutes
making it uh our producer Ed comes over
and he's like that looks exactly the the
same as when she started you've done
absolutely nothing but way time I must
have been doing that like I would go
through all of them and go yeah the
defaults great but it felt like I was
making educated decisions but it's
actually actually tricky like I'm always
kind of scared to really screw them up
oh especially when you start messing
with noses and jaws and stuff and you
know what's the worst and this happened
to me in Oblivion so many times when
they look great from the front and turn
them to the side and it's like what has
happened that was my problem with
Inquisition as well cuz I couldn't turn
the head and then yeah so shiny lips and
it's messed up face first play through
was great created a
monster the problem with Mak Nicholas
Cage is there's no option to just like
do a huge evil smile like a he a lips
whereas Travolta is very lip heavy he's
got a lot of lip to give Travolta yeah
just you I got a whole day to spend just
making these sweet sweet
lips um I I'm not seeing I feel like K's
I don't know what you're doing I'm glad
you're doing it but I don't I yeah the
truth is I find if you can just find one
character trait and make that big and
hopefully that gets the rest of the face
over the line so it's a
car I always I go with hair and eyebrows
first yeah see they're pretty Cy they're
Cy
eyebrows Cy
she's good so actually when you do
create your own characters what do you
start with do you always start with hair
and eyebrow we start with the hair cuz I
feel like that's one of the simplest
ones that I know I can probably decide
on see I I take a step back and I think
about what their whole life would have
been up until that
point yeah and I go okay well they grew
up on the streets yeah so I'm going to
give him a little scar here I just s of
I start off with what what is the story
that this face will tell yeah
[Music]
um
oh did
I so I actually tend to make the same
characters like all of my characters for
some reason especially my RPG um
protagonist like uh fallout Skyrim and
Mass Effect they all have like practical
black buns and blue eyes all the time I
don't know why see I'm more the
Storyteller type of person like I'll I'm
not starting off with a story I usually
start with the face cuz I figure that
that's the easiest bit to mess up and I
want to get it out of the way um but I
do when I start looking at the options
try to create a little bit of a
personality and a story that I'm going
to play through essentially I think
that's kind of what I enjoy about like
I'm a Sims devote I'm sorry um and it's
it's one of those things where you're
creating so many characters that it in
it kind of creates that want to build
more personalities than just like cuz I
just make Jennifer hail every time man I
play an RPG I'm like she's sassy and
cool she's going to have cool hair and
exciting eyes and that's about it but um
like man lately every time I log into
the Sims cuz I've been playing it since
I was a kid I will spend ages creating
the character and it's even more painful
because you're picking outfits as well
and then I wenton play the game cuz I
just did that for ages and I'm like well
I'm done time now that was gaming that
counts that was fine so do you guys
prefer games that have very extensive
character creation options or do you
sometimes want to FastTrack through no I
I'm all about character creation um I
feel like most of the room probably you
it adds a sense of I mean before you
even began the game oh no lost my
controller I think
yeah what do I push it this thing oh
yeah I forgot you there is that should
be fine okay technolog is Coming Far
Away better in a pile of
rocks I feel like I've hit the limit on
on caging up this
character um I just need to get the nose
right and I think that's going to pull
the whole face
together yeah that's uh that's life for
you though isn't it it looks pretty
default to
me there we go I think this
is that's is
all are your lips big know he looks a
bit hu Jackman he does look a bit hu
Jackman but you know that's quite common
quite often you end up at Hugh Jackman
it's a destination point that we all end
yeah yeah like I've sort of ended up at
the uh actor Kieran Hines which I bet no
one no not a name anyone knows laugh
politely he played uh he played the the
wildling king in Game of
Thrones no
okay great um oh
man just need a little bit
more I I make characters in games better
now oh yeah I like those eyes yeah I
mean they unnerve me to an extent but
something not quite right with his skin
I just need an open mouth skin tone
making his mouth that's pretty good he
does have a big
CH you guys are quite good at this how
how high would you say Nicholas Cage is
eyes are or you're allowed to yell out
Suggestions by the way if you think that
that if you go no cage would definitely
have really low eyes I'll do it why is
his chin so big which one cage yeah I'm
just playing
around no it's it's it's it's long
what's the oh it is very
long for can I BR at the start but his
cheeks are quite sh oh no I feel like
that's better yeah you know what though
that's he looks like he has is less
forward because I made his eyebrows
really wide cuz I'm trying to bring out
the craziness you
know the eyes are doing that ex except
his his mouth is very
Stern St having a bad day yeah this is
Nicholas Cage who like he's not happy
with the
[Laughter]
catering howy I love
it okay I'm determined to find the
perfect cage mouth oh my God oh that's
right actually that's I thought there
was a way you could make your um you
could make yourself younger or uh there
this complexion yeah where's that that's
in the uh that's head up the top there
you go yes I think you are the youngest
as you older don't you it's just too
shiny yeah I want to get rid of these
mouth lines it's that shine under his
eyes that's making him that's what I can
do Botox he's had work done yeah it
might be I can I can Rouge him up a
bit what color does
Nicholas I'm going to give Nicholas Cage
quite solid evil Crazy Eyes okay well
there you go that's John that's that's I
think that's that's rather excellent I
think I feel like col blue eyes blue
eyes see I can't I can't see his
eyes you say when there we go they C
eyes tell me when he's got blue eyes
tell me when he's got blue
is that blue yeah yeah White Walker no
wait that's too much they're white now
you you're making him you're making him
real
scary he's not a
vampire probably well so so we
know yeah is that a rapid joh V guy is
that acceptance of probably not going to
be
better all right yeah how's my
[Music]
[Laughter]
cage
wow you know what though he was well
known for his love of lemons oh they
called him lemon
neemo all right I reckon we should get
some more suggestions all right um all
right if anyone wants to give us a
name
[Laughter]
wow
that's sassy lunch lady aonian okay a
sassy lunch lady Argonian all right
maybe we should get another suggestion
second one Garfield
Garfield I'll do Garfield you do
Garfield uh at the successful conclusion
I'll do the yeah why cuz you know that I
I like a I'm partial to
a have you ever been Argonian though I
feel like no one chooses
argonians
really nice aronian you guys want to get
some uh deep sea exploration happening
is that the yeah you are screamer fans
in
here
profile that's true I apologize this is
actually Garfield is very close to a
character I would naturally want to make
in
Skyrim I would role play that um
whenever what's the what's the day of
the week on Skyrim that is Monday though
you know how they have like M it's like
M or something K hat
mundas I just like I would role playay
that charact actually this is another
part of the game that kylo and I overc
commit to we both roleplay a lot in
games like Skyrim um if I was doing a
Garfield character I would just wait a
full 24 hours on
Monday I made a character once that
wouldn't cross bodies of water in armor
and also refused to leave the main roads
uh unless there was some kind of real
imperative that they left the main
incling like if there was a road say
going this way and the destination was
here I would follow this road all the
way until it would get to another road
that would take me closer to the
location I didn't travel at night why
why were you just scared were you role
playing like yeah I was role playing
scared
yeah it's quite a fun way be a hero do
you do quests in caves
no I wouldn't do question in CES either
no one wants that no one wants that
spiders and [__] no one's got time for
that H I um I Ro play a pacifist once in
Skyrim just to see how far I go like
about 15 minutes out of uh Riverwood
turned into a vampire and I was like I'm
going to roll with
this H it was exciting it was very
exciting complicated it's interesting I
I usually play to get more immersed in
the story and and kind of let the game
carry me more than add additional rules
onto it see I always like to play the
game with a story that I've with well
with certain character elements that
I've already created so that um if a
decision has to be made I know kind of
how my character would make it but that
makes it more interesting for you and I
think it's great that Avatar creation
and flexibility in mechanics enable us
to do that yeah
it's actually one of the main reasons I
like uh Skyrim a lot more than Fallout 4
cuz Skyrim is very there's no voice
acting there's a lot of character tools
and the role playing aspect you can
really do anything there's a lot of
different disciplines um because I added
voice acting like I built a whole
character in my head in Fallout 4 and
then the moment my character opened his
voice I was like oh this isn't this
isn't the character I thought I was
playing I was going with a really Gruff
Mad Max style like goes off the grid cuz
his wife dies spoilers and the male
voice actor in that game is like Waka
waaka he's like all sarcastic and like
all ameran oh man it's the worst it's
always a little weird for me at least to
be building a character without knowing
what they'll sound like
[Music]
red I think I'm going to be making the
decisions um yeah I I mean I had to I
changed my whole race and everything
with my character for Dragon Age
Inquisition because I had made I wanted
to make this elf that was really
connected to Nature and didn't want to
have much to do with humans and neither
voice suited that so I ended up going
back and making a real pro- Chantry
human and she had some things to say
about Magic let me tell you I bet she
did that's terrible you should be
ashamed of yourself yeah actually it's
it's I find it's really fun in those
kind of games to give yourself rules
like I rolled a geralt AR Rivia in
Skyrim and anyone who who's into their
Witcher law would know geralt has one
rule and he doesn't kill dragons
um and you can't get far and skym
without killing dragons but it ended up
being the best playthrough I've had
because it just forced me to not do any
main story and it was just like focus on
Alchemy a little bit of magic but not
too much cuz Wich just don't do much
magic um it was great you sort of you
find your own game and and play it that
way what the hell is going on with this
aronian blue I think they want blue see
right now I mean people want blue I'm
finding the limitations of kajit color
in there is no good Ginger like where's
as a ginger I'm offended tan there's a
soft tan no that's brown that's brown
what are you doing Bethesda where's my
ginger cat my Garfield coloring where's
my Garfield mod
yeah sure
yeah that's too much sexy I'm just
trying to make him look like an actual
cat my M she's so sassy can you see the
sassy oh my God look at those ears is
now we need more furrowed Brown there a
yeah there's a like Link's ears yes link
he's a cow cat can I give can I give
Garfield a fedora narrow them
down not a lot of fedoras around in
Skyrim unfortunately I bet you there's a
mud for it a little Fedora
light H oh look at that see the bit of
kajet teeth can you call it hair if they
horns I mean so what do do you guys have
any any go-to things that frustrate you
when it comes to character creation
limitations like if they don't have a
particular option or is there something
that I think they're more the merrier
like I I want all the options like I
will spend forever getting the jaw wrong
and the nose wrong but I want to have
the option to get it
wrong power choices yes
yeah yes
I agree I like RGB selector and I mean
you know sc's pretty old now so uh yeah
there is only a few select colors but I
think a lot of more recent games are
giving you RGB selectors instead of just
like um nine or 10 shading options yeah
and that makes a big difference for me
as someone who prefers this particular
shade of blue hair if I want to make
myself in a game most of the time it's
like it's not right fine I'll go with
black do you guys tend to make
yourselves ever all of you guys I used
to like when I was younger maybe like
Teenage that's what I used to do and
then I just got bored of it very quickly
because you realize after a while it
sort of it stops feeling unique when
you're seeing a a different version of
the same character across multiple games
whereas I really like ever since I got
into D and D that was a big turning
point for the way I approach characters
and I sort of try to look at it like
from a fresh slight perspective who's
this character how do they EX in this
world um how little or how much do they
look like Nicholas Cage all very
important all the questions you got to
ask so I think for I haven't since Mass
Effect one other than um other than the
Witcher 3 I haven't played a game as a
man so for about I guess I what said 10
years yeah um so yeah good that's a good
point make yourself
yeah never play as a dude ever the only
time I would control a guy is in a Sims
game cuz if I'm going to play a 50 60
hour game I don't know I always like to
play as a woman because there's a lot of
games um where you have a pre-selected
character and let's face it usually
those times it's a guy which is fine
there's nothing wrong with that but it
means that when I'm given the option I
tend to like to play as women yeah I'm
exactly the same I have so many options
to um to play as a guy and go through
that type of story I want
to
they're agreen they're on board she's on
board she likes to play for the rest of
the panel I'm going to direct my
character to whoever's
talking that's amazing listening
intently with those big ears listening
intently hang on I don't think I can
make this going any sass yet now he's
listening pretty
sassy
a I thought that was more genuine than
the last of FL that's that's that means
you're getting better this is a little
sassy look here she's quite sassy um and
my GFI like I'm going to mod in a lot of
lasagna into the sky I think um think
that' be great and I'm going to turn
Lydia into
Odie
so all right who who hang on who
suggested we should say who suggested um
Garfield and the Argonian before by the
way yeah can we get them um Bethesda
prize packs fantastic thank you guys
thank you um
yeah that was great all right what
should we see next yeah uh here we go um
your jiggling hand
guy aronian dark Mall oh that's good
that's good what about you
should Hillary Clinton highelf Hillary
Clinton we had a reference point had a
picture of Hillary Clinton in front of
me okay all right sorry you like to some
people what would happen is that right
Aran Darth Mall I feel like you've got
Argonian hang on go back pretty cool
that was you Jennifer Lawrence done
next hey every won um I you know this
might be controversial never play elf
characters in Things don't know why
that's because of your uh your hatred of
the white gold Concord though that is
true yeah I know what side of the
alliance I stand on yeah no one likes a
FAL um okay
there's even the don't
like in that race should
[Laughter]
actually amazing let's let's get it real
Darth moley find some good Hillary here
Hillary
Trump yeah he's already got Trump look
at him we're doing a lizard Dar more
we're going to build a wall and marn's
going to pay for it
fantastic goodness that's Hillary is
hair that's pretty good yeah that's not
bad she needs she needs just a look on
her face that just says like I don't
give a
[__] you know like she don't take NOS
yeah yeah she she won't take no Guff
from some Argonian dictator
yeah oh that's good cuz that's a sort of
like it's a half amused just smiled it's
sort of like I I can't seriously believe
this other guy is he's my political
opponent what is happening that's going
to look
good very good very
good never I never thought I'd find
myself wondering how high Hillary
Clinton's mouth was on her
face well I mean this is why I was
asking if you guys made yourself because
I occasionally not So Much Anymore now I
weirdly do have a preset that I carry
across different games which is I don't
know why I'm just a very boring person
but um when I used to make myself in
games you know I do the thing where you
look in the mirror and you try and get
your face right you just end up real
depressed I'm going to be honest with
you you make a really pretty version and
then your friend comes by he's like that
doesn't look like you your nose is way
bigger your Chin's way larger and you're
just like all right I'll never have
feathers like
that I usually don't make myself exactly
but like I like to have one key element
or one something that I'm like yeah that
bit is
mine yeah yeah I I mean it was easy for
me because you just go blonde hair
gingerbeard whatever that's it done it's
only a preset too yeah yeah you're a
preset well who in the audience who
likes to make themselves in character
creators okay interesting not not so
much who places their own gender
all right sometimes who who tends to
play as the opposite
sex why I'm
curious more options yeah very true do
do
[Music]
oh
Cosmetics
yeah yeah good point or be it on a
woman
yeah well I find it quite jarring when
I'm playing as a male character and
people talk to me like a dude I'm like
okay cuz it is really different cuz some
of these games will like you know regard
you differently particularly Dragon Age
they'll talk to you differently
depending on your race and depending on
your gender that's really odd it's kind
of
terrifying is it Am I whitewashing by
trying to make this elf look less
Elfie I'm nashing an elf
no I was given elf I was given high elf
Hillary Clinton oh of course you were
well then yes exactly you leave alone
I'm so
sorry oh you know
what you know what though Imperial was I
want to give Hillary some sweet war
paint just because she's going to need
it she's getting ready for battle you
know oh how about
that don't [__] with
Hillary see I always try and make pretty
much the same in every which is Admiral
Helena Kane from battar Galactic oh my
God it is it's a serious problem with
him guys every single character is
called Helena whatever yeah it's always
and then if I make a second character
it'll be something new and excited but
it's always first place is
alwaysa do you guys change up your names
or do you use similar names like when
you're making an RPG protagonist uh
similar to D and D I just I'll I'll do a
custom name but depending on like for
instance I have a Goto to kajit name
from doing a kajit character that is
rcar fireclaw obviously yeah you know
rolls off the tongue yep um I like the
name Ronin but like not like the
Japanese warrior but like Ronin
kading obviously yeah that's what I go
to but no not really other than those
names yeah that's is this pretty Darth
moley sweet that's pretty good oh
okay his eyes are yellow aren't they
yellow on mine that is
terrifying look at her that's Black Swan
Hillary
Clinton oh my
God it's hard to figure out which is
more terrifying are they not yellow oh
yeah oh they're green they're green is
that green yeah that
yellow tell me when they're yellow I'll
get don't worry maybe if I pick the
green
[Laughter]
eyes
all right I think I'm done I think I've
got my Hillary okay I think these are
pretty Fierce oh no wet her can I she's
got a much wider yeah but she's an elf
Carlo don't change her don't don't try
and change her we tried that we're get
in
trouble also this photo I have for
reference she's sort of you guys
probably can't see it but it's like it's
like a heroic shot so just for
[Laughter]
reference excellent all right I'm done I
think these are beautiful uh hands up
who made these suggest those people just
so can we get them bags as well can get
you couple of couple of goodie bags and
then do you want people is it helping
people yell out suggestions or does it
turn into a [__] bite just name a let's
let's do the hands up do hands up but
let's just try uh try name and we'll
we'll pick the races
I then you can pick your favorite yeah
yeah make each other make each other yes
all right find red preset just find the
find the biggest the biggest and most
1920s German scientist mustache I can
yeah
good do you guys want to see who can do
it FAS yeah should we R since this is
just one yeah I think you should R
[__]
yeah you can decide who's is better
actually N I think Carla you're going to
be a Nord or did you make me know it as
well yeah you going be
Anno all right let's see
freet it's like it's good to just pick a
good preset to start as
a as an example point I reckon like you
could just find a little feature that
looks common and then there L to change
yeah you guys looking at each other for
reference I feel like you just know I
know K's face too every night before I
fall
asleep
so how long have you guys been playing
this game since I mean you you're making
each other well talk about your life hey
col um two questions how dirty do you
think you
are and what is the what is the color of
your
Dirt N come on just JS Just J jokes jks
all right
here hope turn
insulting you're always wearing that
Warrior bread right
there there we go here we
go
done oh my God I need it's quite the
mustache see I mean we what we're facing
now though is a limitation in Skyrim
hair choices oh that's I mean a very
white her but then I guess
[Laughter]
col it's not bad I think I I've been
playing Skyrim a bit I I got a bit
frustrated with Skyrim in a way because
it's not re like it's not um the kind of
role playing game I'm really into in a
lot of ways and then Skyrim is like the
Elder Scrolls games since Moro went have
been great in kind of creating like
really beautiful worlds um and really
exciting things to do but they haven't
they've kind of missed the point of
affecting that world and changing things
that you kind of want to get out of a
role play experience I mean if you
finish the main story you want that to
have some impact on the world um yeah I
mean when I think about I mean I love
Skyrim I put like 130 hours into it but
uh yeah when it it's a fantastic game
but when I think about it I think about
the places I've been I don't think about
like really the people I've spoken to or
definitely not the person I made like I
don't feel like a person in the world of
Skyrim with this protagonist but I I
think that's kind of uh the curse of a
lot of you know custom character
creation games and a lot of these huge
open world games uh because you're
you're experiencing everything through
what is usually a first person lens and
you don't have that pre-established
character who already has all these
narratives to be a part yeah and that's
that's a little bit why I was asking
earlier like sometimes I just want to
get into the game and I want a little
bit more preset and maybe a little fewer
options but then I know who I'm playing
yeah and and it that character has an
identity that I can sink into and other
times I want to just open it up and go
crazy and do whatever um but I do feel
like I need both yeah yeah I mean like I
think this definitely has its place I I
think it's even not so much that you
know who you're playing but the game
knows like the other characters in the
world know who you are um which is where
I think Mass Effect really succeeds
because it makes you able to make so
many decisions about who you want to be
uh both just uh like physically custom
character creation wise and also how you
interact with the people and things in
the world but at the same time I very
much felt like that character because of
the relationships it builds see in
Skyrim too many people know who you are
like you walk into a room and you're
like oh you're that new guy from The
Companions Guild like what how does that
travel how do how do you see my
face and when you save the world and
they're still like I know you're in the
Thieves Guild yeah because I'm wearing
thev Guild
Armor yeah it creates a big disconnect
between what you've experienced as that
character and what the game is telling
you you've experienced that's one of my
favorite things about Elder girls games
I love becoming the hero of everything
that's why I don't like MMOs cuz I love
games like this where it's like yes I am
not even a magic user and I'm King of
the M's G cuz I'm the best one except I
hate it when you become like you're like
the head of magic you're the head of
everything and the God's like oh you're
going to steal my sweet roll and it's
like no do you know who I am I could
create sweet rolls out of
matter H I'm trying to make you look
less strung out but you've had a you've
had a real rough
weekend my you so I can only give you a
a black stubbly beard exactly and you
know what You' have stumbled on one of
my big pet peeves in character creators
when you can't have different shades of
hair and beard it's always like hair
color and it's like who has the exact
same color it's always like slightly
lighter or slightly every guy in know
has a ginger beard so I don't know why
he'd ever make a color it's not Ginger
it's the hidden kelt in all of
us they got it
about I'm going to Bas mine on your side
profile cuz that's what I can see right
now so the ratio nose to mustache yeah
okay what down to his
cheekbone I told you he looks like he's
glorious kny cheekbone he's a
prisoner yeah he hasn't eaten it a while
he's doing his um Christian Bale from
The Machinist God no stop looking
those don't look at me don't look at me
there's something at the cheeks that's
what it is that's what it is you look
too Stern I can't give him a goofy
smile
you know goofy making goofy would be a
great character like Disney
goofy we can dream though oh how great
would that be and they're at war with a
kajit they're like right next to to the
Ken
Homeland oh no what's going why can't I
give
you that's going to be a way please feel
free to tell these guys how screwing up
how they could improve each other's
faces kind just stare at them till you
get inspiration do you have any
scars
sh no glasses in the Skyrim world I can
make you look here
go you know your war
paint no I yeah
that's
oh I hate that a it's the
worst so annoying I just don't like I
mean Mass Effect is one of those games I
love with a passion can't watch anyone
else play it cuz it's like that's not
yours it's my experience it's like
you're not allowed to have an enjoyable
experience in this game this is my game
no I save the Galaxy get your own come
with MOS it's like I don't want to be
surrounded by
Heroes yeah yeah like walking in on
someone else with GIS what what the hell
GIS I'm sorry that was my Garris that
was amazing SP on hello I'm
GIS
wow well it's not it's not a world of
difference between Garris and Skeletor
have you seen him in the same room
together
um yeah always have way better hair
options really good hair options yeah
but I feel like Japanese or Eastern
games just get
customization right and or they just
really get care a lot about it yeah
totally huge difference a lot of triaa a
lot of Western games just have baffling
like Destiny I still can't understand as
a AAA game um how little it didn't have
any facial hair options for one or um
the division another huge triaa game uh
and there were like legit eight faces
per gender and and that is an MMO where
it would have paid off so much to have
way different characters and also it was
eight faces but two per race so of
course 90% of people in a room were
always just say generic white dude and
it was so like
it was just
yeah they might as well have had no one
north um that's that's part of the
challenging bit from um development
standpoint is balancing all of that out
because the more options you have the
more robust the engine behind it need to
be for the animation to look good um and
all of that so sometimes it's just about
prioritizing what you feel is more
important about the game and how much
space that needs to take as well it's
it's really a balancing act um I was
working on the Sims free play on mobile
so I can tell you about figuring out
limitations in character creation
character creation because there's no
choice yeah do you do did you find that
like sort of I mean I always feel like
no matter what options you put in there
there's going to be someone who's like
this option I want isn't in there yeah
that always happens um and it's yeah and
it's tricky to to be able to cover
everything and sometimes times it's just
the engine can't support it um like
looking at a mobile game versus the Sims
on PC we still we have players asking
for different body shapes and everything
and I would love for us to have that but
the animation system just the engine
can't support it we would have to redo
all of the gazillion of animations of a
5-year-old game to make that happen um
so it's like it you you want to give the
right things and then picking the right
things is the
challenge what about like from a
development point of view how do you
feel about things like cosmetic mods and
stuff um you know add other people
adding options to a game well that
something that you sort of like
personally I think like for me as a
Storyteller um and all of that the games
belong to the people playing it as well
so if I can't make it but someone else
has the time because they're really into
this game and they want to do
that have at
it yeah cuz often times when we make
those decisions it's not for fun hey
let's not offer these options yeah yeah
I just hate beards yeah why would you
want different color hair and beard yeah
that's luck that's going to be relev
very relevant to this game as well I
mean Skyrim is bloody massive of course
the team ofth just huge as well but the
number of things you're being offered in
this Monumental game uh I mean it's it's
wonderful that we have all the options
you guys are going through um and of
course there's always room for
improvement but yeah I mean it is one of
those things you got to pick and choose
you got a li resources time create
different things do you want you can't
more quests and stuff to do or different
eye shape like it's not that trade off
obviously but it's it's something to
think about yeah yeah um like there's
just no way in a game that offers player
Freedom you to preempt every choice that
someone's going to want to make like a
game like Skyrim everyone's going to
come to it with a totally different idea
of what their sort of fantasy Nordic you
know vision of that game would be and
you know like they'll have a character
in their head perhaps that has mustache
brides and the moment they can't find it
it's like well that's the character I
had in my head and I can't do it whereas
that's such a niche thing for a
developer to be like don't forget
mustache
braids
I reckon I reckon that's as close as I'm
going to get to you K that's pretty good
yeah I that's pretty good get you look a
little bit
Stern um you look a bit like Al SAR
Engen from
Deadwood quite good
good everyone's always
angry yeah that's a hard one actually
because you do see like when games try
to work it into the animation it can
totally backfire as well um like I just
noticed actually in in the Skyrim HD
Edition I made a I made a really good
with use of mods I made a really good um
doctor strange and um he the face looked
perfect and I was so proud of it and I
was checking him out in third person and
all of a sudden his face was
like I was like what's going on and I
realized it was a wolf and he was in
combat and so like he's this great
doctor strange that looks really like
sort of mysterious and then when he goes
into combat he freaks out um so it's
just yeah it's weird like it's I guess
it's cool to try and preempt how your
characters going look with sort of basic
facial animations but yeah you can't
predict what it's going to and that's
that's part of canning some of the the
options it prevents a lot of that stuff
um but yeah it's It's tricky to find
that limit and one of um the great
things that they do in uh the recent
Sims games and also Fallout 4 did it
where uh the animations can be seen in
the character creation screen so you can
see what it looks like when they open it
and horrifying horrifying yeah oh Manz I
mean I'm sure there's a market for
people who just want characters who look
ridiculous when they're
talking yeah I'm up for that that always
weird you wanted to be intentional right
it's it's the eyebrows that always look
weird for me like you spend a lot of
time going this is the perfect Stern
eyebrows and Fallout did it when every
like the dip in the middle it's just
like oh I'm being lighthearted now and
it's just
like some kind of weird alien brow
creature
so good look I'm I'm going to be honest
I'm not very happy with this but it's
got red hair I you know you know I'm
mostly blonde
right blond definitely blonde yeah but
there was no look at this is it how is
there no blonde hair you started
blonde that's already
better all right no look let's hands
down who who who has the better face
okay let's let's let's hear it for uh
for K's offering of Ben clap if if you
think
k
no you didn't get one person I don't
even have a beard I don't have eyes what
are you thinking I'm just I'm from the
eyebrows skin I wouldn't clap that wow
everyone agrees with more
like so you can make one person yeah
whereas who thinks I absolutely nailed
Daniel de LS
all right can can we get a can we get a
gift bag to whoever you already want do
you want to do you want to be Santa
Claus and decide who to give it to I'm
putting all the pressure on
you throw it over your shoulder
that's cuz I don't think there's blue
hair in it cuz there's only like four
hair
colors yeah that's the eternal
struggle should weit so how much how
many characters J can we can do in the
next um 10
minutes
one should we do we should do a
lightning round let's try and do why
didn't I do a
br oh that's good oh but that's also
going to be revealing of uh our opinions
on Skyrim
races oh God what was that
suggestion I think ORS are beautiful
actually I'm not going to
go so we're making the ugliest character
we can make yeah I think there's no blue
hair which is the problem I know I like
the idea of oh look it remembered your
face
color I like the idea of making a really
although I mean ugly what do we Define
as ugly they could look beautiful but be
awful
people okay
gr okay you know
what thank you what's this dictionary
defined ugly as just saying Klo has a
picture of Donald Trump right there
yeah um I think they're going to go with
ugly
possible this is where I cut loose well
why don't we try and give away some more
things yeah so why don't can we go
through a bunch or is this going to take
a long
time how long does this process
gentlemen yeah I think it'll take I mean
we could think of another another way to
give people um oh yeah yeah go go on
present
it what's a good way to get prizes um
who wants a
prize look under your chairs you get a
prize you get a prize your chair already
a
prize um pretty
gooded character speedrun a character we
have we have characters on on cuz then
people don't get prizes all right let's
get let's get everyone put your hands up
who has a character and let's Carlo and
I will take five characters each and in
the next
eight minutes we've got to make all
those characters all right what
characterand Adam Sandler Santa this is
a great idea
um George
Cy new
aquam aqu to the left
yeah I shotgun bab oh wait I'm running
it down you take your own no you get
Aquaman that was giving a
you um back
right yeah
see no no no I'm I'm going to interpret
that how
[Music]
I I've got four I need one more I need
one more I need one more yeah
you all right okay I think I've got
pretty ugly character though look at
that yes okay um that's quite unpleasant
so who are we beginning with guys
starting with Adam Sandler I'm going to
set where who is this who did I write
here s
Santa that's a
sentient all right well that's Adam
Sandler hair I reckon um let's go next
one yeah facial hair um I don't think he
has facial hair cuz he's just like a
Manchild I think that's right here we go
why did we start so ugly also that's my
next my next one is George Cory and I'm
going to use the same
hair no almost that's pretty NF sand
though look maybe they have to say when
it's okay and you can move on yeah okay
I'm at the mercy of you
[Music]
guys um here we go big eyebrow oh no no
I'm disadvantaged where's my screen
there we go com
back what the sent is head hair look
like who thought you'd hear that phrase
today can I there's no espresso option
for Clooney either
so what is happening go it's still the
ugliest pre-build I can find why are you
making ugly
Santa you have a much easier character
to make he's an old man with white hair
You' done from the ugly it's still
see there's no rule that said your Santa
had to be
sexy otherwise you would have been given
sexy Santa all right that's how I see
Adam Sandler um where are the black
soless eyes there we
go wow there we go Adam Sandler tick all
right Santa
Santa you're all right next one who we
got now Danny Deo Danny Deo all right
I've got to make C
uh Clooney would have the good look oh
that's Clooney
already just go I'm picking the good
presets all right um Always Sunny Dano
this is like out of sight oh you know
what he'd have a bit of stubble he'd
have a bit of like sort of sexy Clooney
stubble does he have a beard now cloy
yeah I think so he's got that se dishel
thing going on let's see his nose is not
quite that sort of um that angle he's
got more of a I don't know how he
describe his nose buttony
buty oh that's more
Cy slash um slash Obin from Game of
Thrones pretty good
Danny yeah you're Danny Deo started with
a n that's from that's Danny deito in
that episode of always sunny when he
shaves all his body hair
off what on
lipstick um
actually those eyebrows were pretty
Clooney I think I started with a better
Clooney than I'm at
now too much
uh maybe
that minutes by the way oh God that's a
Clooney that's a TI all right tick tick
Bieber orc Here We
Come Oh God God that is so
F the other way okay let's find a good
Bieber preset um
done the prettiest do in town it's all
going to be it's all going to come down
to the hair
do this looks a little bit like
it I don't think there's going to be an
orc with a bow
cut maybe
that men button works oh facial hair cuz
I don't think he can grow any yet
um what color his
hair I think we need to move
on Carlo you've lost Danny deito and now
the very easy distinct man I need just
to wipe the Breton face from that shitty
thing that I created before everything
you can you know if you flip presets it
resets your character oh
[__] oh look at that
youthful Brown types oh look at
that what a beautiful baby babber
orc oh man you could have made a great
Darth Mo orc look at
that sham kind of
deal yeah it's just like fishy eyes that
face
outwards uh I think that's as sexy as my
baby Rock's going to get he's pretty
sexy yeah
good job all right the doctor down to
the
wire anyone's this um oh
god oh no no 30 seconds gone okay um oh
my god there are so many doctors why
would did I ask for something
specific uh all right I'm going to go
who has long hair what's the Tom Baker
oh my God it's Carlo he's come back to H
me oh
no
no I'm going to go oh no I've lost my
screen
again I can't
say uh yeah that's the Obscure oh you
know what I'll make John Hurt
doctor can I get my my screen back I
think I've got I've got the time up I
think it's detaching ex okay there we go
I think that's that's it that's it we've
run out of time oh no but I never made
Mr
Bean and that's my Steve
[Laughter]
Jamie and look it's John Herz
doctor if your pass was made today
please come get a gift back yeah thanks
very much for
coming keep making characters keep
having a lot of fun and keep on
packs yeah thank you guys you made a
suggestion head over
there we
take but I'm coming to put you in your
grave So It
[Music]
Begins
for
oh
[Music]
what's the smell
Storm Trooper versus Han
Solo ready fight
h
what's this smell
[Music]
I don't know what grand scheme you've
got
for
[Music]
e
he
[Music]
I don't know what grand scheme you've
got underway to
Mila we'll take
it but I'm coming to put you in your
[Music]
grave hey guys how are we
all good I'm tired is three of packs are
you guys tired yeah let all have a nap
a okay uh we're actually still waiting
on someone so this is kind of awkward uh
what we will do is jump right in and go
to the first clip on our thing and
hopefully by that point line will be no
no let's let's roll it let's roll it
it'll be great it's live it's
topso nice
[Applause]
excellent
we don't know how to pronounce it though
we have no
[Applause]
idea
win
y um so that is the worst fighting game
of all
time um okay she's not here I I had a
plan that was going to be really
impressive I'll do introductions now I'm
Luke Lancaster with
CET oh hi I'm Nicky ex
CET I'm David hollingworth and all
Affiliated C that uh and I'm Dan Crow
I'm from
Gamespot um and we all play a lot of
Star Wars games and watch a lot of Star
Wars and talk about a lot of Star Wars
Star Wars and live Star Wars in my
day-to-day life
really not I I'm not I don't want to
tell you how it's too embarrassing how
to live Star Wars You' got one of those
J bath robes don't you yeah no I
actually do I actually do um yeah it's
embarrassing okay um also the mtyc is
Lana PI from IGN who is going to be
really really embarrassed when she gets
it so everybody applaud when she comes
up please do make it a big deal why are
Star Wars games so bad you know that's
the age-old question really
um is there is there a simple answer see
that's I I deferred it away it was good
though is there a simple an to ni yes
there is uh Star Wars isn't very good to
begin with so the games were never going
to be great
anyway take him down why did I ask you
to be on this panel that too early too
early wow man with the Star Trek show
thank you for noticing um uh I think
often because so I grew up with with
Star Wars you know I I saw it when I was
6 years old in the cinema um so it is
this very very personal thing and you go
Star game that can't
[Laughter]
suck they have to suck so that's one of
the reasons look I think we also
certainly people of David and my um age
Generation Um we got used to games being
bad like games just were especially if
they were going to be a tie into a film
or a franchise I mean I actually played
the Poltergeist game on Atari and it did
not have a lot to do with the film I can
assure you of that and it was not very
good I think we just just expected that
a game that was going to be a licensed
thing like that was going to be bad
that's really true I don't think there
are any licensed games anymore are there
that aren't mobile games does anyone
make has there been a console licensed
game isn't that like Lego's entire model
that's true but does that count that's
kind of two properties does that really
count as like a over two things it's
fine yeah that's games are actually
pretty good
yeah so I think it's just stuff like
Terrace Cari you get games that you
don't need a Star Wars fighting game it
doesn't make sense that Stormtroopers
who just are there to get shot are
martial artists right but or the or that
you have a move where what is h solo
known for drawing his gun but there is a
move in that video where he puts it away
that's so you can keep taking it out
right no it was bad and
like you want these games to be good
right we all love Star Wars probably too
okay apart from Nick Nick doesn't here
we go
[Applause]
this tombs aren't going to raid
themselves uh hi everyone I'm Alana I
guess this is the part where we' have
already introduced ourselves a little B
okay I'm an editor at IGN um and I'm
really hoping that Battlefront 2 is good
oh should we talk about Battlefront 1
now no no not not yet not yet not ready
yet not yet
too soon the wounds are still too fresh
man okay but like I think this goes back
to the original sort of like super Star
Wars games cuz I replayed those in
preparation of this panel that's right I
do
research and they're not good guys they
say that's a controversial opinion I'm
going to throw it to the audience Super
Star Wars good or
bad have you played them recently yeah
okay I'm wrong sorry what if he's wrong
yeah if I am what what what makes it bad
in your eyes
just they are way too hard and I'll go
on the record and say that they are way
too hard but that's all old games we all
know games video games
[Music]
yeah that's true no it's the children
who are
[Laughter]
wrong um I I replayed Super Star Wars
again recently and I think it's got this
Rose Colored Glasses of my youth playing
it in my lounge room you know on my CRT
while my parents were asleep upstairs
and I'm turning it down and like as an
adult I don't have that connection to it
anymore and I'm just like I don't have
the time to play this anymore I just
can't be bothered when I was a kid I
could sit there and play it and just
like struggle through the harsh
difficulty like you said but now man I
value my time too much I would much
rather be asleep like oh love having a
nap how could sleep oh
dude that's true that is all we had back
then like these bad games were all we
could play and I remember tricking
myself I got masters of Terrace Cassy
does anyone know how to pronounce it is
it terce Cassy terce casai terce Cassy
let's go with terce Cassy I uh it was
the first game I convinced my mom to buy
me not for my birthday or Christmas we
were at Maya and I played it on a uh on
a on a console uh like demo station and
I played that level the the one on Endor
and I was like oh my God this is amazing
this is the best game ever made mom by
this for me and she was like all right
cool this is this is out of the ordinary
you can have it and I remember getting
it home playing a little bit and just
realizing how [__] it was and just
convincing myself that it wasn't a [__]
game I used to get friends around to
trick them to be like hey man this is a
really good game but we all knew it was
just so bad Rose tinted glasses in video
games is kind of a fascinating thing and
I think that there's actually this
period of time where you can pinpoint
your Nostalgia and I think it's from an
age where you can remember everything
but you haven't fully developed critical
thinking so I think it's like it's not
even a joke I think it's like up to the
point where you hit about 13 you want to
stalgic from everything from like maybe
9 to 13 and for a lot of people that
also encompasses Star Wars because I
feel like it's family friendly it's a
family fantasy series and it's something
that people see at a really young age
and then we just like to pretend that
all of the games are good same thing
happened when the prequels came out and
everyone was like that was good was it
they did it was good no one ever thought
that was good show of hands who didn't
hate the first prequel until they'd seen
it at least twice me for
sure is it because you wanted to believe
that's exactly what it was I wanted to
believe
yeah that would have helped U but we
were talking about Pod racer Pod racer
was the episode one tie-in game
p okay
good they really used him well um and I
absolutely hated Pod racer but I was
playing it on PC Dan was saying before
that on on N64 that was was one of the
best N64 games ever made and there was
that cheat code where you could get two
N64 controllers and control the engines
uh independently it was did you not know
about this I didn't know that oh my god
when I found that out it's also did you
know on time crisis on PS1 if you put a
controller on the floor and had the gun
con you could step on the controller and
use it as a pedal anyone else know that
well that's a great way to break it when
they just do dumb [__] like that I think
that's brilliant like to racer on the
N64 was just um again I think it was my
childhood getting friends around we play
Four playit split screen and just no I I
have really good memories friends with
uh zero they also didn't
exist okay that was awkward I thought
someone um speaking of games from our
youth that we have a real nostalgic tie
to have you played Jedi Knight 2
recently David
no I have such a deep affection for that
game because that game is the thing that
taught me how to use console
codes right because you don't want a gun
at the start you want to be a Jedi you
want your lightsaber um don't play
through it again if you have any fun
memories of that game do not play it
again and it might just be us getting
older but like I still love Star Wars I
still love the original movies yeah I
still love dark Forces I think it's one
of the greatest games ever I can't go
back and play it ever
again yeah so my theory is that Star
Wars games can be good if they're not
tied in to a film so I still say that
Kotor is just one of the best things
ever two was great you get away from
what the franchise has done
cinematically and you can have a great
game I'm going to slide down a bit
further from sorry I was going to say
except for the sound design like the one
thing that I love about Battlefront is
the sound design if you rip that
straight from the films stoked but like
it's almost perfect because they
actually you know it sounds like Star
Wars because it is Star Wars one of the
greatest things about that game how it
sounds yes and then there's the rest yes
hey look it looks all right amazing 20
minutes of gameplay that's true that
first 20 minutes you'll always have it's
one of those games that if you play it
at a convention and you play it with a
lot of people it's super fun and then
you play it in your living room by
yourself and you're like where's that
DLC yeah I really paid for that season
pass a while
ago um but just talking about cotor and
games that aren't directly tied into the
main Star Wars cannon Kotor is a very
good BioWare game
o but but is it a good Star Wars game
Star Wars game I didn't say it's not a
Star Wars game I just said it was a good
BioWare game what do you think of
BioWare games in general I'm a fan of
BioWare games in general like I think
BioWare make really good games
but the thing I look for in Star Wars is
that the feeling of the world the very
black and white moral certitude for
lightsaber noises you know I'll own up
to that um and I don't think bware is
sued to making that kind of
game I'm going to have to level with
everyone in this room uh I've never
played played cotour what um I know and
I know and I know I've waited I waited
too long cuz now when I try to play it
it hasn't aged the best so as someone
who's never played it has no connection
to it I just can't get into it hey I've
tried multiple times on like multiple
consoles and like on my phone on my iPad
on my computer and I just it's on yeah
it's on everything literally everything
how does it run on a phone pretty well
pretty well SS great yeah that was like
one of the big App Store releases when
it came out everyone was like oh [__]
inredible and you know I got caught up
in the hype and then I was on the train
and I was like just crying a little bit
I don't like
this my 1699 yeah yeah where's my
1699 um gra clip two um we got to talk
about the prequels because it is the bad
thing in Star Wars like the number one
bad thing um and I will go so far as to
say apart from Pod racer every game
about the prequels is bad nothing
correct this one is really
[Music]
[Applause]
bad
[Music]
in
oh my
[Applause]
[Music]
God okay so
um I'm a video producer for Gamespot and
that was one of the worst edited things
I've ever seen oh my God why was it so
long my favorite thing about it is that
is like all the combat in the game like
there was not more than that why what
was he doing front flips I don't that's
the prequels that's dead on everyone
front flips they do a lot I don't
remember the Xbox looking that garbage
like so I just looked it up on Metascore
uh it's it's Metascore and Metacritic is
a 58 but I particularly like that the
number one review is 88 it's like while
this program might not be as intense as
Halo this program what does any of that
mean Yahoo says just plain fun thanks
Yahoo seven out of 10
I I mean watching that I got uh memories
of Shadows of the Empire on N64 and
everyone has fond memories of like the
ho level in Shadows of the Empire but
the rest of it is hot garbage that game
sucks doesn't that it has like really
weird platforming Parts but because you
have to be so precise because the game
sucks is nearly impossible it wasn't fun
yeah yeah Shadows is weird because it's
part of this this larger uh attempt by
Lucas film and Lucas Arts to create this
whole new property new characters new
setting new designs and it was like wow
this is just the tie-in for a tie-in for
a tie-in there was no actual original
property it was just all commercial all
these games kind of came out in a time
when they were just throwing so many
Star Wars things at the wall to see what
would stick and I think that's probably
what led to this like bad Star Wars game
so they just tried everything I think
part of it has to also be working with
Lucas I don't know if this has been the
same way the whole time but uh I went to
Disney Infinity to appal before they
shut down and there was so many things
that they asked us to cut in the video
we were making about how they produced
Disney Infinity toys because they were
like working with Disney sucks and they
kind of referred to things as um being
handed to you on the Mickey gloves so
they're like really Smiley about it but
they're trying to design kylo Ren and
they only get to see like one shot they
used fan art that other people had made
to try to make kylo Ren as a figure like
it seems like working with Lucas kind of
makes things hard who knew yeah who
would guess I mean speaking working with
Lucas and by Lucas now I mean George
Lucas this is something I love about the
EU it's hundreds of people trying to
explain the [__] that he just makes
up that looks cool yeah so do you know
the origin of Ja bink's voice so on set
the uh motion capture artist just did a
Dopey voice and George Lucas was like
brilliant love it we're going to use it
and he was like whoa whoa whoaa what
what and then no one said hey George
that's a bad idea great like that's how
it that's how he made decisions one of
my favorite stories about the pre is
that um when he was deciding what would
be CG and what would be uh physical or
practical effects they basically had
this board of scenes and characters and
he just took a highlighter and was like
the ones that are yellow will be CG and
the ones that are orange will be
practical effects and just was lining
just anything he could find just
completely no preparation and everyone
in the room's just screaming there's one
that he accidentally lined in the wrong
color and like went over it with yellow
and was like oh it's close enough to
yellow and everyone's just panicking
while he's making these decisions that
basically ultimately ended up in
everything looking terrible a uh a
friend of mine actually worked on one of
the prequels she's um slime MO is the
character's name it's like the uh
Emperor's personal assistant M she
appears in about 2 seconds despite
having been on set for like 3 months or
something ridiculous like that even had
her own action figure like scanned out
to be made up for her how long is her
Wikipedia entry I bet it's huge I
haven't actually checked it out yet it's
not even that different to all of the
figures that we got of um what's what's
her name the Chrome lady for uh fasma
fasma we got so many figures of fasma
and then she has such a small role in
the force awakens and it's like I don't
know if they planned to have her in
those films more and then took it out or
and we had no Ray figures for whatever
reason like they were really strange
with toys and it's toys that effectively
funded the prequels they Star Wars toys
they also completely changed the market
for action figures and it's absolutely
amazing them filing changed with Star
Wars yeah like articulation is different
like Hasbro basically became a company
because of the way that Star Wars
figures came to life and it's they did
really strange decision making with the
ones they choose to release yes don't
understand tons of you could you could
you could argue that that's the major
problem with Force awakens is they're
attempting to recapture all the stuff
that worked from the original trilogy
and that's why I think fasma is only in
it for a little bit they were like she's
going to be the B Fett we got a we got
Star Killer base that's the death St we
got x-wings but they're a little bit
different we got blasters and they're a
little bit different like it was I mean
they played it safe and I'm hoping with
the next movies they don't play Rogue
one looks very different so we'll see
how that
goes okay who has played the gungan
frontier you're a brave man I to that
one guy heard of it is this this the
building one it is a Sim strategy game
where you need to colonize a moon so the
gungans can live there and I have a
problem with this conceptually no that
sounds great so they got they were they
were kicked off the bo they were like
get out we don't want you anymore go to
a moon yeah just leave just go you like
defended the planet at the end of like
episode one but you're real Annoying get
out yeah something like that anyway I
don't want to play a game where my role
is to keep gungans
alive
right oh BOS pretty
annoying and also all of the other
gunguns I'm
sorry could we just do a quick straw
Paul Who hat all
gunguns
oh who thinks ja is a
Sith I told you it was a real Theory I
told you I believe you it's just
silly heaven forbid Star Wars be
silly so you you played this game no I
oh okay this was just a Google entry you
didn't because you're racist oh space
racist space racist space racist it's a
different thing it's a different thing
spaceist that's it yeah I'm spaceist um
but there's this whole slew of the
proper what you think of when you say a
licensed game where it's like it's a
math game with Jabber real thing it's
Yoda stories which stays
awful see we had Yoda stories installed
on our uh Primary School computers and
so uh as a as growing up as a as a heavy
child uh that was where I spent most of
my life breaks um was on the uh on the
school on our classroom computer leading
him around old uh is it D it is dager
right pretty sure it's D yeah
yeah is yod this isn't the math
adventure this is Yoda's procedural
chore hell
basically oddly I want to play
that
Massac and won't replay dark Forces
yeah okay okay let's talk about it now
um could we get clip three oh no
yeah it is
unavoidable we will witness the
destruction of the
alliance and the end of this
insignificant
Rebellion soldiers of the Reel
Alliance this is our most desperate hour
[Music]
you are our only
[Applause]
hope Focus your attack on the
Walker run
re for the Rebellion don't get in my way
sh
up that won't happen
again come
on prevent the walkers from reaching the
[Music]
space your Victory will be short
lived
now it's my
[Music]
turn blast them into
submission with
[Music]
us
your pathetic Rebellion ends
[Applause]
here dear God that's a good
[Music]
trailer so that trailer is so good it
makes me want to play Battlefront again
oh my God I was getting chills at the
beginning it's so good and like when uh
that rebel pilot looks at the uh at the
Millennium Falcon you're like that's
that's me that's me oh like it's so good
I don't even care about the slightly
wrong
voices they're pretty jarring You' got
for the fact that Palpatine was never on
the forest Moon of Endor I'm just
pointing that out I don't know I down
I'm sure he went down there at some
point just to be like let's paint that
wall grayer or
something um that one is a 73 on meta
score and H's a score of
five that's L out of out of a 100 yes
five out of 100 damn no 5.0 oh okay okay
that that's slightly better um what went
wrong with
Battlefront I think it's boring design
for children that's that's
interesting
um yeah it I I I will agree with that I
think I think Heroes I play Star Wars
games not to play as a Jedi I don't like
playing as a Jedi they're boring Jedi
are too powerful it's like playing as
Superman don't want to do it I want to
play as a Smuggler or I want to play as
a rebel or I want to play as like a
lowly nothing person person who's in
this massive universe and had my own
adventure and when I run around the
battle the battlefield I guess cuz dice
make that too um I like I want to feel
like I'm part of something bigger I
don't want to be the the the like the
the the winning to to be able to turn
the tide I want to like be able to be
part of something bigger like part of
like the galactic War that's what I want
and yeah I don't so you saying you want
single player well who's played
Battlefield one
so if they took the campaign from
Battlefield 1 and literally just put
Star Wars [__] in it and had you go on
around the Galaxy my God it would be
amazing I totally agree I I would bet
money that Battlefield 2 will have a
single player campaign definitely
definitely it wouldn't be hard for them
to do the same thing that Battlefield
one did and do it effectively just on
different planets that would be really
cool and then you can do like any time
period you can you can do all kinds of
cool [__] and also like I know everyone
hates the prequels but the prequels had
some great design in them like the nabo
star fighter stuff like that I wanted
that I don't want to just like B around
in an X-Wing and a freaking awing I'm so
bored like stop talking what you don't
like Theo star Fighters I'm saying stop
talking [__] about x-wings but also yes
I love an X I love a good X-Wing they're
great but come on I want I want to I
want some change I don't want you know
walkers on every planet I want something
that's that's unique to each planet
stuff like that so the reason I like
Star Wars and I guess most people do is
because uh I I like weird as [__] aliens
sorry sorry yeah I just like very very
strange things existing and I think Star
Wars does a very good job of not giving
you too much Exposition it's like this
is a thing that exists this is what it
does I'm not going to tell you anything
else figure it out and I love that and I
love how well Star Wars does that in a
multiplayer only game you don't get any
of that they could have even put lore
into the multiplayer maybe but they
didn't
uh but this I feel like this isn't
productive how how would they make what
could they have done gameplay-wise to
make you guys like Battlefront more um
this
single sounds like a really lame thing
but aim down sides aim down sides make
the maps just a little bit smaller I I
think it's it's who it came from it's
Dice and you think dice doing Star Wars
Battlefront it's going to be like
Battlefield with with a DL 44 and it
wasn't it was just liked yeah it almost
felt like they' done the first pass and
they were like and we're going to put in
all this other stuff and then they're
like should be R out of time um every
time a Star Wars game gets announced
that isn't a narrative driven RP G I am
incredibly disappointed and think they
wasting their time okay so you're a big
force on
Leaf there are
[Laughter]
exceptions that is
true absolutely
yeah the I on
a
want
and kind of feels like genocide really
do you think that was uh something that
happened because it was Star Wars maybe
because so many people love Star Wars so
more people probably bought Battlefront
that probably wouldn't play Team
Shooters it's funny though because all
of the beautiful stuff and it what is
that word they kept using in their
marketing photogrammetry ridiculous but
uh all of the assets are just taken from
existing assets so it's like what did
you do really like I don't think it's a
bad
game
yeah and then we had like six months
before DLC and everyone bought the
season pass was just waiting sadly for
things to actually come out and so is
there is there a way to fix Battlefront
one so like if if there was an update
that could come out now that you would I
I am so ready for the X-Wing VR
experience you tried that incredible
there are two Star Wars VR experiences
that I know of right now one of them has
you repair the Millennium Falcon and
there's a little bit of lightsaber
combat which in VR is cool as hell
because you're using like a VI an Oculus
controller and just sort of tilting it
while the lightsaber makes noises every
single time you move it feels amazing
the other one is you're sitting inside
this X-Wing you can like look around in
the cockpit and it's really really small
but it's just it's Star Wars is almost
perfect for VR and I would love to see
way more of
that that is a hard group to design for
between 4 and 40 I mean how you can't
make a good game that's going to appeal
to everyone there unless an EA kind of
thing though you know with Dead Space 3
they were like well make it less scary
so more people will play it and that
just made everyone who loved Dead Space
really angry yeah same as Star Wars St
Wars
CI
no I'd like a game I can play not a game
I wait
for I say this as a pledge so
yeah fair enough um sorry just a
housekeeping if you guys want to ask
questions there are mics on the side
it's going to be easier for us so que up
if you want um we're going to keep
goinging and talking
um I like the idea of Forex Star Wars
but I don't think it's ever been done
well because that's not the stuff that
gets explored in the fiction and the
narrative yeah Star Wars is about
exploration it's not at all like the
universe is known the bounds of it are
pretty much set but I know what you mean
yeah yeah um like um just a tabl toop
game which was based off an old PC game
Rebellion is amazing so good go buy it
now like well after the panel after the
panel go by it it's awesome please don't
leave um should over here sorry I was
just going to say on Forex but you then
just said Rebellion rebellion was a
really good basically Forex if you took
away the space combat but but then you
just you're
right we
agree great pop
in I'm
tall I just wanted to say something
about for Unleashed which was I liked
the PS2 version a lot better I don't
know if anyone played it on the PS2 but
I didn't even know there was a PS2
version there was more content in that
game really you had more levels more
costumes way more story and cutcenes it
was basically just a really shitty
looking Platinum game that didn't have
quite as much intriguing combat as a
platinum game I don't think anyone
really hated the first one the first no
I remember that coming out and people
into play a PC which might be my first
problem like the first one like after
the PS2 and it was all right but I felt
like I could feel the less content after
playing the PS2 version first which was
really weird cuz usually like in that uh
era the one that was on the older
console was the one that had less in it
but it was the reverse for Force
Unleashed one and I just always found
that really
interesting it was some kind of deal
some kind of exclusivity deal with uh
Playstation yeah probably it happens uh
TF you 2 is the game that I got right
towards the end and then realized that
life was too short to bother finishing
this game and I really probably only had
about 10 minutes to go and I was like
yeah n we're done and it was just it was
that wildly disappointing from what
could have been a very promising game
how long from the end you were like a
half hour in you realized you were 10
minutes from the end yes yeah
just that connect game though guys oh no
no not yet what are we doing oh no it's
it's fine we're going to do this now
could we get number four please we're
going to make you watch all of this oh
oh I know what we're
doing
[Music]
no
every oh
God
[Music]
[Applause]
scaring see all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
so Star Wars connect was a thing oh boy
um just a just a uh funny little thing
um when I started a Gamespot um when
we're making videos we do lower Thirds
with people's names our template is that
and I hear that song every time I make a
lower third for someone and it is I see
it every day and it's it's it it haunts
my dreams that quick of and also the
worst part is whoever's dancing isn't
very good at it so his legs keep
lighting up and I'm just like oh I could
do this better I could have done this
better that one say 55 on Metacritic but
my favorite part of this is uh the top
review is in 80 and it says to anyone
expecting a poor dance game yes there is
dancing
I think my favorite part of that is
paying Jason dero to use that song and
changing the lyrics like imagine being
the person who wrote that like that's on
his resume so all her resume it's like
the bad idea is just highlighted in
yellow highlighter
yeah who's who is it that uh wrote Fat's
bed um MC Chris MC that's a really good
song and his ig88 song's really good too
just see as one of
those I don't have an answer for you I'm
sorry I mean it kind of has a place in
my heart because it's so ridiculous like
it's such a dumb idea oh it's incredible
so here we've got this amazing kind of
world of Star Wars how about we find out
with the Han Solo can dance or not it's
such a nuts idea that I feel like you
probably it probably wouldn't happen now
now that Disney's got Star Wars I don't
think you're ever going to see a dancing
game with like Ray in it oh Never Say
Never Man H it's on its way it's just
yeah it's just so strange of course I'm
just started wondering solo wouldn't
dance like that so now I'm wondering
would he dance I feel like he'd got to
be like an edge of the dance ball kind
of guy right cuz he's too cool to dance
he yeah he waits he waits for everyone
to come dance with him and then he's
like all right let's get this party he
the kind of Lando totally Lando I think
Lando dances I think Lando definitely I
think H solo is Saturday Night Fever I
think he's
really I'm going the other way man he
cannot dance that's what I'm saying it's
a Carbonite injury he can't do it
[Laughter]
anymore um we have obviously missed some
very bad games so we would love to hear
what your least favorite Star Wars games
are if you want to shout some
out the Phantom menis tiin the one that
was on PC I'll fight you on that cuz
it's amazing I love that
game I don't know what that
is really
in year8 um on my uh uh laptop at home
in my room and I thought it was the best
you you har bad opinions I can see this
no I definitely do yeah it's it's it's
foolish cuz they're all tired to a very
do they let you review games for games
no thank God CU I would give everything
a 10 everything would be
amazing hi uh this isn't uh my one of my
least favorite games is actually a game
that was uh very close to me and I would
like to hear you all talk about Star
Wars
Galaxies oh
good call yeah um did anyone he play
Star Wars Galaxies a little bit I didn't
pre or post the
massive yeah yeah um so before the big
change it was epic like had weird
systems you could dance to heal people
there were three different
tracks ah good point um it's over um um
yeah it it had it was probably one of of
the greatest most involved MMOs uh and I
think because of that it was its own
yeah worst enemy it it was just too much
to do but then they went the opposite
direction and they created uh World of
Warcraft with Wookies
um yeah yeah I'd love to see it done
right and I don't think necessarily kns
the Old Republic is it I want you know
modern Star Wars properly but yeah I
mean that's actually a really good
question what would your uh all of your
ideal Star Wars games be
um I know what mine is
yeah wow
R yeah hands up for remake of
X-Wing yeah okay we're done here thanks
guys I I feel like uh Naughty Dog Star
Wars could be pretty
rare that was that's that's exactly my
perfect game you play as a Smuggler and
you're not a Jedi you're nothing
important and it's it's I mean it's easy
to say Mass Effect Star Wars that's like
cheating but I feel like something
darker like if it were more the Lar you
really like aliens don't you I really
like aliens all those aliens I kissed in
Mass
Effect uh I'm not sure whether this is
actually the worst Star Wars game but
the Clone Wars game because I played it
for like 3 weeks without a memory card
so I just have to keep playing the same
two levels over and over again so it
wasn't that bad look I don't want to say
you did that to
yourself I was eight yeah okay you did
it to
yourself does anyone remember super
bombad Racing for the
PS2 the worst cart racer ever on the
PS2 I will say there was a worst Star
Wars racing game and it's was it Star
Wars
demolition I like that what's what's
Star Wars demolition it's demolition
derby with Star Wars that Mak sense
right yeah it was just I I don't know
why it existed was it in space or was it
like on the ground like
racing yeah exactly and I think so yeah
you know it's of the Old Republic too to
was one of the few games that you can
actually review the cut scenes after
You' unlock them and if you play through
light side and you play through Dark
Side the ending was exactly the same the
planet blew up no matter whether you
choose LIF side or dark side cuz they
never finished the game that really
annoyed me that spoilers by the way guys
um it is a BioWare game yeah I was going
to say Mass Effect 3
anyone there's still a lot to forgive
about the cotor games they are very good
they are and that would be my ideal one
is number
three so I just want to say first I will
fight you on Star Wars demolition cuz
that game was awesome you could unlock
the raner and the cloud car and it was
sick going to fight I'm not going to
fight you could eat people with the r
you literally ate people wait hang on
you could play as a ranor yeah okay
that's actually really
cool it it was so okay so apparently my
ideal game is now remaking Star Wars
demolition yeah oh it was
awesome ranor VR that's what I
want that sounds like motion sickness
waiting to happen I've I've never played
a better demolition game than Star Wars
is it the only one you play a big
CL um anyway you were saying my other
option my other thing was
um uh my ideal like Star Wars game this
might exist and I just don't know about
it but like a a Star Wars muso game like
Dynasty Warriors I think would be really
interesting because I feel like that's
basically what the Star Wars movies are
in like big battles it's like
Luke cutting down like 50 bajillion St
like the original I guess it's more of
like a new thing yeah and that's and
that's why I think the prequels fail is
cu everyone's so powerful and there
there's so many so many lasers and
because and yeah I'm going to say this
right now you use the force for
knowledge and defense and not attack
right y have said that Yoda said that I
just want to point out sorry Star Wars
demolition actually had a backstory
um that the Empire officially bans
Jabba's pod races so jabber decides to
create a more life-threatening contest
also also when Galactic legal code in
Star Wars is really
strange all the time so I just wanted to
mention when you're picking a car in
that game in Star Wars demolition the
voice that when you pick a car is way
too seductive like it's creepily
seductive can we can we get an
impression
no ranor
oh do you still have your Dreamcast so
you can play this I've played it on the
PS1 oh okay all right good but I mean
the superior console so we're not here
to do
that we
just oh okay thank
you I remember it being a bit offbeat
when it first came out for PS2 but um
what did everyone think of Bounty Hunter
like the the Standalone game thought
that game was very funny I thought it
was weird but I I enjoyed it when I
played it
I think you can get it on PS4 actually
can you I think it's available for digal
PSN yeah yeah um and it has an aged
great no it it doesn't look great but I
didn't hate that game I didn't hate it
so that was good being able to like lock
onto two separate targets with two
pistols is the coolest thing I've ever
done like playing as a bounty hunter
like I think that's really rad I'd like
to kind of needed its own game in a way
but also what did you guys think did you
hear about the canel just touching on
from earlier the Darth the cancel Darth
Mall game do you think they would have
really messed that up or I guess it
depends on who would have made it no
idea yeah that's a
shame himself yeah isn't Darth more like
a scorpion
now
while is that Canon I think it is Canon
yeah Rebel yeah so it is technically
Canon spoilers again sorry sorry sorry
yeah nice he is vad Luke's
dad this isn't so much a bad game but
what did you think about Galactic
Battlefront the Age of Empire
clone made me angry I I I never had Age
of Empires 2 I I went straight from Age
of Empires 1 to this so for me it was
great and I went back to Age of Empires
2 and I'm like where's flying units Age
of Empires 2 missing flying units yeah
yeah yeah what do you think about who
was I hated it I feel like I look I
didn't like Age of Empires to begin with
so look that's my bad opinion um but it
didn't yeah I know yeah but it just
didn't feel like Star Wars it just felt
like you know unit stacking and that's
nothing I associate with Star Wars so
just didn't feel
right you stacking
yes what about their other attempts at
RTS like Empire at
War yeah for Commander the whole kind of
build up your base and then send swarms
of dudes in it doesn't say Star Wars to
me like doesn't mean those games are bad
though think they could do something
like dawn of War II where it's Squad
based small units or something like I
just feel like that's such an easy way
to make a Star Wars game is to have
Starcraft and reskin it like obviously
that would be great but it it isn't what
a lot of people want from a Star Wars
game uh sure it it would sell and it
could work but it's easy simple doesn't
require the World building that a lot of
people really love about Star Wars yeah
it's not touching on what makes Star
Wars unique or interesting it's just
putting a Star Wars skin on it as you
said like it's a thing that people come
back to a lot but the idea that the Star
Wars universe is so different to the Tre
Universe because it feels lived in it
feels old it feels aged and damaged and
something that's been around um and the
idea of putting your buildings on a map
doesn't seem to jive with that for me
c okay that
be Sol Empire the mod for it the Star
Wars mod yeah yeah that's pretty good
but again you yeah and mod makers will
always make the yeah
yeah and then just added all
that you can do that with most things
like the guy who said Dynasty Warriors
before I feel like um that would even
work really well there's a I don't
remember if it's actually Dynasty
Warriors but there's basically a game
like that that's Gundam in space and
it's the coolest thing in the world but
it's still you could do that to Star
Wars but you could also do the last of
us to Star Wars I do
like so like you want something
character driven right yeah totally 100%
yes they are doing that but we don't
really know much about it yet just over
here oh just did anyone play Jedi power
battles because I played that on the
original console and then not owning one
myself tried it on a PC emulator and it
was just as
janky
shocking you
yeah uh one thing I remember when I was
a kid uh was on the PC there was a game
called Droid Works um it was a game
based on on all the droids from the Star
Wars universe and um it was really
strange and really clunky um does anyone
remember it that was the one where you
built droids out of different parts I
think I had that at school I think that
was on PC in my primary school you see I
actually had the physical play set that
it was kind of inspired by this weird
Brown lump of extruded plastic with
random Droid parts that didn't go
together very well which pretty much
also describes the game I
think but seriously there are so many
goddamn Star Wars games I didn't even
realize yeah so many
yeah the old republ yes the
MMO yeah yeah the the MMO yeah
M I think that again I just wanted that
to be more of a single player experience
in an MMO but the first 10 levels of so
were great I
thought would you like to um come down
and talk to the we can't really hear you
yeah n Sunday afternoon at packs um
again it's my problem and this is my
problem with I guess the prequels
tonally I don't like swarms of Jedi it
seems wrong yeah totally there shouldn't
be like armies of them running around
waving their lightsabers being like yeah
that's not what Jedi do you know no and
and it's one of the big things with tfu
is that was saying before when when Luke
can you know use the force to grab his
lightsaber that's really exciting when a
when a Jedi is tearing a star destroyer
out of the sky that's just to boring how
did you guys ever lose seriously
yeah I've never played this game but
have you guys played Republic Commandos
public
commando just want you to know that the
guy behind noted at you I've got it uh
on my Xbox original but I still haven't
played it so it's great um but it hasn't
aged terribly well but I think that's a
thing with old Shooters in General on
Console to haven't aged very well does
it look as good as Star Wars Obi-Wan did
when we saw that
before speaking of those games where
you're just like the front flipping Jedi
cuz you're always a front flipping Jedi
I don't know why you guys are
complaining about that I think it's cool
as
[__] cuz the Yoda fight scene is the
worst thing to ever happen to Star Wars
is why flips are rad you
the worst thing to happen in Star Wars
yeah the worst the worst oh I don't know
man this is POD racing is pretty
bad are you an
angel that's pretty bad how do you feel
about sand sorry I said how do you feel
about sand you not like
sand yeah yeah all right so it's all so
it's all well and good to sit here and
just hate on Star Wars games sure what
the which is fun don't get me wrong it
is fun to break it down good question
thanks but let why not talk about like
some of the positives some like some of
the games that make us feel really good
cuz we all love Star Wars while we're
here absolutely so why not break down
what we love about some of these games
and then create our perfect Star Wars
game from it well I'm a massive tabletop
gamer as well as a video gamer and
fantasy flight's current range of Star
Wars games is incredible like X-Wing
models dog fights better than any other
board game I've ever played armad is
great the card game is just like the
last B of the
EU Imperial assault is perfect because
it's like a campaign based small Squad
of characters is Imperial assault the
one with all the figures yeah they're
amazing as well I wish they were scaled
they're not but they're God they look
good um so yeah absolutely good Star
Wars games out there but they're all I'm
really excited about the Star Wars games
that are yet to come out I think there
are three Star Wars games in development
right now or two maybe that from what I
know are going to be amazing so we're
headed in the right right direction I
think and I think you know if we do get
that Amy Henning Star Wars game salt
just
100% but something that I I think we're
all touching on is we want a single
player campaign we want a story we don't
want multiplayer we we don't want uh I
think the reason they haven't done that
is because it's harder you know and it's
if you screw up the story in a Star Wars
game people will hate you more than they
would hate a multiplayer game being bad
that's a lot of pressure yes um
so got like remastered recently and I've
been playing it for like the nth time
what if they skin Star Wars into Skyrim
the whole open mods people have done
that yeah but like you know instead of
modding Skyrim to Star Wars but built
like from scratch a star war Skyrim open
world game with the whole character
progression
RPG I I think that kind of thing would
be almost exactly what we're
after tailor story that we'd like but
yeah I'd play the hell out of that kind
of Star Wars game without doubt won't
let you play anything a Smuggler or a
Jedi totally but that said I think you
could put pretty much all of my favorite
properties and put them in the Skyrim
and I would be happy like if you could
put Pokemon in
[Laughter]
that yeah yeah yeah um I'm just um we're
talking about the positives and one of
the positives for me was TI fighter was
one of the best PC games um if sequ or
X-Wing as especially when it went to it
didn't it followed the movies but it
also went to that expanded universe like
Grand Admiral fror came into it as well
that was the first time I saw Grand man
FR and then oh there's books that follow
this on too um I I still play this game
on dosbox and it's fantastic it still
holds up it's still it's you know a bit
clunky but it's still beautiful why
wouldn't developers kind of go back to
that go that PC flight Sim kind of look
for um I think that's going to happen in
our VR like I imagine that someone is
proba working on that I mean even arcade
games have done really good jobs of that
I don't remember what it's called but
the arcade uh is it I don't I don't
remember the name of it but it it's just
you flying through the Death Star and it
works really isn't that St okay I'm
pretty sure that's what it's called is
yeah yeah it's just it's really really
good and it's like I think that you just
need racing Sims especially if we're
going to have it as technically accurate
as Star Wars is kind of Niche it's Star
Wars so it's huge but I feel like
putting it in VR is the perfect way to
continue that and I feel like someone's
got to be doing it for sure one of the
great memories of T is remembering all
the all every keyboard button was an
actual thing to do like reverse Shields
and it was
fantastic so so that was um Empire
Strikes Back on Atari who here has
played Empire Strikes Back on Atari yeah
such a small am of people it's crazy
yeah uh I was mostly wondering what your
opinion was because since it's no longer
Lucas Arts doing the games it's going to
be EA and they're just farming it out uh
your opinion on EA's General approach to
DLC for everything like battlefronts a
key Point like that's how they make
money for the most part yeah that's the
thing so you're really positive about
this yeah well publish um it still
depends on the studio I mean the biggest
thing with EA that you have to remember
is that they are I think still the
highest grossing publisher which means
that they have stakeholders who demand
things of them so that's why you know I
mentioned Dead Space 3 not being scary
before that probably wasn't a developer
decision that would have been a
stakeholder decision we want to sell
more units and I think they also give
them really tight deadlines and EA does
that where maybe they wish they could
have put more content in the game but
stakeholders are like we want this to
come out at this point in time so it has
to be DLC and I I don't want want to
ever blame Developers for that but it is
a thing that EA is known to do that
continues to happen and people
complained about it enough with
Battlefront that I'm just hoping that
they take that feedback because I mean
the season paths thing I think is just
ridiculous people paid a lot of money
and had to wait a really long time for
Content not even knowing what it was
like that's just terrible for consumers
and they have noticed so I'm hoping that
it just
changes it's just hope that EA gets
better yeah maybe stop buying season par
people stop doing it also stop
pre-orders yeah preorders all right I
thought it'd come up uh for Star Wars
Old Republic I personally really like it
because it has both aspects of single
player and also group so they have the
heroics and everything that you can do
and events that you can play as a group
or a guild because I have a team we're
on team speak and so we have a lot of
fun interacting with each other but then
if we can't get on at the same time we
also have class missions so we do a lot
of single play as well and so I think
they've done a great job of intertwining
the two yeah I feel like that's one of
the better received solos games and I
really like it but are you still playing
it yeah how many people are still
playing swal you know what I we did lose
some like even our team is cut down by
about 10 people but they're going to
come back because the expansion's coming
back so I think they play it through and
then another expansion comes out and
then they'll be coming back and we'll
team up for the big events again it just
I feel like it died off pretty quickly
because uh well as someone who mentioned
before it was good at the start but then
go repetitive kind of towards the end
well a lot of people didn't like the
single player so Lewis he's a he's
engineer at Dell and he left the game
because he doesn't like the single
player so it's kind of hard to meet both
uh you know aspects but I think they've
done a fabulous job and I really like it
yeah I think visually and tonally it
feels very very good it feels like Star
Wars I just wasn't a huge fan of the
actual mechanics of gameplay to a degree
oh yeah they've got great story line so
they do
have it is also really good for
accommodating uh social situations I
think that's a much better social game
than Battlefront is 100% yeah yeah and I
think it's something that's worth
remembering about Star Wars we keep
talking about you know a single player
experience but Star Wars in terms of the
films is about groups hanging out being
absolutely totally and that's something
that a lot of Star Wars games don't do
they don't give you a small group yeah
so I think that's where galaxies
galaxies um Old Republic really works
well
yeah hey guys look I'm just hit a check
Rogue Squadron uh
obviously from that obviously the best
uh action scenes in Star Wars are the
starf fighter battles and some of the
best games obviously the best are the
starf fighter games so X-Wing TIE
fighter x-ing best TIE fighter and Rog
Squadron uh uh do you think that this
this fantasy of the Jedi and the fact
that we all kind of want to be Jedi is
kind of like the underlying problem of
Star Wars games is the Jedi fantasy
ruining I want to be a
SI I think an assumption that we all
want to be Jedi I don't think we all
want
wed like I always wanted to be Han Solo
man that dude was wicked cool I'd go I'd
go Bounty Hunter I reckon Bounty Hunter
Smuggler
yeah yeah and I I do think that that's
one of the big problems is they focus on
Jedi and they don't focus on the rest
all the other cool [__] that they've got
I mean like who's super super excited
for rogue
one yes right awesome um and again cuz
it's focusing on the other parts of the
universe it's not making the
whole I think he's like force sensitive
I don't know if he's a Jedi I mean yeah
force in it
you well yeah that one well I mean
darth's always the exception right like
if you can be Darth be Darth
but one of my um favorite parts of Jedi
Academy was that you could avoid
murdering people by mind tricking your
way past or pulling the weapon out of
their hand and sort of taking the ammo
out of the gun do you have any
recommendations for games like that
since then it's not totally similar but
my oh Don is a very good example my
favorite uh game that does that is The
Witcher 2 actually pretty much every
single interaction in that game you can
talk someone out of fighting you so it
also has this Fork at very early on in
the game where it just completely
changes two totally different stories
you can play it through a bunch of
different times but almost every single
boss fight you can be like hey I don't
actually want to fight you and talk
people out of it um you have to be
really careful with your dialogue
decisions but it's not a skill tree
based thing like Mass Effect we have to
have like high Charisma or anything
whichard two is a very good game should
definitely play that no Force we got
time for one more I
think um this is a bit of a can of worms
but you were talking about how you have
the Battlefront experience you've got
the tour experience one is very the
groups are not a very train uh transient
whereas tour is by its nature you
establish a guild and you play with the
same people over and over have we lost
something in moving multiplayer away
from dedicated servers which kind of
foster the
communities
yes yes immediately looking at David for
that one yeah absolutely I'm dedicated
servers are just are great for you have
a server with a set of server rules uh
you can control who comes comes in comes
out you have an admin who can kick out
idiots you can foster the right kind of
community that you want yeah I think
that's very very important
absolutely
yeah okay but there's also examples of
uh I know I was playing Left for Dead
one and when left the Dead 2 came out it
just completely split the community they
should have just added the maps to left
Dead one which meant that you know there
were people playing both games
separately and it's we have a lot of
Star Wars games so they've already
divided people who like Star Wars a
million times at that point anyway
there's just so many
and none of them seem de cater to many
of us
entirely true yep uh any more final
questions okay I'd like to thank
everyone who was up here we have no
conclusion sorry we don't like
up we got to get out of here
um Na dog that's conclusion and also the
demolition remake demolition remake no
this was really cool though thank you
everyone
for
[Applause]
time and what grand scheme you've got
underway
Delila we'll take it
all but I'm coming to put you in your
grave
So It
[Music]
[Applause]
Begins
hello
for
e
yeah
sad
live thank you
thank